jamais 203 la France est en grève
aujourd'hui enfin la France une partie
en tout cas troisième journée de
manifestation contre la réforme des
retraites quel sera l'ampleur de la
mobilisation c'est l'éternel question
matin de ces grands raousts sociaux
figarolive il est 14h et 7 minutes
bonjour bienvenue vous ne raterez rien
de cette journée tous les spécialistes
viendront nous éclairer sur la situation
aujourd'hui on commence avec vous
François-Xavier bonjour bonjour Thibault
grand porteur au service politique du du
Figaro j'ai plein de questions mais
d'abord je voudrais qu'on aille sur sur
le terrain Damien Canivez nous attend il
est place de l'Opéra c'est de là que
débute la manifestation
il y a du monde faites-nous le parcours
Damien
écoutez il y a énormément de monde là où
je me trouve tout simplement parce que
je me trouve au niveau de la tête de
cortège je suis au niveau du croisement
de trois grands boulevards le boulevard
Poissonnière vers lequel on est en train
de se diriger le boulevard Haussmann
cher Thibault que vous connaissez bien
puisque le Figaro se trouve à cet
endroit là et je me trouve également au
niveau du boulevard Poissonnière voilà
c'est vraiment le croisement des trois
boulevards et je me trouve très
particulièrement effectivement au niveau
de la tête de cortège où on a vu toutes
les personnalités syndicales rassemblées
Laurent Berger le leader de la CFDT le
leader de la CGT également Frédéric
Martinez et Frédéric Souillot de FO pour
ne citer que et là la manifestation
vient de partir à l'instant difficile de
savoir s'il y a beaucoup de monde pour
l'instant parce que normalement la
manifestation devrait s'élancer devait
se lancer au niveau du de l'Opéra qui se
trouve à 100 mètres d'ici l'opéra à
l'Opéra Garnier et manifestement il y a
pas mal de monde alors les autorités
maximum 70 000 personnes les remontées
de terrain indique que la manifestation
pour l'instant est en baisse est-ce que
ces chiffres-là vont être atteints bon
on saura ça en fin de en fin de journée
tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
il y a une un itinéraire qui est prévu
aujourd'hui de 4 km qui passe donc à
partir du boulevard Montmartre donc là
on s'élance vers le boulevard Montmartre
ensuite on passera vers le boulevard de
Bonne Nouvelle alors pour les Parisiens
enfin pour les Français qui n'habitent
pas Paris ce sont les boulevards où il y
a beaucoup de lieux de culture vous
savez il y a le Grand Rex le théâtre du
Gymnase enfin c'est le grand boulevard
en réalité ensuite on rejoindra la place
de la République ou la manifestation du
19 janvier dernier à rassemblée de
nombreux Français et on se dirigera
ensuite par le boulevard du Temple
direction la place de la Bastille ou la
manifestation s'arrêtera merci d'avoir
été reprenez votre souffle vous allez
4h30 à tenir je vous le dis tout de
suite jusqu'à voilà donc la place de la
Bastille François-Xavier 3e round quels
sont les enjeux aujourd'hui faire encore
mieux alors oui oui il y a effectivement
un enjeu de mobilisation qui est un peu
plus compliqué à tenir parce que en
province il y a les vacances scolaires
qui ont commencé par endroits donc c'est
pas facile de mobiliser pendant les
pendant les vacances mais en tout cas
l'enjeu c'est de montrer une
mobilisation qui ne faiblit pas voir qui
progresse
sachant que si la mobilisation devait
faiblir dans les endroits où il y a pas
de vacances
ce serait
le risque serait que elle seradicalise
en général quand les quand les
manifestations mobilisent moins de moins
de personnes et bien il reste que les
plus motivés et qui sont en général un
peu plus radicalisés donc c'est c'est un
des des enjeux de la manifestation
parisienne en tout cas aujourd'hui pour
les syndicats de continuer à maintenir
une cortège une manifestation qui se
déroule en bon ordre dans le calme c'est
plutôt le cas lors première voilà il y a
pas eu par rapport à ce qu'on a pu
connaître notamment durant les gilets
jaunes il y a absolument aucun aucun
rapport ce matin en région visiblement
sont les premiers chiffres parce que
vous le savez les manifestations le
matin elles ont lieu en dehors de Paris
et puis d'après-midi c'est à la capitale
c'est une tendance durable une baisse
comme ça alors il y a peut-être un
premier effet de l'arrivée du texte au
Parlement qui commence à se faire sentir
puisque maintenant la bataille des
retraites elle se joue à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est là où vont se dérouler
les les débats pour 20 jours et donc le
passage de cette de cette réforme au
sein de l'Assemblée nationale peut se
traduire par une forme de démobilisation
ou en tout cas d'attentisme de la part
des opposants à la référence qui vont
sans doute voir ce qui ressort des des
débats et si l'on ressort quelque chose
pour pour voir s'il y a lieu ou pas de
maintenir la mobilisation donc en tout
cas là on est dans cette dans cette
étape là qui est importante où le débat
passe de la rue au simplement et la
caméra l'éclairage change un peu de
sujet je vous réagissez évidemment sur
YouTube sur Le Figaro.fr on passe
l'après-midi ensemble le gouvernement
est-ce qu'il regarde très attentivement
ce qui est en train de se passer cet
après-midi parce que j'ai la sensation
après les deux premières manifestations
qui ont été des réussites factuellement
il y avait du monde dans la rue
gouvernement n'a pas réagi bravo il leur
a dit bravo mais pas mieux pas de
proposition non non mais évidemment que
le gouvernement regarde très
attentivement ce qui se passe dans ce
qui se passe dans la rue si la
mobilisation grossit dans le un peu
comme ce qu'on avait vu entre la
première et la deuxième on était passé
de de millions à 2 millions 6 si je me
si je me souviens bien selon les
syndicats voilà selon oui oui selon les
syndicats
le ministère de l'intérieur d'un million
100 millions 300 voilà donc
il y avait une progression ce qui est
intéressant dans les chiffres que
fournissent les syndicats c'est le le
c'est aussi de leur part une une façon
de doser la montée en puissance de la
contestation donc évidemment que le
gouvernement regarde ce qui se passe
dans la rue elle va être attentif à un
éventuel essoufflement de cette de cette
mobilisation ce qui serait quoi qu'il
arrive bon signe pour lui vacances
scolaires ou pas vacances scolaires
puisque ça voudrait dire que on rentre
dans une dans une phase moins plateau
quelque chose qui commence à ressembler
à quelque chose de descendant une
question un peu provocatrice mais est-ce
que sans violence c'est manif ne servent
à rien on se souvient de l'épisode des
gilets jaunes il y avait beaucoup moins
de monde dans la rue dans l'ensemble du
du pays et pourtant Emmanuel Macron
avait réagi pourquoi parce que il y
avait une très forte violence on se
souvient des images à Paris à l'arc de
triomphe dans les beaux quartiers
parisiens alors le la question de la
violence dans les dans les gilets jaunes
si on le mettons là un petit peu de côté
ce qui est vraiment à
perturber le gouvernement pendant les
gilets jaunes c'est que c'était un
mouvement inédit et surtout dans lequel
il n'avait aucun interlocuteur ah c'est
ça voilà il y avait absolument personne
à qui s'adresser on a vu toutes les
tentatives des gilets jaunes à l'époque
pour faire émerger un leader on se sont
traduits par des par des échecs qui
n'acceptaient aucun leader les gilets
jaunes voilà donc le face à cette
adversaire sans visage le gouvernement à
l'époque à lâché des concessions parce
que ils savaient pas trop comment
c'était pas tellement la violence il y
avait des images très impressionnantes
comme tous les samedis des gaz
lacrymogènes des affrontements des
forces de l'ordre et des CRS qui se
faisaient cogner dessus oui mais le
gouvernement pas ça qui les a forcément
le plus inquiétant le gouvernement c'est
maintenir l'ordre
je suis surpris de coups de matraque ou
de de tir de flash-ball le gouvernement
s'est maintenir l'ordre ce qu'il sait
moins faire c'est négocier sans
interlocuteur ça c'est plus compliqué
d'accord alors là dans les
manifestations contre la réforme des
retraites il y a des interlocuteurs
réguliers depuis le début qui sont les
de position syndicale et dont on voit
bien que elles sont de toute façon
fermée mais il y a en tout cas des des
forces des forces vives qui sont sont là
et qui sont prêtes à débarquer à
Matignon ou à l'Élysée pour discuter il
y a un interlocuteur d'accord
identifié en face ils sont pas d'accord
donc c'est pas la question de la
violence voilà la question de la
violence ça peut perturber un mouvement
social mais ce qui est vraiment
important pour le pour l'exécutif c'est
d'avoir un acteur locuteur quelqu'un qui
sait en face pour discuter il y en a des
interlocuteurs même si la connexion est
parfois difficile entre Martinez
notamment de la CGT et Elisabeth borne
mais il vaut mieux puis en plus c'est
une des grandes des grandes stratégies
mais d'Emmanuel Macron en tout cas c'est
au moins ils sont d'accord sur les
désaccords voilà mais il a quelqu'un qui
parlait il y a quelqu'un en face avec
qui ça soit autour d'une table pour pour
parler juste pour constater un des
accords mais en tout cas il y a un
interlocuteur et ça c'est extrêmement je
suis content que vous soyez là
François-Xavier bourreau même si on
n'est pas d'accord même si on n'est pas
d'accord au moins il y avait quelqu'un
avec qui parler essayons de voir ce que
peuvent changer c'est journée de grève
évidemment parce qu'il y a une double
actualités c'est manifestation donc vous
voyez les images ici à Paris et puis ce
qu'il se passe à l'Assemblée est-ce que
certains députés peuvent être sensibles
à ce qui se passe dans la rue je pense à
ceux qui sont tangents les frondeurs de
la majorité qui hésiteraient à voter
est-ce que c'est manif là peuvent eux
ces députés qui peuvent faire la
différence à un moment un autre parce
que c'est très serré
dans le nombre de voix pour faire vos
tests est-ce que cela peut basculer du
côté de la rue et se dire et bien il a
une manifestation il y a un mouvement
populaire je ne vais pas voter ce texte
non mais évidemment parce que les
manifestants qu'on voit aujourd'hui à
Paris et dans les villes de province
et bien ce sont les mêmes que les
députés vont retrouver quand ils vont
retourner en circonscription sur les
marchés le samedi dimanche et qui vont
aller leur faire part de leur de leur
récrimination contre la réforme des
retraites donc évidemment que ce genre
de mobilisation ça peut avoir un poids
sur les sur les sur les députés parce
que les députés ils sont en première
ligne sur le terrain et c'est eux qui
encaissent la contestation
ne changeront pas d'avis tous ceux du RN
ne changeront pas d'avis à l'opposé ceux
de la majorité voteront une grande
partie votre a cette loi il y en a
combien qui sont peuvent faire la
bascule quoi une cinquantaine
soixantaine alors si on regarde dans le
sein au sein de la majorité on voit
effectivement qu'il y a des des coupes
François-Xavier Mathilde panot là
présidente du groupe la France insoumise
à l'Assemblée nationale prend la parole
on l'écoute on revient dans un instant
mon ordi avec ça là que on a quelqu'un
pour un duplex pour Interview d'accord
et voilà est-ce qu'on entend Mathilde
panot on va me dire en régie
on l'entend dans un instant en tout cas
on la voit on dira quand on peut avoir
le son de Mathilde panot qui a l'air
mobilisé
qui est en train de me dire va-t-il
panneau la réforme du gouvernement est
injuste c'est une parodie de débat que
nous avons écoutons
d'avoir les gains de productivité qui ne
soient pas engranger tous par les
dividendes et les actionnaires du CAC 40
qui se garde comme jamais mais bien par
la grande majorité du peuple français
c'est ce que nous demandait aujourd'hui
offrant c'est une question de partage
des richesses qui est posée donc elles
sont nos marges de manœuvre posez-les
plutôt au gouvernement quelles sont les
marges de manœuvre d'un gouvernement qui
entraîne faire une réforme qui est haïr
par 80% des Français 93% des actifs
l'ensemble des syndicats l'ensemble de
la nuit passe je pense que c'est plutôt
eux qui sont dans une situation
difficile que nous
merci à vous
aviez bien vu hein
les discours sont assez écrits quand les
positions sont figées comme ça c'est pas
tellement difficile de
faire de faire le sous-titre sans le
sans le son homme on voit on voit bien
en tout cas avec la présence des députés
aujourd'hui je vois pas bien où ils sont
dans le cortège ils sont
vraisemblablement pas à côté du Caritat
ou alors
nous voir qui suit la gauche Figaro
politique en reporter comme vous elle
est dans la manifestation et souvent
elle nous explique que
les personnalités politiques sont pas
toujours les bienvenus elle ne croise
pas les leaders syndicaux ça c'est un
petit jeu dans les manifestations
toujours intéressant à voir oui parce
que les les syndicats en profitent se
faire récupérer par les politiques et
puis les politiques voient passer le
magot et ont envie de se glisser un peu
au côté de tous ces tous ces
manifestants dont ils espèrent bien
retirer un bénéfice un bénéfice
politique mais en général les politiques
effectivement sont pas venues dans les
manifestations ou alors dans des très
très rares cas où le
en général c'est plutôt dans des
manifestations quand on les voit côte à
côte syndicat et politique où il y a pas
d'enjeu qui concerne directement le
monde du travail oui voilà c'est pour
prendre enfin
les manifestation après Charlie Hebdo là
il pouvait marcher main dans la main
c'était un enjeu national ou là il
comprend mais dans les manifestations là
vraiment on est sur une réforme du monde
qui touche le monde du travail les les
syndicats en front Unis s'affiche
ensemble en ouverture de cortège et aime
pas bien voir les politiques essayer de
récupérer derrière eux les foules qu'ils
ont réussi à mobiliser
les politiques qui n'arrivent pas
mobiliser autrement que les syndicats au
passage faut le noter donc on comprend
un peu le petit jeu qui se qui se joue
toujours
entre le voilà les les de la nups qui se
mettent sur le sur le bord du cortège
parce qu'ils peuvent pas rester absent
d'un tel manifestation mais qui ont les
a vu plus chahuter à d'autres périodes
souviens d'Olivier fort il y a deux ou
trois ans en arrière qui ne pouvait même
pas rentrer dans le cortège c'est
souvent un en plus de siffler les
politiques en général le les socialistes
souvent se font
voilà mais là c'est ils sont sur le bord
de la route apparemment à observé par
passer le cortège vous voyez Damien qui
a ni vs ce qu'on rejoindra également
dans un instant on parlait des
potentiels frondeurs au sein de la
majorité ceux qui pourraient ou non
basculer voter ou non cette réforme des
retraites alors qu'ils ont été élus avec
la bannière Renaissance il y a deux
choses qu'il faut séparer d'un côté
effectivement les députés qui sont un
peu fébrile ou qui voit bien que leurs
électeurs pourraient leur en vouloir de
de soutenir la réforme des retraites
donc bon ça ça député qu'on peut qu'on
peut comprendre et puis il y a il y a
ceux aussi qui voit un investissement
rentable à faire c'est à dire que quand
vous êtes dans une quand vous êtes
minoritaire au sein de la majorité
vous posez très lourd et vous pouvez
obtenir satisfaction pour les toutes vos
revendications c'est c'est
décale un petit peu c'est ce qui s'est
passé avec François Hollande lors du
quinquennat 2012-2017 lorsque lui avait
la majorité absolue et au sein de cette
majorité absolue il y avait un groupe de
frondeurs d'une trentaine de d'une
trentaine de députés qui
s'il faisait des flexions faisaient
passer le seuil de flottaison en dessous
de la majorité et oui et qui donc
négocier très cher le les les voix qui
les apportaient à Hollande pour pour
voter ses lois c'est il y a ça aussi qui
se joue au sein de la majorité c'est à
dire la tentation au sein de la majorité
relative de vente très cher les les voix
et ça se joue aussi au sein des
républicains qui eux sont la force
d'appoint bien sûr faire passer la la
réforme et au sein des républicains on
voit qu'autour de revient Pradier et ben
il y a une dizaine quinzaine de députés
qui eux aussi
veulent vendre leur voie très chère en
obtenant par la droite c'est étonnant
mais des concessions sociales on en
reparle dans un instant de ce qu'il se
passe à l'Assemblée nationale je vous
préviens également qu'à 15 heures début
des questions au gouvernement on suivra
ça en alternance vous aurez toujours les
images de la manifestation et on
écoutera ce qu'il se passe dans
l'hémicycle avec sans doute peu de
personnes sur les bancs de la gauche on
a vu beaucoup de députés de la nuit
parce qu'il était ici Damien canivevez
vous êtes dans la manifestation
qu'avez-vous de sous les yeux j'ai
l'impression que ce sont des
manifestants cagoulés
ce qu'on peut revenir en plateau et on
va continuer à discuter puisque
visiblement on a un problème de
connexion avec Damien Canivez on va
récupérer les images bien sûr alors oui
c'est député de la France insoumise
c'était un peu le bazar hier dans
l'hémicycle expliquez-moi ce qui s'est
passé alors là on est dans la pure
stratégie mélenchoniste mélenchonienne
il y a quelques années avant la montée
en puissance de la France insoumise
Jean-Luc Mélenchon avait expliqué à ses
à ses troupes il faut tout
conflictualiser c'est ça bordélisées
stratégies de de l'extrême gauche c'est
créer du conflit partout pour créer de
l'opposition et alors là sur une réforme
des retraites on peut pas on peut pas
tomber dans un meilleur champ
d'application de cette théorie c'est à
dire il faut absolument tout
conflictualiser dont la réforme des
retraites et hier à l'Assemblée
nationale les débuts de débats de débat
houleux enfin ont été d'autant plus ou
le que la France insoumise n'attend
absolument rien de cette réforme elle ne
veut pas faire passer d'abonnement elle
veut pas essayer de la modifier en quoi
que ce soit et elle a compris que de
toute façon quoi qu'il arrive elle
obtiendrait pas gain de cause donc ils
sont partis dans une stratégie
d'obstruction donc de bordélisation
selon le terme de Gérald Darmanin c'est
ça mais qui est qui là éclaté au grand
jour hier à l'Assemblée alors c'est ça
ça a commencé il y avait deux motions
c'est ça une motion référendaire oui
autour de là après on rentre dans la
essayons d'être concis sur ces pour pas
rentrer dans la technique au tactique de
l'Assemblée nationale mais deux motion
la France insoumise est déposée la même
motion que le rassemblement national
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
que ça arrivait hein c'est ça là
d'émotions référendaire deux motion
référendaire déposées sauf que la France
insoumise ne veut pas voter la motion
référendaire quand du texte qui sont
proposés par le RN voilà et bien ça
c'est une bataille technique ou au sein
de la technique parlementaire on est
aussi dans
l'ultra-conflictualisation tous les
sujets
la France insoumise et le rassemblement
national voulait soumettre le projet de
loi sur les retraites à un référendum
donc on déposé une
motion référendaire et qu'en deux
motions référendaires sont déposées
en conseil des présidents de l'Assemblée
nationale il faut choisir entre les
entre les deux il y a eu un tirage au
sort qui a vu le rassemblement national
gagné donc sa notion
référendaire du rassemblement national
qui sera présenté qui sera parfait
évidemment mais il y avait un enjeu
symbolique en tout cas et puis une
occasion une
occasion de de conflictualiser
du socle le ministre devait s'exprimer
pour lancer les débats il s'est
exprimait presque une heure plus tard et
alors tout ça en plus pour pour
pédaler dans la semoule parce que de
toute façon cette notion référendaire
n'aboutira pas donc c'est ce qu'on va
voir à l'Assemblée nationale pendant
toute la durée des débats jusqu'à
pendant une vingtaine de jours où tout
va être sujet à conflit rappelle aux
règlements enfin pour mais alors
d'accord François-Xavier vous me dites
que ils veulent tout conflictualiser
bordéliser comme le dit Gérald Darmanin
faire de l'obstruction parlementaire
finalement avec de très très nombreux
amendements déposés mais j'entends
partout qu'ils auraient un intérêt à ce
que ça accélère pour voter ce fameux
article 7 vous le pensez pas et
expliquez-nous ce qui est cet article 7
oui non
on n'est pas parti là-dessus en tout cas
c'est c'est non non là on est vraiment
dans une stratégie d'obstruction
l'idée de la France insoumise c'est de
rendre les débats totalement illisibles
ok voilà pour nourrir le ressentiment
contre la réforme alimenter l'idée que
ce texte serait voté sans débat sans
consultation de la représentation
nationale bref que ce serait le fait du
prince Emmanuel Macron et tout lui
mettre sur le dos donc le cette histoire
d'article 7 c'est exactement la même
chose que le la motion référendaire on
est dans l'idée de
tout rendre compliqué voilà
beaucoup de contestations de critiques
contre l'attitude de la France insoumise
et de la nupes dans cette examen de la
réforme des retraites il y a un point
positif qu'on peut souligner pendant la
crise des gilets jaunes dont on parlait
en début d'émission il y a eu beaucoup
de voix qui se sont élevées pour dire
mais voilà si les gilets jaunes avaient
été représentés à l'Assemblée nationale
et bien ils auraient pas été sur les
ronds-points parce que leur voix aurait
été portées dans le dans l'hémicycle
qu'est-ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui c'est
exactement l'application de cette
théorie les les gilets jaunes c'est pas
contestataire est représenté à
l'Assemblée nationale par cette partie
de la de la nupes qui est la France
insoumise et en fait ce qu'on voit là
hier à l'Assemblée nationale et c'est
les ronds-points occupés par les gilets
jaunes sauf que ça se passe dans le
cadre réglementé de l'Assemblée
nationale où il y a effectivement des
Bizzbee ou des des tensions très fortes
dans les débats mais c'est le lot commun
des des débats l'Assemblée nationale ça
prend un peu de
beaucoup d'ampleur parce qu'on a tous
les projecteurs regardent dessus mais
les débats l'Assemblée nationale ne sont
jamais très calmes bien sûr en tout cas
il se déroule dans un cadre défini les
rappels aux règlements la motion
référendaire c'est quelque chose qui
s'inscrit dans le règlement de
l'Assemblée nationale alors petit carnet
leur petit règlement à la mort mais la
la contestation pour virulente qu'elle
soit et aujourd'hui encadré alors
qu'elle ne l'était pas autant des gilets
jaunes le rôle de l'Assemblée nationale
pendant les gilets jaunes a été nul oui
il y a l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas du
tout servi d'exutoire ou en tout cas n'a
pas servi de de soupapes de produits on
peut essayer de récupérer le mouvement
ce qui était bonne guerre mais
à l'Assemblée nationale il s'est rien
passé sur les gilets jaunes là
aujourd'hui la la contestation s'exprime
dans un cadre
démocratique définie par la Constitution
il y a quelque chose qui est pas dire
réjouissant le terme est peut-être un
peu trop
peu trop fort mais en tout cas la
contestation est encadrée le problème
pour le gouvernement c'est si la
contestation des
rapsant en début d'émission là il y a
des syndicats il y a des interlocuteurs
si le gouvernement perd ses incopter le
cutter ou s'il a contestation sort du
cadre d'une manifestation encadrée par
des syndicats ou d'un débat même
virulent à l'Assemblée nationale ça
devient compliqué si ça débarque si ça
dérape dans la violence ou ce genre de
choses je vous libère dans un instant
François-Xavier j'ai une dernière
question le RN dans tout ça pas dans les
manifs pas accepté non mais peut-être
que la situation la fameuse des
diabolisation du RN n'a pas si bien
fonctionné que ça il n'arrive toujours
pas à aller dans ce genre de manif alors
qu'on imagine très bien qu'il y a
certains de leurs électeurs parmi le
million et demi de Français peut-être
dans la rue alors je vais vous citer
Jean-Marie Le Pen à allez-y qui disait
régulièrement du temps où il était
Front national ça sert à rien de
s'agiter quand il y a pas de vent dans
les voiles aujourd'hui il y a pas de
vent dans les voiles pour le
rassemblement national c'est-à-dire on
observe un petit peu ce qu'on avait
observé au début du premier quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est à dire une
France insoumise dans l'hémicycle qui
est extrêmement bruyante extrêmement
virulente qui fait le spectacle mais qui
n'obtient pas grand-chose pendant que
pendant ce temps le rassemblement
national essaye de capitaliser sur le
sur la contestation à l'époque en 2017
il y avait huit députés rassemblements
dans le ciel 189 aujourd'hui donc le
réveil risque d'être douloureux pour les
pour ceux qui oublieraient rassemblement
national parce qu'ils sont en train de
se préparer
ils ont fait preuve de une certaine
manière de sagesse face à l'agitation de
l'autre côté de l'hémicycle ils
attendent le vent et le vent c'est les
élections et les élections les
prochaines c'est en 2024 les Européennes
et pour l'instant il y a aucun intérêt à
Marine Le Pen a sorti sur le sortir dans
la rue ou essayer de récupérer ce
mouvement parce que en 2024 épisode l'un
des retraites il sera derrière nous et
on sera sur autre chose donc ça sert à
rien de sortir prendre des coups
maintenant en revanche capitaliser et ce
crédibiliser en ce moment c'est quelque
chose qui germera aujourd'hui qui
produira ses fruits demain ils attendent
le vent merci beaucoup françois-xavour
je vous souhaite bon vent d'ailleurs et
puis retourner au deuxième étage oui on
vous suit on livre papier on retrouve
Damien canivels qui est dans la
manifestation
Damien ce qu'il y a du monde vous en
êtes où ça avance parce qu'on sait que
d'habitude les les manifestations ont du
mal à se lancer à quitter leur lieu de
départ
ça marche c'était à propos de l'affaire
Benalla si vous voulez savoir ah oui
d'accord ok
non bah je vais pas vous laisser
tranquille vous avez pas envie
prochaine
salut
parfois pour l'instant elle a rien mais
elle vient d'être lancé voilà on est de
retour on a du mal à voir Damien
canivelle visiblement en dans la
manifestation mais c'est pas grave nous
sommes là nous en plateau avec nos
spécialistes et Christophe Cornavin nous
a rejoint rédacteur en chef adjoint un
service société du Figaro spécialiste
des questions de sécurité de
renseignement bonjour Thibault comment
ça va bon vous venez de faire les
prévisions de la météo syndicale
exactement le temps évolue un petit peu
en fait on reste un peu sur la même
configuration mais
il y a un peu c'est moins électrique que
la dernière épisode en tout cas au
niveau de au niveau de la de la
mobilisation ça c'est clair il y a bon
beaucoup enfin oui bien beaucoup moins
de monde on va en parler mais je veux
d'abord qu'on commence par les chiffres
ceux qui étaient envisagés hier par le
ministère de l'intérieur alors hier en
fait le ministère de la terre avait déjà
imaginé enfin prévu une amorce un reflux
léger c'est à dire entre 900 000 et 1
million
de de manifestants versus on s'en
souvient 1,2 millions pendant l'acte 2
c'était le 31 janvier dernier c'est à
dire on est à peu près les estimes à peu
près à 200 200 300000 personnes de moins
pourquoi pour des raisons assez simples
on est
en période de vacances scolaires donc il
y a la zone A avec des villes qui sont
assez fédératrices comme Lyon Bordeaux
clairement etc ils sont en vacances ok
donc ça c'est pas bon pour la
mobilisation
les services de renseignement
s'ils mettent cette démobilisation sur
le compte de peut-être d'un sentiment de
lassitude de la part des des
participants lassitude tout simplement
liée au fait que on est la troisième
journée nationale d'action en moins de
15 jours que l'on a samedi
celle qui se nouvelle qui se qui se
profile les gens
ça se traduit par une perte de salaire
donc bien sûr c'est pas rien voilà c'est
pas rien et donc
tout ça mi boit bouffe et qu'on est
vraiment sur un sentiment de
décélération d'ailleurs ça se ça se voit
ça
parce que vous avez les premières
remontées des chiffres de la matinée de
la matinée alors
les manifestations en région alors en
région alors on le sait les
manifestations à Paris c'est
l'après-midi et depuis début de cette
mobilisation le matin c'est en région
c'est le matin alors des grosses villes
comme Marseille oui ça a beaucoup moins
c'était beaucoup plus clairsemé que que
les que les fois précédentes
c'est-à-dire que à Marseille on était
entre
23000 et 26000 dans les deux dernières
éditions donc l'acteur acte 2 là on
descend à 15000 ah oui donc c'est à dire
que on a vraiment un effet de on perd
30% c'est ce que je vois à peu près
partout dans l'idée grosso modo c'est ça
mais parfois ça peut être ça peut être
un peu plus ouais comme Toulouse par
exemple dites-moi Toulouse
j'ai noté que on est à 24
000 manifestants ouais c'est 30%, 6 ça
fait 10000 de moins quand même que la
semaine dernière mais dans les petites
villes vous vous souvenez que oui alors
c'est ça vous me racontez et on aura
toujours des résultats du film data tout
à l'heure qui a recensé ces petites
villes et ses villes moyennes avec
beaucoup de monde avec un pourcentage de
la population très important dans chaque
ville et alors là ça continue ou pas a
priori bon c'est un peu moins fort que
que les que les fois précédentes par
exemple on prend des villes je prends
vraiment des villes à des seins pas
forcément des villes qui sont au cœur
des fonds sociales je crois Guéret dans
la Creuse par exemple
de Guéret dans la Creuse
on embrasse tous les habitants comment
on dit les guerres toi vais chercher
et en tout cas les guerres toi en tout
cas les habitants de Guéret étaient 2900
ce matin ce qui reste ce qui reste
vraiment quelque chose de assez
important ils étaient 4000 il y a il y a
il y a quelques quelques jours le 31
Pontivy pareille dans le Morbihan on est
à 3000 versus 4000 c'est-à-dire que à
peu près partout ça descend d'accord
alors mais en fait les il s'est quand
même des villes qui restent mobilisés et
pourquoi parce qu'on est quand même sur
sur des ressorts qu'on commence un peu à
affiner à mieux comprendre il y a
en tout cas c'est analysé décrypter par
par les analystes de la place Bovo comme
une persistance du sentiment de
déclassement qui avait vécu les gilets
jaunes c'est intéressant à Beauvau il y
a évidemment des gens qui comptent mais
il y a des sociologues d'une certaine
manière qui parce que c'est quasiment
une analyse sociologique là que fait
bobo avant de pour savoir qui sont les
gens dans ces manifestations en fait
c'est de l'analyse de l'analyse de deux
terrains de de comportement de
physionomie de foule ils essaient de
voir un peu l'ampleur mais aussi qui
participe
et à quel endroit et quand on est des
petites villes donc c'est des analyses
qui sont souvent des dans les services
de police comme les anciens
renseignements généraux qui s'appelle
Martin le renseignement territorial et
ce qu'il relève en fait leur capteur un
locaux c'est qu'on est vraiment dans
cette France des gilets jaunes dont la
colère n'est pas passée quasiment cette
colère avait pas soldée donc c'est
l'esprit gilet jaune c'est complètement
expliqué la jaune et on se rend compte
que dans ces villes là en fait c'est pas
forcément que les retraites qui qui
mobilisent dire qu'en fait on dirait que
le le mot retraite est un mot un peu
valise un mot attrape tout oui c'est ça
il y a le prix du carburant et des trop
cher donc justement parce que le carbone
est trop cher je vais pas dépenser de
l'essence pour aller à Paris ou pour
aller dans les grandes villes donc je
reste je défilé en bas de mes fenêtres
en bas de ma maison c'est aussi j'ai
peur de l'avenir j'ai peur pour mes
enfants il y a des déserts médicaux on a
même vu des enseignants qui ont
alors il y a une colère plus générale je
peux vous l'assurer mon cher Thibault
déjà première information je vous
entends et ça c'est pas une mince
affaire bravo je peux vous dire
qu'effectivement ici il y a une colère
qui est quand même beaucoup plus
générale que la réforme des retraites
ici on voit des slogans vraiment de
toutes parts des gens qui protestent
contre l'inflation qui galope on a des
personnes aussi qui manifestent contre
les pratiques du gouvernement qui ont
beaucoup qui a beaucoup recours aux 49-3
ces derniers temps là on se trouve vers
le début quand même de du parcours on
est boulevard Poissonnière on n'a pas
fait beaucoup de mètres depuis que l'on
s'est parlé tout à l'heure on est vers
la tête de cortège où se trouve tous les
leaders syndicaux il y a un premier
groupe qui s'est formé devant cette tête
de cortège là composée de manifestants
plutôt jeunes avec des cagoules mais pas
loin de cette tête de cortège j'ai
croisé le regard de deux jeunes
étudiantes et m'a aidée qui sont avec
moi et qui sont très révoltés aussi
contre cette réforme des retraites
bonjour mesdemoiselles alors vous faites
quoi
étudiante en quoi et vous vous êtes
à la Sorbonne en double licence histoire
espagnole
pour quelle raison êtes-vous dans ce
cortège parce que la retraite paraît
très loin pour vous parce que c'est
important ça va nous concerner aussi un
jour hein et ouais même si on est loin
ça va nous toucher à un moment donné
parce que bah la vie elle continue et ça
va être nous les salariés et un moment
ça va être nous qui allons être en
retraite et si on fait rien maintenant
et bah là je petit à petit va continuer
à reculer et c'est maintenant qu'il faut
bouger c'est maintenant qu'il faut
changer les choses alors aujourd'hui
vous êtes deux mais est-ce que dans vos
universités les étudiants se mobilisent
beaucoup aussi bah il y a plusieurs
organisations par exemple il y a
lunettes ils font des interviews des
interventions et et ils nous disent bah
de manifester devenir
simplement vous faites partie de ces
organisations syndicales aussi c'est
très actif en ce moment vous sentez
qu'il y a un regain de colère
[Applaudissements]
tout le monde est énervé j'ai
l'impression donc non alors après par
rapport à cette réforme des retraites
c'est vrai que la volonté du
gouvernement c'est de repousser l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite à 64 ans
est-ce que c'est ce point-là qui vous
embête où il y a d'autres sujets qui
vous indignent également
aussi le salaire
il y a beaucoup de choses qui devrait
évoluer je pense d'accord avec eux
vous êtes ici pas seulement pour la
réforme des retraites mais également
pour d'autres raisons
là principalement aujourd'hui pour la
réforme des retraites quand même parce
que c'est le c'est bon manifeste là mais
après il y a d'autres sujets
on va vous laisser défiler dans ce
cortège parce que on est assez loin de
l'arrivée pour être honnête avec vous
Thibault puisque on se dirige vers la
place de la Bastille et là je peux trop
juste à côté de du quart de la CFDT et
pour être honnête avec vous je m'entends
pas vraiment parler parce que les
manifestants sont très heureux de la
France insoumise et on l'écoute
traditionnel dans les manifestations
comme l'international mais également des
slogans un peu plus hostiles au
gouvernement
on n'arrive pas à entendre pour
l'instant j'ai envie de se Mélenchon là
font partie de l'histoire du pays vous
rencontrez du monde qui a vécu au fait
les grèves de 1995 ça commence déjà à
dater mais voici que celle-ci à nouveau
marque les imaginaires
marque l'expérience personnelle et il y
a en quelque sorte une culture
cumulative de la lutte vous voyez ce que
je veux dire c'est à dire que quand vous
l'avez fait une fois la fois d'après il
va vous savez de quoi il s'agit voilà je
trouve ça très encourageant pour
l'esprit rebelle de notre peuple tout à
l'heure j'étais avec des responsables
parlementaires belges de la gauche et il
venait voir parce que pour eux c'est
très enthousiasmant
voilà
qui est dans la manifestation il était à
Marseille lors des deux premières
journées de de grève sociologie
particulière on le disait des femmes
dans dans ces manifestations à
Christophe les renseignements plus de
travail ce sont des cortèges beaucoup
plus
féminins que d'accoutumé on peut
peut-être on peut peut-être lier ça au
fait que en fait les les femmes là pour
le coup sont véritablement vent debout
quand un contre un projet qui est
présenté comme étant de nature à aller
pénaliser plus que les plus que les
hommes et donc il y ait beaucoup de
beaucoup de médias dont le Figaro qui
ont essayé de décrypter ce oui parce que
pour la majorité des femmes c'est mieux
mais pour certaines femmes voilà des
enfants notamment c'est beaucoup moins
bien c'est beaucoup moins bien et
notamment il y a beaucoup de maires de
familles qui qui sont dans les dans les
dans les cortèges qui n'est absolument
pas habituel et d'ailleurs dans ce dans
ces cortèges il y a pas que dans cette
sociologie nouvelle de du défilé il y a
aussi
des des amateurs du mais des mais des
gens qui sont un peu des primo
manifestants voilà c'est-à-dire qu'en
fait c'est des gens qui se sont rendus
compte qui avait à l'esprit que les
manifestations ça finit toujours mal ça
finit toujours avec des casseurs et dans
le gaz lacrymo ils sont rendu compte que
l'acte 1 et l'acte 2 se passaient plutôt
plutôt pas mal et donc du coup ils
osent descendre dans la rue et ces
gens-là on ne les voyait pas avant et
parmi ces gens là il y a notamment et ça
c'est un un cadre policier un cadre de
la police qui me le disait hier pas mal
de gens qui descendent de manière un
petit peu
spontanée non réfléchi non syndiqué non
politique juste en ayant fait leur
simulation derrière leur écran
d'ordinateur la simulation de retraite
ils ont vu l'âge légal de départ et plus
que l'âge des parts de l'âge légal de
départ c'est le montant de la pension
manifestement qui qui les a incité à
rejoindre les cortèges donc c'est à dire
qu'en fait on des profils qui sont pas
forcément des professionnels
alors cet acte 3 je vous ai lu
pourraient être plus violent c'est ce
qui est craint c'est ce que j'ai compris
alors oui parce qu'en fait il pourrait
être plus violent parce que il y a
plusieurs choses c'est à dire que là
pour l'instant et on ne peut que s'en
féliciter on n'a pas l'impression qu'on
soit fasse une physionomie de on les
voit sur les images de de manifestation
particulièrement
violente ou à risque en tout cas il y a
pas de on voit pas trop les les
black-box se former etc mais justement
les policiers savent que les Black Blocs
sont dans chacune des premières et
deuxième manif même s'il y avait pas
d'incident ils ont maintenant la
certitude qu'ils y étaient initiatelles
et il faut quand même rappeler qu'ils
sont quand même une vidéo surveillant
l'image de vidéo surveillance et en fait
ils ont les policiers en civil dans les
manifs exactement c'est à dire qu'en
fait il y a différents capteurs il y a
des des capteurs de vidéos et puis il y
a aussi
euh des des des policiers notamment de
de bureau d'intervention de voie
publique qui sont en civils et qui sont
un peu noyés dans la foule et qui
permettent de remonter de l'info sachant
que les Black Blocs entre nous soit dit
ils sont reconnaissent à ses aimants en
tête de cortège et la manière dont ils
sont pourquoi ils
se mettrait cette fois-ci en avant alors
qu'ils ne l'ont pas fait lors des deux
dernières magnifiques ah en fait ils
sont assez calmes enfin ils ont été
assez calmes en fait pendant les l'acte
1 et l'acte 2 donc les 19 janvier et le
31 janvier notamment alors ce ne sont
que des que des analyses mais on des des
services mais en tout cas on pense que
les
les Black Blocs ont été entre guillemets
tenus par les et sont toujours tenus par
les syndicats
qui disent en clair pour l'instant c'est
notre tour d'accord c'est le tour des
syndicats donc vous êtes grata et et
donc ils ont une il y a une perception
au leader syndicaux il y a pas alors
c'est difficile de de de tisser des
équations de de dresser des équations à
l'échange national mais on sait qu'elle
est fort local notamment dans des villes
comme Nantes il y a une porosité quasi
évidente et pour ne rien cacher presque
familial dans certains entre des têtes
de d'accord des têtes de de réseau
d'ultra gauche et des organisations des
des responsables syndicaux qui font
partie des centrales se connaissent en
fait on va dire qu'ils se connaissent
bien et donc du coup les messages
passent plus aisément ça c'est une
première chaussée pour ça que ça marche
pas en tout cas c'est pour ça qu'ils
vont pas au créneau et la deuxième chose
c'est que en fait les Black blocker ne
passe à l'action que quand ils sont dans
un rapport de force favorable ce qui
n'est pas le cas là ah bon pourquoi bah
parce que
ils sont ils sont pris en étau entre des
services d'ordre qui fonctionnent très
bien les services d'ordre de la CGT de
la CFDT etc qui sont très présents et
puis aussi la police qui qui est même si
au moins un peu moins de manifestants
comme on vient de le dire reste elle
dans un format quasiment analogue à
celui que l'on a connu le 31 janvier
c'est à dire 11000 policiers et
gendarmes sur le territoire national et
4000 rien que pour Paris donc c'est à
dire que pour les Black blocker
c'est très difficile de passer à
l'action actuellement bon on a vu tout à
l'heure quelques images comme la
dernière fois que ça vous savez avec des
grandes bâches voilà pour l'instant
nous verrons par la suite je posais la
question à François-Xavier Bourbon il y
a quelques minutes est-ce que les noms
réponse gouvernementales d'une certaine
manière peuvent pousser à la violence je
prenais l'exemple des gilets jaunes
Macron avait répondu alors qu'il y avait
beaucoup moins de monde dans la rue à
l'époque sur les manifestations de
gilets jaunes il avait répondu peut-être
parce que Paris était à feu à 100 non
il y a certains des des on va dire des
organisateurs en tout cas des
protagonistes de la France sociale qui
commence à à se dire que évidemment les
défaits dans le calme en tout cas les
ultras ça paye pas ça paie pas les
gilets jaunes ça apportait quand même
pas mal de ils sont ils en sont sortis
avec une enveloppe assez conséquente à
la fin du mouvement ça
ce qui a été conçu comme un acte de
faiblesse en exécutif et une grande
victoire des gilets jaunes même si ces
derniers étaient sorties on s'en
souvient assez pampelants de ces de ces
quelques
60 70
mais en tout état de cause c'est vrai
que certains se disent que la violence
paye alors avant d'arriver à avant de
lâcher entre guillemets et les blagues
bloqueurs dans dans les rues et de les
laisser
libre cours alors violence il y a quand
même
tout à l'heure Jean-Luc Mélenchon par là
d'une culture cumulative des
manifestations on a attendu à l'instant
dire qu'on apprend entre guillemets
de manière un peu itérative de ce qui
s'est passé pour adapter augmenter le
augmenter un peu le son dans les
cortèges et puis ça rejoint un peu ce
que dit Martinez qui tout à l'heure
disait bon en tout cas les risques alors
lui il veut pas employer le mode de
blocage mais il dit des plus dur plus
nombreuses plus massives et il appelle à
monter un cran et donc
parce que là il baisse d'un cran au
niveau du nombre de manifestants dans
ces cas-là quand on arrive plus à
mobiliser dans la rue on va travailler
de manière plus chirurgicale sur
différents secteurs sociaux et notamment
les les observateurs notamment du
ministère de l'Intérieur
ont observé que l'on remarqué que
notamment dans les secteurs mines et
énergie je lis les secteurs de
l'industrie
électrique et gazières il y a des des
projets déjà de blocage de retour de
blocage de raffinerie de coupure de
livraison de électrique de voilà des
opérations Robin des Bois ou quoi ces
opérations c'est en fait vous recablez
vous remettez de l'électricité à des
gens qui ne payent plus voilà c'est à
dire qu'en fait vous vous appropriez en
fait le secteur de l'énergie il y a des
fins militantes vous me dites chaque
semaine lorsque vous venez que les
renseignements cherche à savoir le
nombre de personnes qui aura dans les
manifestations on a parlé de la
sociologie de ces manifestations est-ce
qu'ils cherchent aussi à savoir si la
grève pourrait changer j'entends
s'installer sur du long terme sur une
grève qui dure plutôt que point par
point manifestation par manifestation
parce que les renseignements
s'intéressent à ça et ça savent s'il y a
une tendance à une grève plus longue et
plus étalée alors pour en avoir discuté
avec eux je pense que
eux ne font pas forcément le pari d'une
multiplicité de de grandes
manifestations de rue qui sont qui sont
cadencés comme ça une fois par semaine
parce qu'elle est vacances donc c'est à
dire que là il va avoir une espèce de
trou de creux de creux de mobilisation
et donc il y aura comme dans les comme
dans toute entreprise des relais de
croissance qui vont être trouvées par
ailleurs donc on va penser à ces actions
coup de poing et puis ce que ce qui ce
qui préoccupe les services de
renseignement aussi c'est les risques
d'embrasement que l'on peut identifier
et parmi ces risques d'embrasement il y
a évidemment
le fait que le spectacle qui nous a été
de n'avoir à l'Assemblée nationale dans
l'hémicycle et le fait que le que les
que le que la politique s'embourbe
dans les dans les méandres de ce texte
et à travers ces milliers d'amendements
ça peut tout d'un coup électriser la rue
un moment un autre en disant de toute
façon
la solution politique ne marche pas et
donc il va falloir qu'on passe à quelque
chose d'autre il y a évidemment les
fameux militants d'ultra gauche qui sont
pour l'instant tenus mais qui ont
c'est de Martin une chose acquise
attendre la première occasion pour
passer à l'action et peut-être une
dernière chose allez-y parce qu'après
vous libère très rapidement
il se concret aussi c'est un incident
évidemment pour moi des manipulations
d'un politique merci beaucoup Christophe
Cornavin vous m'avez dit libère et moi à
14h55 il est 54 vous avez une petite
minute de rab et on écoute Olivier Faure
le patron des socialistes qui est dans
la manifestation et qui n'est donc pas
cet après-midi sur les bancs de
l'Assemblée nationale
l'âge de la vie disponible tous
aujourd'hui mardi et qu'effectivement il
y a d'autres moyens pour financer nos
retraites bien sûr qu'il faut les
réformer mais les modes de financement
sont très variés on pourrait très bien
au niveau du SMIC ça coûte rien de 12
euros de cotisation supplémentaires même
un petit patron assumé 12 euros par mois
par salarié et s'il fallait partager on
pourrait même trouver le moyen de
partager avec les grandes fortunes avec
celles et ceux qui dans le monde du CAC
dégorge d’argent chaque mois et
finalement et bien après il a pleuré une
toute petite part pour arriver à
financer nos retraites donc la réalité
c'est que nous avons le faire les moyens
existent c'est simplement la volonté qui
n'existe pas aujourd'hui donc nous
allons démontrer nous détermination et
des Français avec nous parvenir à une
autre belle femme des retraites hier
j'étais avec Madame board qui dit
qu'elle est à l'écoute qu'elle entend
etc vous imaginez que vous êtes d'accord
avec ça madame bon on a des bouchons
dans les oreilles en fait n'entend pas
ce qu'on lui dit donc on va répéter plus
fort ça veut dire quoi jusqu'à quand
c'est quoi
la réalité c'est que on ne peut pas en
fait quand on est garant de la cohésion
d'un pays garant de l'intérêt général
maintenant normalement on écoute ce que
les gens disent enfin c'est une petite
majorité on peut comprendre que ce soit
difficile et quand Paris sur une forme
de retournement mais là il n'y a pas
d'autonomie impossible en fait le client
public elle est totalement acquise à
l'idée qu'il faut pas cette réforme et
c'est pas en fait parce qu'ils n'ont pas
compris les Français ont très bien
compris ont trop bien compris ce que ça
concerne et les uns et les autres ont
été sur les simulateurs ont vu ce que ça
concernait pour eux le nombre de mois ou
d'années qu'ils vont devoir travailler
en supplément rien n'a échappé à
personne ni pour les femmes ni pour les
précaires ni pour ceux qui ont commencé
à travailler tôt ni pour toutes celles
et ceux qui voient leur âge la retraite
s'éloigner alors même qu'ils savent que
ils auront bien du mal à tenir est-ce
que vous répondez à ce
la faiblesse de la qualité du débat à
l'Assemblée dans la semaine dernière
comment peut-on qualifier de faiblesse
débat qui n'a même pas commencé alors la
peine commencé hier les travailleurs
d'obstruction est impossible puisque le
gouvernement a choisi une procédure
particulière qui est le 47.1 qui permet
au bout de en l'occurrence dans 10 jours
quoi qu'on est fait on est voté au
pavoté il passe au Sénat donc la réalité
c'est construction en fait elle est
absolument impossible maintenant c'est
au gouvernement lui d'expliquer pourquoi
il a posé cette procédure alors même
qu'il n'y avait aucune urgence et que il
prive les Français d'un débat majeur
est-ce que vous trouvez vous logique que
en 10 petites journées on solde une
affaire qui va concerner des millions de
Françaises et de français même la
totalité des Français pendant les
prochaines décennies la réponse
évidemment c'est non merci à vous
salut Olivier fort le patron des
socialistes qui est évidemment dans
cette manifestation parisienne on y
retourne dans la manifestation avec
Damien Canivez Damien vous êtes avec une
manifestante me semble-t-il
absolument et je peux vous dire qu'il
fait un froid de canard ici dans les
rues de Paris Thibault mais heureusement
la pluie n'est pas encore arrivée
effectivement je suis avec Christine on
s'est éloigné de la sono de la CFDT
parce que on s'entendait plus mais on
est malgré tout au cœur de ce cortège
orange avec tous ces chasses humbles et
Christine est avec moi effectivement
bonjour Christine alors Christine vous
vous êtes retraités mais vous avez quand
même tenu à être ici dans ce cortège
aujourd'hui absolument ça me paraît très
important de faire face à l'injustice
qui va être faite aux personnes qui vont
devoir partir plus tard
moi j'ai moi-même parti le plus tôt
possible à 62 ans parce que j'ai
considéré que je voulais vivre vivre ma
vie et ne pas être tributaire de du
travail j'avais les moyens de faire
parce que j'ai une retraite modeste j'ai
choisi de ne pas gagner plus pour les
personnes qui sont qui sont qui parfois
étaient éloignés de l'emploi l'intérieur
des carrières brisées ça sera pas
possible et c'est vraiment dommage c'est
vraiment dommage pour elle et il
faudrait que le gouvernement puisse
reculer sur cette question vous faites
quoi dans la vie Christine sociale vous
étiez assistante sociale et est-ce que
vous pensez que le gouvernement peut
reculer en malgré tout le monde qu'il y
a aujourd'hui dans la rue on a
l'impression
c'est une photo une animation c'est
l'Assemblée nationale parce que il est
15h01 et dans une minute à l'autre les
questions au gouvernement doivent
débuter on va rester ensemble vous aurez
à gauche les images de l'Assemblée
nationale avec les questions aux
différents ministres en imagine que les
questions seront largement portées sur
et bien cette manifestation sur cette
réforme des retraites et puis vous aurez
à droite ces images toujours dans les
dans les rues de Paris on reste ensemble
tout l'après-midi aller pour l'instant
je vous laisse avec l'ambiance toujours
place de l'Opéra me semble-t-il on a vu
que Damien canivevez avançait
progressivement dans la rue de la
capitale vers Bastille en passant par
République il n'y est pas encore mais ce
sera l'un des points de passage de cette
marche de 4 km cette troisième journée
de grève dans les rues de Paris mais
comme tous les jours visiblement et qui
viennent de manifestation et bien le
cortège a du mal à s'élancer vous voyez
ces images nous attendons donc les
députés il y aura-t-il des députés de la
nups sur les bancs de la nups sur les
bancs pour poser des questions au
Gouvernement ça c'est l'une des
questions on a vu beaucoup dans les rues
de la capitale on a entendu tout à
l'heure Massil de panneau on a entendu
Olivier Faure le patron des socialistes
mais on imagine que certains députés ont
dû rester sur sur les bancs de
l'Assemblée pour pouvoir poser leurs
questions au Gouvernement tiens je vous
donne avec quelques chiffres en
attendant à Lyon 30000 manifestants
selon la CGT c'est beaucoup moins que
mardi dernier ou les syndicats s'étaient
targués de rassembler 45000 personnes
c'est la tendance environ 30% de moins
sur cette journée de utilisation on sait
et on rappelle qu'il y aura une autre
manifestation samedi prochain il y a le
brun Pivet est en train d'arriver sur le
perchoir je vous laisse avec cette
séance de questions gouvernement et ces
images dans les rues de Paris on écoute
ce qu'il se passe à l'Assemblée à tout à
l'heure
lundi
un séisme d'une force inédite suivie de
puissantes répliques à frapper le sud de
la Turquie et le nord-ouest de la Syrie
plus de 5000 personnes ont trouvé la
mort dans cette catastrophe les blessés
se comptent par milliers
de très nombreuses familles se trouvent
sans abri par un froid glacial alors que
des milliers d'immeubles se sont
effondrés
face à cette terrible tragédie la France
se mobilise avec ses partenaires pour
apporter une aide d'urgence aux
populations sinistrées
les équipes de secours français sont sur
place pour participer aux opérations de
sauvetage de recherche et d'assistance à
la population sinistrée
mes chers collègues face à ce terrible
drame je vous invite à observer une
minute de silence en mémoire des
victimes et en soutien à ceux qui les
aimaient
je vous remercie
donc l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au Gouvernement
la première question va être posée par
Monsieur Victor Catteau pour le groupe
rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Économie
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire Monsieur le
Ministre l'huile de tournesol plus 112%.
le sucre plus 70%. le riz plus 40%, les
légumes frais + 34%, les steaks hachés
plus 30%. on appelle un an les prix des
produits alimentaires n'ont fait que
grimper en flèche et chose inédite en
France la consommation alimentaire est
en chute libre comme jamais vu depuis
plus de 160 ans le constat est là les
frigos des Français sont de plus en plus
vides et pour beaucoup de nos
compatriotes faire ses courses et devenu
un véritable chemin de croix et pendant
ce temps-là pendant que les prix
flambent tout va les pompiers pyromanes
que vous êtes restent les bras croisés
mais quand allez-vous vous réveiller
monsieur le ministre quand allez-vous
enfin comprendre que les Français n'en
peuvent plus alors on sait vous nous
dites que vous travaillez vous annoncez
des mesurettes par-ci par là mais
contrairement à ce que vous pensez les
Français ne sont pas dupe cela fait des
années que vous ressortez les mêmes
salades au final quel est le résultat
les prix des produits alimentaires n'ont
jamais été aussi cher vos veines paroles
et vos gesticulations ne trompent
personne en réalité obligé les Français
à se faire hara-kiri en faisant reposer
sur eux les conséquences de votre
politique du rien de votre politique du
néant de votre politique du vide ce
n'est pas ce que j'appelle faire preuve
de courage monsieur le ministre vous
voulez un exemple de courage allez voir
dans ma circonscription du côté de
Bourdin de Wattignies ou encore de la
Bassée allez voir ces familles entières
qui se serrent la ceinture allez voir
ces familles qui se partagent à 5 un
paquet de pâtes de 250 g allez voir
c'est papa et c'est Maman qui doivent
choisir entre acheter un paquet de
biscuits ou habiller leurs enfants vous
osez clamer haut et fort que tout le
monde doit partager l'effort mais en
même temps vous refusez de retirer la
TVA sur ces produits de première
nécessité comme le propose depuis fort
longtemps notre présidente Marine Le Pen
merci je n'ai pas fini madame la
Présidente alors Monsieur le Ministre
assumé vos responsabilités dites-nous
quelles sont les mesures concrètes que
vous allez mettre en place pour que les
Français puissent à nouveau remplir
leurs assiettes
savoir merci donc la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier Véran ministre délégué
chargé du renouveau démocratique et
porte-parole du gouvernement merci
madame la Présidente de Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
députés catho
au point de départ il y a la guerre que
livre les Russes à l'Ukraine qui fait
augmenter le prix des céréales et quand
les céréales augmentent le prix de la
viande augmente lorsque le prix de
l'essence augmente le prix du poisson
augmente au point de départ il y a aussi
des catastrophes climatiques très années
habituelles très inhabituelles mais
auquel il faudra peut-être se préparer à
l'avenir je pense à la sécheresse au
Canada on l'a vu sur le prix de la
moutarde je pense aussi aux inondations
qui ont pu frapper le Brésil et qui ont
un retentissement important par exemple
sur le prix du sucre c'est un fait le
prix des produits alimentaires est en
augmentation en France en Europe et dans
la quasi-totalité des pays
occidentaux monsieur le député et c'est
un fait aussi qu'un certain nombre de
nos compatriotes face à l'inflation sont
obligés de faire des choix ils ont
commencé par renoncer à certains loisirs
certaines activités et c'est un fait
aussi que le panier alimentaire y
compris dans les grandes surfaces y
compris dans les grandes surfaces dites
low cost c'est modifié ces dernières
semaines ces derniers mois ce député
quand vous dites qu'on se croise les
pouces qu'on se croise les doigts ou
alors qu'on attise les choses je vous
rappellerai simplement que l'inflation
est plus basse en France que par tout
ailleurs en Europe parce que le
gouvernement agit et si vous posez la
question à vos collègues si vous posez
si vous posez la question à vos
collègues notamment je pense aux
populistes d'Europe de l'Est vous leur
demanderez à combien se porte
l'inflation est-ce qu'ils font pour
protéger leur population néanmoins
monsieur le député nous ne croyons pas
et nous continuons de considérer que
l'option que vous proposez que Madame Le
Pen propose à savoir de supprimer la TVA
sur des produits de première nécessité
n'est pas une bonne option au-delà du
coût de cette mesure c'est évidemment ce
qui va se passer c'est que les grandes
distributions garderont l'équivalent de
la TVA et ne baisseront pas les prix il
n'y aura pas de gain pour le
consommateur mais il y aura des gains
pour les distributeurs ce que nous
travaillons en revanche depuis des mois
avec Bercy travail cela en lien avec la
grande distribution c'est un panier
anti-inflation pour que des dizaines de
produits notamment alimentaires et de
première nécessité ne voit pas leur prix
augmenter dans les prochaines semaines
et que cette concurrence entre les
grandes surfaces permettre de rendre le
panier moyen du consommateur français à
des prix acceptables croyez en notre
engagement complet depuis des mois et
Constance pour lutter contre l'inflation
et protéger les Français merci monsieur
le ministre monsieur Catteau monsieur le
ministre dans le Nord on dit qu'il y a
les 10 œufs et les feux et vous vous
êtes un d'eux
la parole est à Madame la caisse est
nous pour le groupe Renaissance
merci Madame merci madame la Présidente
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Intérieur et
des Outre-mer Gérald Darmanin monsieur
le ministre la mission d'information sur
la réforme de la police judiciaire dont
je suis la croix reporter avec Hugo
bernalicis va présenter son rapport
d'information devant la commission des
lois dans quelques minutes la nécessité
de réformer la police nationale fait
aujourd'hui consensus alors que nous
devons faire face à des enjeux
importants sa structuration actuelle
manque d'unité ce qui génère des pertes
d'informations d'efficacité et parfois
même des logiques de concurrence
auxquelles s'ajoutent la perte
d'attractivité de la filière judiciaire
cette réforme de la police nationale
peut devenir une chance pour la filière
judiciaire une chance de se réinventer
tout en préservant sa tradition
d'excellence et les grands principes qui
régissent son fonctionnement
si les garanties que je propose sont
retenues et intégrés au projet et si
l'important moyen sont mobilisés pour
accompagner la réforme je suis convaincu
que le résultat d'ensemble contribuera à
améliorer le quotidien des enquêteurs et
la qualité du service public rendu aux
victimes au-delà de la méthode les
recommandations que j'ai formulées
suivent un triple objectif
revaloriser les fonctions de police
judiciaire au sein de la police
nationale renforcer les moyens de la
filière et assurer le respect des
spécificités de celle-ci apporter toutes
les garanties nécessaires à l'autorité
judiciaire le rapport d'inspection que
vous avez conjointement demandé avec le
Garde des Sceaux a été rendu public la
semaine dernière et la mission
d'information sénatoriale conduite par
les sénateurs belluraux et du Rhin
devrait à son tour prochainement
présenter ses conclusions quels sont dès
lors monsieur le ministre les prochaines
étapes qui seront les vôtres dans la
mise en oeuvre de cette réforme au
regard de l'ensemble des recommandations
qui ont pu être et continu d'être
formulé merci monsieur je vous remercie
madame la première question la parole
est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre
de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs députés madame la député
vous avez raison dans le cadre de la loi
de programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur que j'ai eu le nord de
porter ici la lampe du président de la
République et de la première ministre
une grande réforme de la police
nationale pas simplement de la police
judiciaire et porter avec des moyens
très conséquents que le Parlement dans
un très large majorité a bien voulu nous
accorder et à acter d'ailleurs la
réforme de la police nationale par un
vote vous le savez qui je crois fait
honneur au débat parlementaire et au
très nombreux à un moment qui ont été
adoptés cette réforme est très
importante puisque depuis le début des
années 90 fois la quasiment 40 ans la
police nationale n'avait pas connu deux
réformes d'ampleur surtout que comme
vous le dites aujourd'hui la filière
dites investigation qui touche la police
judiciaire mais aussi tous ceux qui font
de la police judiciaire notamment dans
chacun de vos commissariats mérite
d'être fortement soutenu parce que si
nous mettons plus de policiers dans la
rue il y a de plus en plus de mal
évidemment à présenter devant l'autorité
judiciaire des enquêtes qui sont à la
fois bien faites rapides et qui
répondent à nos concitoyens il fallait
donc réformer la police nationale pour
cela vous avez raison devant les
interrogations d'une réforme qui a été
pensée très longtemps j'ai nommé ici
Monsieur joggs de très nombreux ministre
de l'Intérieur nous avons commandé avec
le garde des sceaux une mission qui a
rendu son rapport et dont nous suivrons
l'intégralité madame la députée des
préconisations vous rendez dans quelques
minutes je n'ai pas encore eu le temps
de les connaître les propriétés avec
Monsieur bernalicis c'est dans quelques
heures ce sera le tour de vos collègues
du Sénat je répondrai je crois aux
interrogations de votre commission j'ai
déjà dit que ce que vous avez esquissé
notamment des moyens plus importants
pour la filière judiciaire sera au
rendez-vous l'évaluation par les
procureurs de la République des VPN sera
évidemment au rendez-vous et bien sûr
que chaque agent de police judiciaire
continuera à faire son travail de police
judiciaire et rien d'autre dans l'action
évidemment de la police nationale c'est
une réforme qui fait naître des
interrogations c'est pour ça qu'après
que le Parlement la semaine prochaine je
recevrai l'intégralité des organisations
syndicales en bilatérales pour évoquer
évidemment cette réforme et je
reviendrai devant votre commission et
devant vous même monsieur bernalicis
pour justifier des recommandations que
j'aurais pris dans votre rapport
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame Sabrina c'est Bailly
pour le groupe écologiste merci monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur en octobre
dernier le groupe huskule d'extrême
droite Action française entrée à l'hôtel
de ville de Stains et agresser des âges
en communaux au cri de jeux cite vous
salissez la France je vous avais demandé
ici même ce que le gouvernement comptait
faire et les moyens qu'il se donnaient
pour lutter contre ces groupes fascistes
je n'ai obtenu aucune réponse dans ce
climat où la parole raciste se libère
c'est avec effroi que nous avons pris
connaissance d'une véritable chasse à
l'homme dans la ville de verseilles
datant du juillet dernier vidéo à la
pluie dévoilée par luftider on dénombre
deux victimes leur seul tort était
d'être noir et pour cette raison ils ont
été lynchés par une foule en furie
comptant parmi elles rendez-vous compte
le deuxième adjoint de ce même village
monsieur le ministre en 2023 en France
un élu de la Nation a voulu tuer des
Français parce qu'ils sont noirs il
semblerait que la police n'est
interpellée personne dans cette affaire
pire tout un village dont la
municipalité se serait employée à faire
régner une omerta honteuse dans le but
de protéger les coupables alors même que
plusieurs témoignages font état
d'agresseurs se vantent en jeu cite
d'avoir tapé de negrons cette actiniable
n'est pas anodin il s'inscrit dans un
contexte plus global où les idées
concepts d'extrême droite ont été
largement normalisés ces dernières
années non seulement à travers certains
médias mais également parmi un grand
nombre de personnalités politiques se
prétendant du camp républicain
aujourd'hui nous envoyons les
conséquences alors que cela fait des
mois que nous vous alertons sur la
montée de cette bête immonde celle du
racisme qui se répond dans la société
nous nous sommes jamais entendus
monsieur le ministre ma question est
simple qu'est-il envisagé quant à la
municipalité de verzeilles dans les
propres élus réussi à être rendu
complice de cet acte abject pourquoi ces
criminels sont-ils encore en liberté et
quand allez-vous enfin agir pour
endiguer cette vague raciste à laquelle
nous faisons face je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Gérald de
Darmanin ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente de Monsieur
député madame la députée je ne peux pas
partager le ton de votre votre question
d'abord parce que s'il s'agit de
commenter une enquête judiciaire vous
comprendrez que et c'est votre groupe
qui en premier me le rappelle tous les
jours que c'est bien l'autorité
judiciaire de répondre aux enquêtes qui
sont en ce moment menées sur des faits
que vous dénoncez en aucun cas le mise
intérieur je crois dans une démocratie
qui se respecte le deuxième c'est que
vous dit qu'on ne fait rien même
monsieur Mélenchon la semaine dernière
avoué que ça n'arrive pas à tous les
jours mais même monsieur Mélenchon s'est
fendu d'un tweet public pour me
féliciter fester le gouvernement pour la
dissolution de Bordeaux nationaliste 11
11 associations et groupuscules
d'extrême droite ont été dissous au
Conseil des ministres depuis que je suis
ministre de l'intérieur
dont génération identitaire
et madame je crois qu'on ne peut pas que
c'est une question est aussi importante
pour la République simplement être
caricatural dans l'expérience de vos
questions ce gouvernement ci est celui
qui a le plus
usé du droit existant pour dissoudre les
associations d'extrême droite si vous
souhaitez
déclables encore pour le colonisation
dissolve des associations au Conseil des
ministres pour qu'ils soient enfin
validé par le Conseil d'État il ne
fallait pas Madame dans le mandat
précédent pour ces pour ces sièges qui
étaient ceux de la gauche à l'époque
refusaient les critères que je proposais
avec la majorité que vous avez refusé et
qui ont été portés devant le Sénat et
qui ont été supprimés en CMP qui
m'aurait permis de dissoudre les
associations que vous évoquez madame
malheureusement il faut constater que
vous implorez beaucoup beaucoup et dès
qu'on vous demande d'être plus dur vous
n'aimez pas beaucoup l'ordre
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Aurélien Santoul
pour le groupe la France insoumise
madame la Première ministre après le
ministre de l'Intérieur et son chantage
sexuel après la ministre de la
transition énergétique et ses conflits
d'intérêt voici le ministre en charge
des retraites et son favoritisme vous ne
dirigez plus un gouvernement vous
pataugez dans un cloaque monsieur du
soft c'était fait connaître par sa
capacité à trahir les siens en 2017
député il avait voté contre le budget
d'Edouard Philippe et séjour après il le
défendait au Sénat entre-temps il
s'était vendu pour un strapontin
ministériel c'était déjà lamentable mais
Mediapart nous apprend qu'il n'était pas
novice dès 2009 et Luère d'Annonay
notamment pour ramener l'eau de la
commune en gestion publique il avait
permis en fait à la SAUR numéro 3 du
secteur de continuer à faire de jus de
profit
en secret l'élu de cette modeste commune
s'entendait avec le PDG de la grande
multinationale il truquait un appel
d'offres pour permettre à la SAUR de
garder le marché monsieur du soft
recevait ensuite de la part de la SAUR
de lithographie d'un artiste côté et
faisait payer par l'entreprise sa lettre
d'information aux habitants jusqu'à peu
il n'y ait les fait désormais il est
poursuivi pour favoritisme et c'est ce
monsieur du soft que vous chargez de
mener contre mener votre réforme des
retraites c'est lui l'homme qui nous
veut du bien en nous volant deux ans de
vie qui peut croire qu'il agit pour
l'intérêt général et pas pour sa
carrière d'exécuteur des bases œuvres
qui peut croire qu'il veut sauver les
retraites par répartition alors qu'il
les sabote qui peut le croire quand il
affirme que votre réforme n'est pas
faite pour favoriser les fonds de
pension et la retraite par
capitalisation monsieur du soft a Bulot
de la sort je ne vois pas comment on
pourrait résister au champagne de
BlackRock et d'Axa prévoyance il est
temps d'assainir madame la ministre il
est temps d'assainir
[Applaudissements]
ministre
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Saint-Ouen je vais peut-être vous
ramener à la réalité vous n'êtes pas un
procureur nous ne sommes pas dans un
tribunal vous êtes un élu de la Nation
nous sommes à l'Assemblée nationale
[Musique]
vous savez monsieur le député au cœur de
notre démocratie il y a un principe la
présomption d'innocence et moi je veux
dire toute ma confiance toute ma
confiance du président de la République
à Olivier du socle qui est un ministre
engagé qui a été un député engagé qui a
été un maire engagé je vous remercie
je vous remercie madame la Première
ministre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à monsieur le Président
Chassagne pour le groupe GDR
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre des millions
de Français sont de nouveau dans la rue
aujourd'hui
rejetant votre effort inique de retraite
toutes les organisations syndicales de
salariés à l'unisson avec nos
compatriotes en bien compris que la
réforme que vous proposez malgré les
artifices constituent une régression
unique qui pénalisera chacune et chacun
d'entre eux aucun progrès n'est possible
car votre préalable est de faire
travailler les personnes deux ans de
plus dans quelques heures nous
reprendrons l'examen de votre réforme
par l'article 1er qui supprime les
régimes spéciaux ces régimes spéciaux
qui sont pour nous des régimes pionniers
cependant il y a un régime très très
spécial auquel vous ne vous attaquez pas
c'est celui de la finance c'est le
régime spécial de ceux qui peuvent
cumuler de super compte épargne retraite
d'attribution d'actions gratuites de
retraites chapeau afin de se constituer
une belle pension de retraite à l'âge où
il voudront et sans avoirisotisé le
moindre euro madame la Première ministre
la politique des affaires de choix vous
avez fait les vôtres depuis 5 ans vous
dorlotez une une minorité et faites
peser les efforts sur le plus grand
nombre vous répétez l'opération avec
votre réforme des retraites en demandant
à ceux qui ont commencé à travailler tôt
à ceux qui ont des carrières hachées de
travailler deux ans de plus pendant que
vous refusez toujours toujours de vous
attaquer aux revenus financiers qui ne
cesse de croître et qui ne cotise pas
cette fois le sacrifice que vous
demandez aux grands nombres et trop
important et les Français ne l'acceptent
pas si vous n'êtes pas prête à épargner
les régimes spéciaux de ceux qui
travaillent pour de prendre au régime
très spéciaux au régime très spéciaux
des grands patrons il ne vous reste
qu'une seule option madame la Première
ministre il ne vous reste qu'une seule
option retirer votre mauvais projets
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
Président Chassaigne
la première ministre avant de vous
répondre je veux à mon tour dire toute
ma solidarité et celle de notre pays
tout entier après le terrible séisme qui
a frappé la Turquie et la Syrie hier
selon un dernier bilan provisoire il
aurait coûté la vie après de 6000
personnes
la France est solidaire et agit comme
l'a annoncé le président de la
République les équipes de la sécurité
civile et du centre de crise et de
soutien sont partis pour apporter une
aide d'urgence sur le terrain
monsieur le Président Chassagne avec
votre question vous démontrer ce que
nous disons depuis le début
si demain le système de retraite par
répartition devait s'effondrer si nous
devions passer à la capitalisation ce ne
sont pas les plus riches ni les grands
patrons qui seraient pénalisés ce sont
les travailleurs les salariés les
commerçants les artisans ce sont les
plus modestes et les classes moyennes
toutes celles et ceux à qui une vie de
travail garantit une retraite
alors monsieur le Président Chassaigne
je voulais déjà dit et j'en reste
convaincu nous voulons tous deux
préserver notre système de retraite par
répartition un système qui garantit la
solidarité entre les générations un
système mis en place au lendemain de la
Libération notamment par Ambroise
Croizat ministre communiste du travail
du général de Gaulle
pourtant pendant que nous nous battons
pour préserver notre modèle social avec
vos alliés de la nupes vous refusez la
réalité vous
ignorez la démographie Vous contestez un
fait irréfutable qui n'est pas une
opinion politique le nombre de personnes
qui travaillent baissent par rapport au
nombre de retraités alors oui nous
demandons un effort aux Français mais
nous le faisons parce que c'est la seule
façon de préserver notre l'avenir de nos
retraites car si nous ne faisions rien
quel serait des conséquences des hausse
d'impôts et de cotisations massives et
nous le voyons dans vos amendements dans
vos amendements qui pèseraient sur
l'emploi et sur les salaires avec à la
clé une montée du chômage et une baisse
du pouvoir d'achat ou alors nous aurions
une baisse drastique des pensions qui
coûterait au regretté modeste à tous
ceux qui ont travaillé toute leur vie et
certainement pas au grand patron plus de
chômage et moins de pouvoir d'achat
voilà votre projet alternatif
nous c'est le plein emploi et de
meilleures pensions
monsieur le Président Chassaigne vous
défendez les régimes spéciaux pour ma
part je crois qu'un chauffeur de bus à
Paris avire ou à Clermont-Ferrand doit
avoir les mêmes droits le même métier
doit offrir la même retraite c'est une
question de justice
monsieur le Président Chassaigne je
finirai par un regret sur nos retraites
nous avons eu l'occasion de montrer que
nous étions capables de nous rassembler
notamment en adoptant à l'unanimité vos
propositions de loi pour revaloriser les
pensions des agriculteurs alors où le
débat commence je suis convaincu qu'il
reste des points d'accord à trouver je
suis convaincu que nous pouvons
améliorer ce texte ensemble cela passera
par le débat la confrontation d'idées et
bien sûr le respect les dégradations les
intimidations ça n'est pas la démocratie
aujourd'hui les murs de l'Assemblée
nationale ont été dégradés mais ce sont
parfois vos permanences ou vos domiciles
je veux dire mon plein soutien et celui
du gouvernement aux élus concernés quel
que soit leur parti politique je vous
remercie je vous remercie madame la
Première ministre
et merci pour vos mots de soutien à
l'égard du Parlement et des
parlementaires la parole est à Monsieur
Hubert hôte pour le groupe démocrate
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre des
Solidarités de l'autonomie et des
personnes handicapées monsieur le
ministre ma question porte sur l'effort
entreprise par la nation pour
revaloriser le secteur médico-social qui
a été en première ligne durant la
pandémie et sur certains angles morts
qu'il nous reste à régler je pense ainsi
à ceux que l'on appelle les oubliés du
Ségur c'est professionnel des services
logistiques techniques ou administratifs
qui représente un maillon essentiel du
service médico-social notre
reconnaissance doit s'adresser à toute
la chaîne humaine sans exception or
contrairement à leurs collègues
soignants ou éducateurs ces personnels
demeurent exclus des primes défilées
dans le cadre du Ségur de la santé les
183 euros nets mensuels accordés en plus
ce sont toujours pas pour eux cette
situation est vécue comme une réelle
injustice par ces femmes et ses hommes
agents d'entretien et de maintenance
secrétaire agent d'accueil comptable
ressources humaines ou équipes de
cuisine une partie des professionnels à
bénéficié d'un rattrapage du Ségur mais
uniquement pour certaines catégories
ayant un lieu un lien avec la santé et
l'accompagnement direct infirmier
psychologue moniteur d'atelier continuez
à exclure une partie du médico-social
revient à instaurer un système à deux
vitesses toutes les professions utiles
au fonctionnement des établissements et
services de santé sont garants de la
bonne prise en charge des patients et
des usagers au sein de ces institutions
c'est d'autant plus incompréhensible que
ces professionnels éducatifs et
d'accompagnement sont financés par
l'assurance maladie les conseils
départementaux et l'État via les ARS
monsieur le ministre comment le
gouvernement compte il accompagner la
prise en charge de ces angles morts sur
les différents échelons y compris
territoriales pour enfin mettre toutes
ces personnes sur un pied d'égalité et
leur accorder cette reconnaissance
unanime qu'elle mérite toutes Je vous je
vous remercie je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Christophe
con ministre des Solidarités de
l'autonomie et des personnes handicapées
merci merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député
uberaute vous avez raison l'attractivité
des métiers c'est l'une des priorités de
mon action depuis le mois de juillet
dernier
cette revalorisation du secteur elle
doit passer par tous les leviers que
nous devons actionner par la formation
des professionnels par l'amélioration
des conditions de travail mais également
par les revalorisations salariales et de
ce point de vue je rappelle que nous
avons produit une augmentation inédite
de l'ensemble des salaires des
professionnels du secteur social et
médico-social le Ségur de la Santé a
concerné 700 000 salariés 700 000
professionnels qui ont été augmentés de
183 euros par mois il a ensuite été
étendu à l'ensemble des professionnels
du secteur de la filière socio-éducative
200 000 salariés ont été également
concernés et de nouvelles augmentations
ont eu lieu à la fin de l'année dernière
pour continuer à étendre ces mesures du
Ségur de la santé je pense notamment aux
mètres de maison ou à d'autres
surveillants notamment de nuit
qualifiées on va pas s'arrêter là et
évidemment il faut aller plus loin vous
avez raison c'est pourquoi notamment
dans le secteur associatif j'ai invité
ensemble des représentants des
employeurs mais également des salariés à
négocier une Convention collective
unique de branches pour le secteur
sanitaire social et médico-social qui
est la seule réponse qui permettra
d'augmenter durablement et de
revaloriser durablement les parcours de
l'ensemble des professionnels du secteur
y compris ceux que vous mentionnez et
pour cela l'année dernière en février
les départements et l'État se sont
engagés à accompagner cette démarche de
500 millions d'euros donc maintenant il
reste plus qu'à négocier cette
convention collective unique et je le
dis c'est la seule solution pour que
tout le monde soit concerné par ses
revalorisations salariales
revalorisation salariale qui ne sont pas
que le seul levier pour améliorer
l'attractivité des métiers il faut
actionner tous les leviers les parcours
professionnels favoriser la valorisation
des acquis d'expérience et qualifier
l'ensemble des faisant fonction merci
beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Patrick Etel pour le groupe les
républicains
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre madame la Première ministre
vous parlez souvent de République
exemplaire c'est pourquoi je voudrais
vous interroger au sujet d'une situation
qui était lasse loin d'être exemplaire
en effet il s'agit de quelqu'un qui est
champion de France des mises en examen
et qui pourtant continue d'être membre
du cabinet et conseillé du président de
la République Monsieur solaire pour ne
pas le nommer si je vous interroge c'est
que nous savons désormais quand cette
qualité de conseiller du président il a
eu accès à des informations
pourtant censés rester secrète en
provenance du ministère de la Justice
sur une enquête encore en cours or ces
informations ont été transmises ensuite
par Monsieur solaire à celui qui était
visé par l'enquête résultat cette
interférence a permis de protéger un
réseau de trafiquants de drogue depuis
la présidence de la République avec
l'appui de l'un de vos ministères madame
la Première ministre que comptez-vous
faire pour que l'exemplarité que vous
revendiqu généralement ne soit pas qu'un
discours mais se traduisent
véritablement dans les actes
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
la pied qui porte-parole du gouvernement
merci Madame la présidence mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le
députés Patrick
la calomnie parce que là je suis désolé
vous avez une interprétation d'un
article de Mediapart que j'ai moi-même
lu et en fait on a ou pas lu le même
article où on l'a pas vu avec les mêmes
yeux enfin l'article de Mediapart est
très clair il reprend lui-même les
propos du procureur général de Nanterre
qui dit qu'il n'avait pas eu du tout
connaissance de l'affaire qui intéresse
le député auquel vous faites allusion
donc s'il procureur général de Nanterre
et c'est donc public lui-même qui n'est
pas au courant comment voulez-vous que
la Chancellerie soit au courant et donc
je vais encore plus loin comment
voulez-vous que la Chancellerie est
fromentée je ne sais quel complot ayant
pour conséquence d'empêcher le
démantèlement d'un trafic de drogue
enfin Monsieur le Député soyons sérieux
s'il vous plaît
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur Hetzel
merci beaucoup président monsieur le
ministre votre réponse est hallucinante
13 mise en 13 mise en examen pour
Monsieur Soler je vais juste en citer
quelques-unes détournement de fonds
publics trafic d'influence financement
illicite de campagne électorale recèle
d'abus de biens sociaux en somme et nous
l'aurons tous compris le président de la
République et sa majorité protège un
multirécidiviste bravo pour
l'exemplarité
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre
mot pour mot ce que dit la première
ministre tout à l'heure je vous rappelle
que vous êtes parlementaire et pas
procureur vous parler d'un parlementaire
qui est lui-même mis en examen l'âge du
site aura à trancher pour le reste vous
parlez vous parlez d'hallucination
monsieur le député
Ezel je crois avoir fait la
démonstration par la lecture de
l'articles des Médiapart sur lequel vous
fondez votre nom question que les
hallucinations elles ne sont peut-être
pas du côté de celui qui le croit
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur il n'ya
[Applaudissements]
ma question s'adresse au ministre du
Travail monsieur le ministre il y a
maintenant quelques semaines vous que
vous avez pu suivre depuis tout à
l'heure depuis l'Assemblée nationale on
a parlé de tous les sujets notamment de
la réforme des retraites on va retourner
dans la manifestation je salue Jean-Yves
Guérin bonjour bonjour
des questions de transport on va parler
de la mobilisation dans les dans les
entreprises de transport notamment
d'abord on fait un petit point Bison
Futé ensemble si ça vous dit c'était
comment les transports ce matin alors
c'était très perturbé mais moi qui a une
semaine et moins encore que lors de la
première mobilisation qui avait lieu le
19 bon c'est la première semaine que ça
avait été le plus le plus difficile pour
les usagers ça va décrécendo bon on a un
peu moins mal on va dire on va voir si
ça continue retourne dans la
manifestation Damien canivels vous
avancez vous en êtes où de ce parcours
encore une fois sur les seuls salariés
injuste aussi ah bonjour alors attendez
parce que je reviens mon oreillette
j'étais en train de la première qu'on
avait deux personnalités avec de
personnalités de manifestants devraient
agir c'est Mohamed c'est ça
MH ok l'indigène pèlerin d'Orléans gilet
jaune et la France insoumise un gilet
jaune et France insoumise alors celui-là
depuis l'acte 4 c'est la première fois
où manifester ici mais tu rigoles depuis
l'acte 4 depuis l'acte 4 gilet jaune
donc vous mettez 118
combien de manifestations vous avez
faite sur les quatre ans j'ai plus de la
centaine et vous faites quoi dans la vie
vous m'avez je suis retraité plombier
vous êtes retraités plombier et j'ai 74
ans et samedi je prends 75 ans mais
alors qu'est-ce qui vous embête dans
cette retraite dans cette réforme parce
que j'imagine que vous êtes vous déjà à
la retraite à cet âge-là voilà à 74 je
l'ai je l'ai j'ai pris à 67
à l'époque parce que bon il y a une
histoire derrière donc un jour on en
reparlera en témoignage parce qu'on a
été la première famille algérienne
arrivé en 52 Orléans mais qu'est-ce qui
vous embête dans cette réforme des
retraites rien je vais vous dire une
chose il est hors de question que je
joue le chirurgien elle est rafistolée
elle reprend un élément quoi que ce soit
je rejette tout la totalité de ce de
cette pseudo réforme parce qu'il faut
pas être dupe cette réforme on est en
train de dépouiller un bien collectif
pour la finalité sur la distance filée
ou privée aux assurances privées voilà
donc en réduisant les les comment dire
les sécurités les les acquis et les gens
qui sont pas satisfaits qui cotisent
ailleurs donc ce système là j'ai même
pas envie de déblatérer à la poubelle
c'est le système pas répartition qui
vous emmène non non je discute même pas
parce que Elisabeth borne récemment aura
bien rappelé qu'elle ne bougerait pas
sur l'âge de 64 ans Emmanuel Macron a
dit qu'il irait au bout de la réforme
jusque où vous vous êtes prêt à aller
pour
retirer alors il y a quel rapport de
force aujourd'hui vu la détermination et
les magous qui se préparent à
l'Assemblée entre le les LR et les Front
national pour le citer et bien j'y crois
pas moi je dis mes amis je vais pas
m'épuiser laissez tomber le débat il est
donc la finalité derrière et bien
on se met en embuscade et ce qu'une loi
a fait une loi scélérate comme disait
Pasqua et bien une autre loi plus
démocratique le refrain et donc avec une
nouvelle génération d'hommes et de
femmes moi c'est ce que je veux je
souhaiterais parce que les politicards
qui sont là pour nous donner des leçons
de comment dire qui viennent à longueur
de journée parler de la misère des gens
et il ne la vivent pas donc tant qu'on
n'aura pas nos hommes les femmes qui qui
vivent notre quotidien la réalité de la
vie et qui soit des délégués et le jour
où je verrai poignée d'hommes et de
femmes qui se mettront au service de la
cité pour mettre en application ce que
le peuple aura décidé ça ça sera les
vrais politiques vous sont déterminés
mais est-ce que vous avez l'impression
vraiment est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que vos camarades sont prêts à
manifester chaque semaine parce que les
chiffres qui viennent de région
annoncent d'une mobilisation un peu en
baisse pour ce mardi est-ce que ça veut
pas dire que le mouvement risque bien de
s'essouffler au fil des semaines on a
l'exemple de des gilets jaunes mais
différemment que sur la distance le
massage les borniers tout ça et là
financièrement ça touche les gens le
portefeuille donc effectivement on aura
des des pertes en cours de route mais il
y a et moi ce qui me comment dire qui
m'interpelle c'est que avec l'expérience
des manifs on avait une certaine casse
de gens mais là ça a touché tous les
strass de la société et là la finalité
fait que le petit l'artisan le privé
tout ça tout à chacun sont touchés donc
chacun dans son domaine dans son espace
économique et flinguer et ça c'est
Macron il a pas compris il va au devant
du mur donc il passe le bouffer et donc
la finalité est bien il y en a qui sont
déterminés qui sont à la distance parce
que c'est
ou donner un biscuit ou une rustine sur
une jambe de bois c'est mort ça il faut
qu'il intègre tout ça donc moi j'appelle
mes frères gilets jaunes comme toi et
moi qui vivent la misère et les
difficultés de la vie au quotidien et
Ben qui s'assemble et j'ai dans les
prochains mois Mao avec une groupe de
vraiment d'amis mais pas de connard de
casseurs de quoi que ce soit et bien on
va lancer le G9 de Mao G9 de Mao
pourquoi le G20 lg8 en opposition et on
va taper sur l'économie et le social et
le relation merci beaucoup Mao pour le
témoignage que vous venez de d'accorder
bonne manifestation à vous et attends
remercie et par la même occasion je
tiens à saluer notre ami comment dire le
vaillant le fidèle
Ivan je te remercie on a perdu notre
merci
vous êtes toujours avec moi merci
spécialiste des transports bon moins de
manifestants moins de grévistes c'est à
la SNCF elle a RATP pourquoi est-ce que
c'est qu'on s'adapte mieux au niveau de
la SNCF et de la RATP ou non il y a pas
un engouement si fort que ça chez les
cheminots alors ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que il y a il y a 3 ans lors de la
réforme des retraites précédentes il y
en a régulièrement en France il y avait
une grève renouvelable et ça durée 7
semaines à la RATP et 5-6 semaines à la
SNCF aujourd'hui le conflit n'est pas
parti du tout sur les mêmes bases
pourquoi parce que les cheminots ont
moins y perdre d'accord ah c'est ça on
va parler des régimes spéciaux voilà
ils ont moins à perdre avec avec cette
réforme premièrement et puis
deuxièmement il se disent que finalement
il reste jusqu'à fin mars pour que le
texte soit définitivement adopté et donc
puissent être selon eux soit à mondées
soit supprimé donc ce qu'ils veulent
c'est
supprimer et donc ils veulent pas
s’épuiser je dirais
et perdre entre guillemets dans leur
logique trop de jours de grève
surtout dans une période où malgré tout
il y a des vacances scolaires et donc
les cheminots sont aussi en vacances
je comprends ce que vous voulez me dire
tiens pas je voulais l'avoir d'un peu
plus tard mais puisque vous y faites
allusion ces fameux régime spéciaux
est-ce que les cheminots font profil bas
en 2019 il y avait une réforme qui
voulait systémique changer beaucoup plus
de choses et ont touché au régime
spéciaux les Français étaient pour la
modification et l'abrogation des régimes
spéciaux cette fois on y touche pas et
les Français sont contre la réforme des
retraites est-ce que les cheminots se
disent bon bah nous finalement on y
échappe on travaille peut-être plus mais
au moins on touche pas à nos avantages
pas tout à fait quand même parce que
quand on regarde je vous ai dit le il y
a plus de train aujourd'hui mais il y en
a pas beaucoup quand même hein
c'est
pas c'est pas suffisant par ailleurs la
réalité c'est quoi c'est que
aujourd'hui
vous et moi plutôt moi que vous
d'ailleurs
les salariés du privé partent ou plutôt
au plus tôt à 62 ans
en moyenne un conducteur de train
à la pénibilité etc il part à sa concept
oui d'accord donc 5 ans plus tôt donc il
part 5 ans
ça veut donc dire que si demain les
salariés du privé partent au plus tôt à
64 ans le mon conducteur de train il va
partir à 59 ans il aura toujours cette
image de départ qui recule donc lui
aussi il a son âge de départ qui recule
mais il garde cette cette avantage qui
est important la deuxième différence
c'est que quand vous êtes fonctionnaire
et quand vous travaillez à la SNCF ou à
la RATP
votre retraite votre niveau de retraite
votre pension est calculé sur
votre dernier salaire et vous touchez
75% du dernier salaire pour les salariés
du privé le salaire de référence c'est
celui que vous avez eu pendant les 25
millions d'années assez long 25 ans
d'accord et puis vous ne touchez pour un
cadre un peu en dessous de 60% 60%
versus 75 c'est pas la même histoire
bien sûr bon souvent on est quand même
mieux payé dans le privé que dans le
public évidemment
a compétence égale on est mieux payé
dans le privé dans Public exactement
syndicat de transport les syndicats dans
les transports sont souvent à la pointe
des mouvements de grève est-ce que c'est
le cas cette fois ou pas vraiment
pour l'instant non c'est à dire que le
discours
officiel de la CGT cheminot
Sud Rail l'une ça fait revienne donc je
vous prends la les trois plus gros
de la SNCF oui disent on n'a pas
vocation pour l'instant à être le fer de
lance de la contestation parce que cette
réforme elle concerne tout le monde elle
ne touche pas uniquement les salariés du
public ou
des boîtes qui sont couvertes par des
régimes spéciaux de retraite c'est une
réforme de retraite qui concerne tout le
monde donc on veut pas être on veut pas
être en point
et ça peut changer ça oui ça peut quand
parce que vous le savez à l'Assemblée
nationale le gouvernement a raccourci le
temps de débat avec l'article 47 ans on
en reparlera avec nos journalistes
politiques tout à l'heure ça va aller
très vite au Sénat dans un mois
l'affaire est plié est-ce que les
cheminots n'ont pas intérêt à se
mobiliser plus vite s'ils veulent alors
au contraire cette réforme de retraite
un mois c'est un peu plus en fait et les
dates ont les dates ont une
signification la fin des la fin des
vacances c'est début mars si il doit y
avoir en clair un blocage du pays
blocage du pays c'est quoi ces blocages
des transports d'abord ou blocage des
raffineries etc et ça de façon continue
c'est à dire on estime que
c'est un blocage de minimum une semaine
10 jours d'accord
ce blocage il doit intervenir il
interviendra à ce moment là c'est à dire
que dans la fin des vacances à la fin
des vacances ok bon intéressant de voir
que non pour l'instant les syndicats
transports ne sont pas les faire valoir
du mouvement les faire de lance du
mouvement mais cela pourrait le devenir
est-ce que aujourd'hui la les grèves des
syndicats de transport dans les
transports sont moins impactantes
notamment à cause du télétravail ce
matin dans certains métro parisiens il y
a pas grand monde alors ils sont pas
beaucoup à rouler mais on se pressent
pas dans certaines lignes à faire la
queue attendre parce que les gens
s'adaptent est-ce que les
salariés des transports peuvent-ils
encore avoir un impact significatif par
des grèves alors il y a moins d'impact
que
en 2019 ou si on remonte dans le temps
il y a très longtemps
pour les plus anciens en 95
il y avait pas de télétravail il y a
deux choses
font que il y a un impact du
un peu plus faible effectivement le
télétravail 30% des gens en région
parisienne peuvent télétravailler c'est
pas mal sur une grève j'allais dire
ponctuelle c'est à dire un jour bah on
peut expliquer effectivement son
employeur que l'on va pas venir et qu'on
sera plus efficace de de chez soi et
puis il y a un deuxième élément qu'on a
pas en tête mais aujourd'hui il y a
beaucoup de gens qui sont revenus dans
les transports mais pas autant qu'on
2019 d'accord on n'est pas à 100% alors
on a un effet un peu déformant parce que
on attend le métro ça fonctionne pas on
est super serré donc on se dit bah on
est encore plus nombreux non on est on
attend le métro et on est super serré
parce que la RATP a pas suffisamment de
conducteur et donc n'a pas remis 100%
des métros
qu'il y avait en France que l'univers
c'est à dire que
lorsqu'il a pas de grève il y a moins de
métro de toute façon
ça RATP oui bon ça va changer ça ou pas
d'ailleurs pas forcément le débat oui
le premier pour pour avril alors après
est-ce que c'est un poisson d'avril ça
c'est encore autre chose mais il le
promet on revient sur les les employés
les syndicats notamment de la SNCF
est-ce que d'ailleurs les cheminots par
exemple
écoute les têtes pensantes de la CGT je
prends par exemple ce qu'il s'est passé
à Noël la CGT ne voulait pas qu'il y ait
de grève et pourtant il y a eu une grève
dans les transports est-ce que les
organisations syndicales ont encore la
main sur leur leurs employés qui sont
syndiqués alors pour l'instant oui ah
pour l'instant oui
sur Noël effectivement c'est un
mouvement qui est venu de la base des
contrôleurs d'accord et qui ont un peu
tendu le bras au syndicat qui ne voulait
pas faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour l'instant il y a une inter
syndicale c'est-à-dire qu'on parle d'une
seule voix mais avec un ton différent on
voit bien que d'un côté il y a des
syndicats maximalistes d'accord CGT et
Sud qui pousse à une grève renouvelable
c'est-à-dire tous les jours continuent
encore une fois comme je vous l'ai dit
une semaine 10 jours minimum pour faire
d'accord plier le gouvernement c'est
l'épreuve de force de l'autre côté vous
avez des syndicats réformistes c'est
l'une ça qui est très fort à la SNCF on
le sait pas c'est le deuxième syndicat
derrière la CGT d'accord
non localement la CFDT c'est le
quatrième syndicat simplement
donc il y a les deux syndicats
réformistes une salle et CFDT qui disent
oula molo pour l'instant on parle pas de
grève renouvelables on verra d'accord
donc ils sont pas
tout s'aligner ils disent qu'ils sont
alignés mais ils ne sont pas toujours et
tout le temps et finalement certains
poussent d'autres frêne et on a un entre
deux en même temps
est-ce que d'où vient cette culture de
la grève d'une certaine manière dans ses
entreprises ça toujours été le cas
François de Petras qui est un autre
journaliste Figaro spécialiste lui aussi
des questions transforme me disait un
jeune même s'il est pas forcément
syndiqué il arrive à la SNCF il a envie
de se syndiquer il entre dans cette
culture de l'entreprise il y a deux
choses même 3 d'abord il y a l'histoire
les grèves de 36
1936 le Front populaire etc le fer de
lance déjà c'est
les
SNCF
ça c'est le premier point le deuxième
point c'est que
quand vous rentrez à la SNCF
vous avez la garantie de l'emploi
la possibilité que on vous remercie au
que vous soyez mal vu n'est pas de même
ordre que dans une entreprise privée ça
joue le troisième point il faut être
honnête et vous l'avez évoqué c'est que
effectivement les rémunérations
ne sont pas les mêmes que quand on a la
sécurité de l'emploi et bien il faut le
payer un petit peu quand même parce que
on a par ailleurs un certain nombre de
davantage de conditions de travail de 35
heures faites avant les autres etc donc
les rémunérations en moyenne sont plus
faibles sont un électricien mettons
puisque la SNCF recrute des économies
gagnent à la SNCF que dans une boîte
privée bien sûr mais il a pas les mêmes
avantages
je reviens vers vous j'allais dire mais
d'abord on retourne sur le terrain
Damien Canivez j'ai l'impression que
vous êtes avec des avec des pompiers
c'est ça Damien est-ce que vous
m'entendez les pompiers sont aussi en
grève aujourd'hui oui
absolument je suis avec un groupe de
pompiers avec moi ils viennent de 50 ans
ils ont fait la route pour justement
faire en sorte que leur voix se fasse
entendre ils ont beaucoup de
revendications bonjour pourquoi vous
êtes là aujourd'hui alors aujourd'hui on
est là pour pour défendre nos droits
pour se pour manifester notre
mécontentement malgré le fait de
travailler on a du mal à finir nos mois
et en plus on nous demande aujourd'hui
de travailler beaucoup plus donc il y a
un moment donné c'est on n'est plus dans
une cohérence on est dans un monde où on
regarde plus le bien-être de la personne
aujourd'hui
il faut voir le bien-être des gens et on
est rentré dans un système où on va nous
presser comme un citron et on cherche
pas à savoir si on vit bien un côté si
on arrive à bien nourrir nos enfants à
bien les habiller à pouvoir faire
plaisir à notre femme pourtant on
travaille pour ça et donc oui c'est pour
la réforme des retraites aujourd'hui
mais c'est un tout moi ce qui m'amène
aujourd'hui ici c'est l'ensemble c'est
l'ensemble de
toute cette pression au quotidien et on
a oublié que la vie elle peut être très
belle
on peut être bien tous les jours mais
avec un système différent et moi
j'aimerais bien que le fameux système il
tombe parce que c'est un système qui
nous eau presse tous les jours qui
dégage de le il est anxiogène et nos
enfants on sait même plus les
conseillers aujourd'hui on les conseille
d'aller vers quelle branche quelle
branche aujourd'hui peut garantir le
bien-être voilà tout simplement alors
c'est vrai que pompier on n'a pas
forcément besoin d'exercer ce métier
pour se rendre compte que c'est quelque
chose d'assez pénible il faut avoir une
certaine force physique aujourd'hui on
vous demande de travailler plus
longtemps est-ce que concrètement ça
c'est possible pour vous alors c'est
simple on pourra pas aujourd'hui on a la
majeure partie on a une quarantaine
d'années on voit très bien qu'arrivant
une cinquantaine d'années on est pu
aussi efficace on perd qu'on ne percute
plus aussi rapidement tout simplement
parce qu'on prend de l'âge le physique à
un moment donné
on arrive plus à suivre comme quand on a
20 30 40 ans et il y a un moment donné
les personnes qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
faire ils vont se mettre en arrêt donc
on va on va venir alimenter déjà un gros
problème le problème de la Sécu les gens
qui se mettent en arrêt mais aujourd'hui
on se dit bah quand on a on arrivera une
cinquantaine d'années qu'on arrivera pas
à réaliser nos missions on se mettra en
arrêt donc on va alimenter un système
qui est déjà défaillant aujourd'hui donc
c'est pas c'est pas cohérent ce qui se
passe aux gens il faut il faut se
projeter dans 10-15-20 ans et en plus le
fait de se libérer avant 60 ans à la
retraite ça va laisser la place pour les
jeunes et à un moment donné un pompier
faut qu'il soit efficace il faut qu'il
soit réactif et arriver quand on aura
dépassé les 50 ans ben on l'est beaucoup
moins
voilà donc voilà la raison pour laquelle
on est là aujourd'hui on a l'impression
que vous êtes un peu au pied du mur
quelque part parce que vous dites que
vous n'arrivez plus à joindre les deux
bouts à la fin du mois malgré le fait
que vous travaillez vous vous mettez
également en danger dans votre travail
parce que vous dites que vous êtes
forcément moins performant aujourd'hui
que lorsque vous êtes entré dans le
métier jusqu'au vous êtes prêt à aller
pour faire entendre vos revendications
aujourd'hui
jusqu'au où je suis prêt aller et ben
tout arrêter puis aller vivre dans la
Creuse ou dans les plateaux du Larzac et
vivre comme un SDF ouais ouais demain
vous êtes prêt à ça parce que
manifestement c'est aussi ce que les
manifestants ont pu souligner c'est que
le gouvernement n'est pas forcément pour
le moment en tout cas réceptif au
revendication des uns et des autres si
ça se poursuit est-ce que aussi vous
êtes pour un durcissement du mouvement
de pompier je l'espère je suis pas pour
la violence mais malheureusement on a
l'impression que pour se faire
comprendre pour faire basculer un
système malheureusement faut passer par
le chemin violence dégradation et c'est
quand même triste que notre gouvernement
ne sache pas nous entendre aujourd'hui
on peut manifester pacifiquement mais
derrière il faut qu'il y ait du
changement et on comprend les gens nous
on intervient mon collègue disait tout à
l'heure à 80% chez des gens faut voir
dans les conditions dans lesquelles ils
vivent limite j'ai pas le droit de me
plaindre moi aujourd'hui j'ai pas le
droit de me plaindre j'ai la chance
d'avoir du chauffage l'électricité de
quoi changer de quoi boire mais il y a
80% des gens aujourd'hui ils sont en
train de crever quoi et sauf il faut
ouvrir les yeux faut s'en rendre compte
mais notre gouvernement ben ils sont
aveugles ils sont soit où ils font
semblant d'être soi eux tant qu'ils sont
dans le petit soulier avec le petit
tapis rouge qui va bien il sent très
bien voilà et bien merci pour votre
témoignage et bon bon défilé et bon
retour à 50 ans merci voilà la
manifestation se poursuit dans une
ambiance pour le moment cordiale et on
va se diriger tout droit vers la place
de la Bastille nous sommes à peu près
amis parcours
rester avec nous Damien canivelle on
revient vous voir dans un instant
ambiance bon enfant il a fait une
audience
tiens j'ai une dernière question
manifestation grève dans les dans les
transports en commun dans la RATP à la
SNCF assez peu dans l'aérien pour
l'instant assez peu dans les riens parce
que les contrôleurs aériens
on fait profil bas ils appellent pas ils
n'appellent pas la grève par précaution
néanmoins je sais pas si vous avez vu il
y a 20 % des vols qui sont annulés
à Orly
c'était le cas lors des deux
journées nationales de protestation
contre la réforme
19 et 31 janvier
pourquoi ils font pas grève alors que
c'est une population
assez vindicative et là aussi
et bien parce que ils ont négocié le
fait que cette réforme ne les concernait
pas et que rien ne changeait pour eux
pourquoi il y aura un régime spécial
ajouté à tout ça expliquez-moi en clair
il partent alors je n'ai plus les
détails je crois qu'ils partent à 60 ans
d'accord pour des questions de limite
d'âge liés au fait que ce métier-là
juridiquement ne peut pas l'exercer au
delà une question sécurité et donc voilà
pour des raisons de sécurité et ils ont
négocié en sous-main pour que il passe
se clapet se cliquer il soit pas remis
en ce plafond voilà il ne soit pas remis
en cause donc eux rien ne change et il y
a une autre catégorie qui fait pas
beaucoup parler d'elle et qui est en
train de négocier à la pas terminé ses
négociations
et quand ils font pas grève c'est que
ils essayent également finalement de
garder
ce qu'ils avaient jusqu'à présent alors
attendez vous êtes en train de me dire
que ah là c'est à la SNCF on fait pas
autant grève que ce qu'on pourrait le
faire et on attend vous me dites que
dans les transports aériens on négocie
mais on attend
ça c'est pas rien c'est une potentielle
un potentielle une potentielle huile sur
le feu c'est manifestant potentiel qui
n'en sont pas pour l'instant oui mais
justement c'est pour ça que le ministère
des des Transports
a négocier avec la corporation des
contrôleurs du ciel pour le aérien et
est en train de négocier avec les
pilotes de ligne comme ils l'ont fait
sur d'autres régimes spéciaux je sais
pas les danseurs ou les danseuses
souvenez en 2019 devant l'opéra devant
l'opéra
pas danser devant l'opéra parce que tout
simplement ils ont obtenus
bien que le régime social ne soit pas
remis en cause bon nous verrons cela ce
qu'on a Damien qui a niaisons on va me
dire dans l'oreillette si on peut
retourner le voir pour qu'il nous
raconte alors ça a l'air clairsemé sur
sur ces images nous aurons des chiffres
dans la dans la journée d'Amiens non pas
Damien bon vous restez avec moi un peu
si c'est comme ça continue à parler de
la de la SNCF
quel est le pourcentage de parce que la
semaine dernière c'était assez étonnant
il y avait plus de gens dans les manifs
et moins de grévistes qu'elle était ce
matin pourcentage vous avez ou pas
un tiers je crois alors il ne donne
est-ce qu'ils l'ont donné
on va les retrouver
ça ça doit être des sources des sources
syndicales c'est source
donc effectivement c'est moyennement
moyennement ferme mais il y a un autre
élément qui est qui est intéressant
par rapport justement à la précédente
réforme des retraites hiver 2019-2020
avant le avant le covid c'est qu'à
l'époque il y avait une entreprise où la
mobilisation était très très forte
c'était l'air RATP oui
la mobilisation les gens ont beaucoup
marché dans Paris la mobilisation était
encore plus forte et plus longue que à
la SNCF d'accord
or aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas
pourquoi parce que pour des questions là
encore interne à la boîte il se trouve
que
le patron la patron des parties et il y
a un nouveau patron que tout le monde
connaît à la RATP ces gens Castex voilà
c'est Jean Castex et Jean Castex en fait
depuis qu'il est arrivé fin novembre
autant
la patronne qui était là avant était dur
sur la forme et dure sur le
fondateur qui sont la forme et tout
aussi dur sur le fond non et il
distribue l'argent ah oui c'est à dire
que il a signé des accords sociaux il
met de la pommade
il a signé des accords
avec les retraites donc pêche que ça
calme ça calme les revendications
et donc ça joue également dans le fait
que aujourd'hui il y a un petit peu plus
de métro que
au mois de décembre 2019 voilà merci
beaucoup Jean-Yves Guérin journaliste au
service économique spécialiste des
questions de transport on continue notre
après-midi on passe par le terrain
Damien canivevez dites-moi faites-moi un
petit bilan il y a du monde dans cette
manifestation est-ce qu'il y a des
tensions ça a pas l'air racontez-moi
c'est vrai
alors pour être honnête avec vous
Thibault j'ai du mal à me rendre compte
du monde qu'il y a dans cette
manifestation parce que actuellement je
me trouve pas très loin de la place de
la République on était dans un espèce de
faux plat montant ce qui m'a permis de
voir vraiment tout le grand boulevard
qui était effectivement noir de monde
mais difficile d'avoir une idée de
l'affluence ici en tout cas ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que les
manifestants sont très déterminés tous
ceux à qui on a parlé ont un ras-le-bol
des retraites certes en tout cas de
cette réforme mais au-delà de ça il
manifeste contre l'inflation contre le
gouvernement en général et côté ambiance
je peux vous dire que et bien tout se
déroule de façon très cordiale les
syndicats sont
organisés par par groupe comme vous
pouvez l'imaginer il y a un groupe qui
s'est mis devant la tête de cortège un
groupe c'est vrai avec des des
personnalités un peu cagoulées disons
enfin des des des manifestants assez
jeunes qui sont d'ailleurs en train je
sais pas si vous le voyez derrière moi
mais en train de
comme on dit sur de la musique tout à
l'heure il y a eu quelques échauffourés
avec les forces de l'ordre un petit
mouvement de foule avec sans doute un
jet de Grenade mais rien de de très de
très violent si j'ose dire donc pour
l'instant tout se déroule plutôt bien et
la manifestation poursuit son son cours
on arrive vers la place de la République
d'ici quelques instants
et bien on vous retrouve tout à l'heure
évidemment on continue avec nos
spécialistes ici en plateau Marie-Cécile
Renaud bonjour
rédactrice en chef adjointe au service
et que économie du Figaro on va entrer
dans le détail j'ai plein de questions
sur cette réforme qui pourrait ne pas
rapporter tant que ça j'ai lu votre
votre papier mais cette journée de
mobilisation Marie-Cécile encore du
monde vous sentez un mouvement solide ou
non il y a quand même des chiffres qui
semblent être à la baisse là écoutez ça
fait maintenant Thibault ça fait presque
un mois je suis régulièrement les
journées de mobilisation
le 19 le 31 et donc aujourd'hui moi j'ai
l'impression quand même en regardant les
images que le cortège est plus clairsemé
que ça avance je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez le premier jour le 31 les gens
piétinaient
la place de la République
la semaine dernière et là il fallait
faire un petit tour tout à l'heure on
avait du mal à rattraper le cari de tête
voyons courrait un peu après on n'a pas
réussi à le rattraper donc ça veut dire
que ça avançait en région ce matin ils
étaient plus faibles il semble plus
faible et même la CGT annonce des
chiffres plus faibles oui la CFTC disait
qu'il y avait 15 % de manifestants moins
et ça se remarque aussi sur les
grévistes dans la fonction publique par
exemple il y a 11% de grévistes selon le
ministère contre 19 lors de la deuxième
journée de mobilisation et 28% lors de
la première donc on voit qu'il y a quand
même une décrue est-ce que c'est la
marque d'une forme de lassitude
c'est vrai que l'opinion commence à en
avoir marre on parle des retraites
depuis deux mois et même on peut dire
depuis 2017
alors le problème c'est que ça c'est ça
c'est le mouvement doit tenir jusqu'au
26 mars puisque les débats vont se faire
la fin des débats à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est le 26 mars
euh donc il faut il y a encore un mois
devant nous plus d'un mois oui 26 mars
parce que 2 mois
voilà c'est très long et puis bon moi ce
que je vois aussi c'est que c'est quand
même beaucoup la RATP la SNCF les IEG
qui manifestent c'est-à-dire des gens
qui partent à 58 ou 60 ans et se sont
eux qui manifestent contre le report de
l'âge à 64 ans on va en parler je veux
juste une précision vous voyez ces
images là on est quasiment au début de
la de la manifestation c'est tout proche
du Figaro d'ailleurs pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas Paris on est à l'arrêt
de métro Richelieu-Drouot à peu près à
Opéra on va voir l'autre image qui est
vous savez on a plusieurs flux voilà
celle-ci là on est place de la
République vous voyez qu'il y a quand
même de une distance entre ces deux
endroits un bon kilomètre et demi
peut-être deux donc voilà il y a déjà du
monde place de la République alors même
que certains n'ont pas encore quitté ou
presque la place de l'Opéra donc
en effet cela semble clairsemé
Marie-Cécile vous avez raison les
chiffres semblent montrer mais il faut
le dire que le cortège est très étalé
l'ambiance est toujours joyeuse enfin
c'est toujours le cas dans les manifs et
c'est toujours
sauf quand il y a de la violence mais
enfin c'est plutôt bon enfant et joyeux
il y a de la musique etc mais
est-ce qu'il y a pas une forme de
lassitude aussi dans l'opinion avec ce
sujet qui accapare toutes les énergies
toute l'attention alors qu'il y a des
des enjeux tellement important aussi
dans l'actualité
économique française et internationale
est-ce que tous les syndicats sont sur
la sur la même longueur d'onde il y a
une baisse de la mobilisation qui sera
sûrement établie ce soir lorsque nous
aurons les chiffres officiels est-ce que
ça peut être un tournant aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il peut y avoir une division
avec on le sait Jean Garen nous disait
il y a un instant pour l'instant il
parle du même voie mais ils ont pas tous
les mêmes idées sur la suite du
mouvement non
pour l'instant l'unité syndicale tient
le front syndical tient
syndicale qui se réunit chaque soir
après chaque journée de mobilisation
donc il s'était tous mis d'accord pour
bien réussir les grandes journées de
mobilisation sans violence en tenant le
mouvement donc pour l'instant ça tient
bien
après c'est vrai qu'il y a des
divergences toujours sur la stratégie à
tenir et on trouve chez donc la CFDT
veut être très dans la maîtrise du
mouvement avec des grandes journées de
mobilisation qui qui cadence
le mouvement et ils espèrent que le
gouvernement ne pourra pas rester
insensible à ce qu'ils estimaient la
plus forte mobilisation de ces 30
dernières années
du côté de FO et de la CGT on préfère on
préférait au lendemain de la première
mobilisation quand il y avait vraiment
beaucoup de monde dans la rue battent le
faire tant qu'il était chaud continuer
donc voilà il y a une des stratégies
différentes mais c'est vrai que pour
l'instant on peut dire que c'est la CFDT
qui donne le la et que la CGT écoute
plus ou moins sagement ce qu'il peut y
avoir un renversement avec un Philippe
Martinez on les a vu tout à l'heure
ensemble et il se taquine et alors
verger disait oui regardez je suis là je
l'aide hein bon voilà
est-ce que ça peut durer oui enfin c'est
leur intérêt de maintenir le front ils
sont d'autant plus fort qu'ils sont unis
on se rappelle qu'en 2019 la CFDT
soutenait la réforme des retraites et ça
affaiblissait quand même l'opposition
des syndicats
là c'est vrai que la CFDT donne le Lab
la CFDT je vous le rappelle c'est le
premier syndicat tout secteurs confondus
la CGT pour l'instant pour l'instant est
aligné mais la CGT à son propre agenda
aussi je vous rappelle qu'ils ont leurs
Congrès le 27 mars qui commencent le 27
mars à Clermont-Ferrand l'objet de ce
congrès c'est de désigner le successeur
ou la successeur de Philippe Martinez
une femme oui il aimerait que ce soit
une femme
mais c'est pas gagné il y a toute une
guerre interne au sein de la CGT pour
désigner le futur leader
et Philippe Martinez lui il appelle à
des grèves plus dures plus nombreuses
plus massives et reconductible je le
cite mais on l'a dit le mouvement doit
tenir dans la durée et donc l'idée ça
serait plutôt d'attendre début mars il
va y avoir comme une sonde une sorte de
ventre mou si vous voulez il va y avoir
les vacances scolaires il y a les
vacances scolaires qui débutent alors la
SNCF a décidé de il y a un mouvement de
mobilisation samedi mais ils ont décidé
de manifester mais pas de ne pas bloquer
il y a pas de grève pour ne pas empêcher
les Français de partir en vacances
l'idée c'est de ne pas garder l'opinion
publique qui est pour l'instant
favorable aux grèves puisque favorable
au retrait de la réforme je rappelle
ouais 70% de l'opinion et contre la
réforme donc l'idée c'est de ne pas se
mettre à dos l'opinion publique de
garder l'opinion avec soi c'est quand
même une grosse force
mais après ce ventre mou lié vacances on
entrera dans la dernière ligne droite et
là il est probable qu'il y ait un
durcissement un durcissement du
mouvement certains
estiment que le 8 mars qui est le jour
la journée des femmes pourraient être un
jour pour commencer et ensuite avoir des
grèves reconductibles donc voilà sur
plusieurs jours d'affilée avec un
blocage
qui a changé depuis le covid c'est et
qui a quand même le télétravail bien sûr
pas pour tout le monde je sais bien mais
le télétravail fait que beaucoup de gens
peuvent travailler à distance maintenant
les réseaux les ordinateurs
c'est qu'il y a maintenant des pistes
cyclables partout les gens se sont
équipés de vélo il y a des vélibres ou
des dans toutes les villes tous les
métropoles il y a des vélos en accès et
donc ces deux éléments font que on peut
quand même contourner on peut travailler
même s'il y a une grève
sur ces futurs élections là à la CGT
cela veut dire que l'avenir du pays ou
en tout cas l'avenir des travailleurs
français dépend d'une certaine manière
des petites tambouilles internes de la
CGT j'ai l'impression que Philippe
partinez parfois n'arrive pas à
mobiliser l'ensemble des Confédérations
notamment celle des cheminots qui est en
grève mais pas vraiment
est-ce que cela peut jouer parce qu'il y
a une guéguerre interne à la CGT ouais
ça va ça va indubitablement jouer
d'ailleurs la CFDT enfin j'en parlais
avec Laurent Berger il avait mis en
garde le gouvernement en disant ne
faites pas la réforme des retraites au
moment du congrès de la CGT mais
je sais pas s'ils ont le choix ou pas
enfin bref
ils n'ont pas tenu compte de cette mise
en garde je vous donne un chiffre et
bien nous arriver c'est le le chiffre de
la CGT concernant le nombre de
manifestants à Paris 400 000
selon la CGT donc ce serait comme le 19
janvier ils avaient annoncé 500 000 la
semaine dernière voilà pour l'instant
pour ce qui est loin des 2 millions que
la CGT annonçait le 31 janvier il y
avait en réalité un million de
manifestants à Paris à Paris 400000
manifestants
nous verrons plus tard dans la journée
le chiffre national alors qu'on voilà
sur ces images en hauteur certains
casseurs voilà on vient de voir un
panneau d'affichage fracassé et une
poubelle en feu
espérant que ça pour le coup c'est quand
même une réussite jusqu'à présent
d'avoir bien tenu les services d'ordre
font leur travail et la violence est
restée très très
absente et des cortèges c'est déjà trop
évidemment mais
après ce qu'on a pu voir notamment lors
de la part des gilets jaunes pour
l'instant rien à voir
justement est-ce que
c'est manifestations trop trop calmes
d'une certaine manière elles sont trop
calme mais non mais voyez ce que je veux
dire oui c'est peut-être pas le bon
terme vous avez raison ce qu'elles sont
trop calmes pour faire
flancher faiblir le gouvernement le
faire reculer on se souvient qu'Emmanuel
Macron avait reculé lors de la période
des gilets jaunes parce qu'il avait eu
des casses il y a beaucoup moins de
monde dans la rue là il ne semble pas
vouloir reculer il me semble rien
accorder est-ce que une manifestation
calme et bien le gouvernement félicite
mais ne change rien à sa réforme moi je
pense que la violence non la violence
n'est pas une n'est pas un levier c'est
certainement pas l'encourager
d'analyser pourquoi le gouvernement ne
refuse pas que le gouvernement cédera au
chantage de la violence et par contre le
mouvement aurait tout à perdre en se
mettant à dos l'opinion publique
alors quand vous dites le gouvernement
c'est vrai qu'il y a un blocage chacun
campe sur sa position le gouvernement
donne dégage fait des concessions
multiplient les concessions mais euh
il y a pas d'entente possible puisque ce
que veulent les manifestants c'est le
retrait pur et simple de la réforme ils
ne veulent pas de report de l'âge à 64
ans donc comme le gouvernement ne peut
pas céder là-dessus c'est le cœur de la
réforme si c'est de là-dessus il y a
plus de réforme ben le discours là il y
a un échec du dialogue social ça ne
fonctionne pas chacun comme sur sa
position et il y a pas de il y a pas de
consensus possible
cette réforme elle va être débattue à
l'Assemblée avec le commence à débattu
depuis hier rappelez-nous l'objectif de
ce texte déjà c'est de faire des des
économies
combien et à quelle échéance je pense
que c'est important de poser des bases
pour tous ceux qui nous regardent et
puis après on va essayer de voir ça va
si bien marcher que ça donc je le
rappelle cette nouvelle réforme des
retraites c'est une réforme paramétrique
c'est-à-dire qui a pour but de revenir à
un équilibre financier c'est une réforme
budgétaire et le gouvernement l'assume
alors que la réforme de 2019 c'était une
réforme beaucoup plus ambitieuse qui
voulait changer les règles changer la
société enfin c'était mue par une vision
de la société ça voulait plus de justice
sociale d'équité de transparence
fusionner tous les régiments d'un seul
les 42 régimes en acier
[Musique]
euh c'est de dégager
17,7 milliards d'euros en 2030
à partir de 2030 voilà en 2030 on fera
17,7 milliards d'euros d'économies et ça
tombe bien parce qu'à ce moment-là on
aura un déficit de 13 milliards et demi
donc on gagne on a 4 milliards de marge
voilà on a un gros 4 milliards
à passer la première ministre dès le
début dès le 10 janvier quant à la
présenté la réforme faisait déjà 4,8
milliards de dépenses de mesures
sociales donc voyez vous me disiez 4
milliards de marge on était déjà à
nouveau de mesures sociales pour faire
avaler la pilule donc le problème et le
problème c'est que 8 milliards
depuis donc
qu'est-ce qu'elle avait d'abord annoncé
euh une grosse mesure qui coûtait cher
c'est qui coûtait 3 milliards 3,1
milliard c'était pour que les personnes
en invalidité et en inaptitude
continuent à partir tôt à 62 ans donc là
vous me dites on a je récapitule on fait
17 milliards d'économies il y a déjà 13
milliards de déficits il nous reste
environ 4 milliards alors on emprunte on
en prend trois déjà
édité inaptitude pour qu'elle continue à
partir à 62 ans
elle avait pris aussi 600 millions
d'euros pour élargir le dispositif
carrière longue vous savez ce dispositif
qui permet aux gens qui ont commencé tôt
de partir tôt donc déjà elle avait un
peu élargi ça prenait 600 millions
d'euros bon ça c'était au moment de la
présentation le 10 janvier et puis
ensuite il y a eu le passage en conseil
des ministres le texte est arrivé en
conseil des ministres et là ils ont
rajouté la revalorisation des petites
retraites à 1200 euros non seulement
pour les futurs retraités les nouveaux
retraités
ceux qui sont déjà à la retraite et ceux
qui vont y arriver
à tous ceux qui sont déjà à la retraite
vous avez beaucoup de monde et là ça
coûte un milliard 8 d'accord
ce weekend avant même que le débat
s'engage à l'Assemblée la première
ministre d'ailleurs
pas beaucoup d'observateurs se sont
interrogés pourquoi a-t-elle fait de
nouvelles concessions avant même
pourquoi griller ces cartouches avant
même que le débat s'engage elle a lâché
sur les jeunes ayant commencé avant 21
ans là aussi bon c'est pas le dispositif
ne travaille pas 40 kilos pas 44 ans de
cotisations mais 43 ans et ça ça coûte
600 millions d'euros par an en début de
au début quand la mesure commence à
s'appliquer mais en période de croisière
une fois que c'est bien monté en charge
ça coûte 1 milliard d'euros par an donc
vous voyez à coup d'un milliard par
semaine
alors on approche aujourd'hui quasiment
les 8 milliards de dépenses nouvelles ça
fait presque la moitié des économies on
avait 4 milliards de marge on a 8
milliards de dépenses on a nouveau en
déficit on continue à en parler
Marie-Cécile juste un instant on va sur
le terrain alors que vous voyez ces
images bon quelques violences quelques
dégradations pour l'instant ça ne semble
pas si grave que ça nous dans les dans
les heures qui viennent Damien Canivez
vous êtes place de la République avec
des de jeunes manifestants ils sont
encore loin de l'artrad j'ai
l'impression
absolument je me trouve Place de la
République alors n'ayez crainte il y a
de la fumée derrière moi mais c'est lié
à quelques grillades pour restaurer les
manifestants je suis effectivement avec
Renault qui est étudiant en sciences po
bonjour Renault bonjour je suis
également avec loan loan qui elle était
étudiante également bonjour Alors vous
deux vous manifestez contre la réforme
des retraites pourtant vous en êtes
assez loin en tant qu'étudiant non oui
après voilà je pense que c'est un
rapport au monde du travail ça rapporte
une réforme en particulier qui que
représente une idéologie donc on est on
est loin de la retraite pour nous on
n'est pas l'un des cotisations ça c'est
clair on n'est pas loin de et on a on a
évidemment des proches des des parents
qui seront impactés par cette réforme
des grands-parents qui sera impactés par
le rapport aux pensions donc on en est
loin individuellement mais pas
collectivement et je crois que c'est un
peu l'idée de la manifestation aussi et
vous l'OM qu'est-ce qui vous embête dans
cette réforme
ce qui m'embête c'est que on pourrait le
gouvernement pour essayer de trouver de
la thune de l'argent ailleurs chez les
personnes les plus riches ou augmentant
par exemple par rapport à l'ISF etc il y
a beaucoup d'autres moyens que de faire
cette réforme et en fait cette réforme
peut rendre malade des personnes faire
travailler des personnes trop vieilles
des personnes malades des favoriser les
femmes et il y a beaucoup d'autres
manières de trouver de l'argent que que
faire cette réforme quoi vous avez
vraiment l'impression que c'est très
fort mais le défavorise les femmes oui
parce qu'en fait c'est des femmes
beaucoup de femmes en situation de
précarité dans en fin d'âge etc et bah
clairement c'est prouvé que ça
défavorise des femmes les auto
franchement la la réforme défavorise les
carragées ça a été avoué d'ailleurs par
le gouvernement lui-même et les femmes
ont des carnachées parce que une partie
des femmes ont accès à la maternité ce
qui est quand même une chance une chance
pour la pour la société en général on a
quand même besoin d'internité et les
laisser le droit des femmes avoir une
analyse protégée et le fait qu'elle soit
pénalisée à la fin de leur vie et encore
plus pour une nouvelle réforme alors que
les productivités augmentent le le le
augmente on devrait moins travailler
avoir une un travail qui est plus
respectueux de des nouvelles formes de
vie des nouvelles formes de productivité
et pas travailler jusqu'à 64 ans pour
les professions intellectuelles c'est
pas forcément un problème et c'est pas
ça qui nous dérange dans les femmes
c'est pas le fait que les gens qui
travaillent dans un bureau toute leur
vie des journalistes ou même des gens
qui travaillent dans le gouvernement
travaillent très tard c'est l'élephaël
que des gens qui soient dans des
catégories défavorisées qui ont des
métiers pénibles sur des favoriser et
soit encore les personnes qui vont qui
vont payer
à chaque réforme et je pense que c'est
pas la première femme comme ça ça sera
pas la dernière si on si on en croit à
peu près tout le monde donc faut pas
forcément se laisser faire à chaque fois
et je crois que c'est un peu le moment
où regarder il y a des gens quoi les
gens manifestent de manière pacifique il
y a pas de pas il y a une mobilisation
populaire c'est c'est un rapport de
force est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
que le monde étudiant est en train de
bouger contre la réforme des retraites
c'est une bonne question j'ai
l'impression que oui il y a quand même
des blocages qui se multiplient moi je
suis à Sciences Po donc c'est pas
forcément la traditionnellement
l'université la plus mobilisée
mais il y a quand même une
immobilisation là on voit que les
manifestations c'est pas les
manifestations traditionnelles
forcément de la gauche parce que parfois
c'est un petit peu ça on se réunion
entre eux on est tous contents mais là
il y a une manifestation d'un public
assez large et des jeunes de un peu de
partout donc oui il y a le mobilisation
qui me paraît assez large et notamment
dans le monde université et parmi vos
camarades pareil vous avez l'impression
que c'est en train de bouger que le
mouvement est en train de d'être
contagieux je pense que c'est en train
d'être contagieux parce que je vois de
plus de plus de personnes qui en parlent
de plus en plus de personnes qui disent
bah en fait on en a marre que le
gouvernement continue à la proposer que
tout ça s'est passé encore et leur
discours c'est de dire même si par
exemple il y en a qui ont pas l'occasion
de venir manifestations par exemple
celle de Paris à cause de transport aux
habitants etc je pense qu'en fait ça
l'idée se propage en général les
chiffres même augmentent sur le fait de
Français qui sont posés à la réforme et
les étudiants fait partie de ça de ces
chiffres là qui c'est de plus en plus
opposés tu connais pas ils avaient pas
trop d'idées sur ce qui se passe sauf
que là ça fait tellement de ça plusieurs
semaines que ça en cours on commence à
se renseigner on commence à aussi
propager la parole autour de nous et à
dire qu'en fait bah regarder c'est pas
bien ce qui se passe mais cette réforme
il faut pas la faire et bien merci Loane
merci Renaud et effectivement on peut
filmer votre votre carton qui est d'une
sobriété incroyable non merci mais au
moins ça le mérite d'être clair voilà
Thibault je me trouve effectivement à
l'entrée de la place de la République
doit être de cortège vient de passer
juste derrière moi donc on se dirige
vers la place de la Bastille
non merci c'est toujours mieux qu'est-ce
que
sympathiques ces deux jeunes mais pour
vous disent n'importe quoi c'est ça
mais
voilà ça je suis frappé par certains
propos quand ils disent bon oui ça
posera peut-être des problèmes à nos
parents et nos grands-parents en fait
les jeunes ne se rendent pas compte que
cette réforme elle est faite pour eux
parce que si on ne fait pas cette
réforme c'est eux c'est c'est la future
génération qui aura des retraites très
très faibles et cette réforme elle est
faite aussi pour ne pas leur laisser une
dette qu'ils devront apurer parce que
toutes les dettes elles doivent être
remboursées et quand on fait un déficit
on dit qu'en 2030 il y aura 13,5
milliards de déficits les déficits ils
sont ils sont
reportés enfin porté par la cadèse la
caisse d'amortissement de la dette
sociale et elle doit rembourser c'est un
c'est pas de l'argent qui part en fait
il faut rembourser les déficitations
pourquoi on tape sur les pauvres on
enlevé l'ISF et ça ça monte ça dans
l'opinion publique alors c'est peut-être
de la non mais c'est peut-être de la de
la démagogie mais vous pouvez pas marrer
Cécile me dire que ce n'est pas un
sentiment que beaucoup de Français ont
aujourd'hui j'entends la jeune fille qui
dit il y a qu'à trouver de l'argent
ailleurs si c'est des gens de dire si
c'était si simple ça serait déjà fait
c'est pas si simple de trouver de
l'argent ailleurs dans une telle mesure
augmenter les cotisations des
entreprises ça serait une autre solution
mais les cotisations mais les
entreprises françaises ont déjà parmi
les plus taxés donc ça renchérit le coup
du travail et donc ça se retourne contre
l'emploi le chômage voilà l'idée c'est
pas de durcir le marché du travail et en
plus si on augmente les cotisations ça
diminue ça pèse aussi cette question
l'employeur mais aussi sur le salarié et
donc ça réduit le pouvoir d'achat des
actifs donc en période d'inflation et de
de pouvoir d'achat ça n'est pas une
solution réduire les pensions des
retraités la pension des retraités la
pension moyenne elle est à 1400 euros
brut donc
il y a pas non plus les retraités les
plus aisés et souvent plus riche que les
actifs en France
quand on compare
quand on compare aux autres pays
européens et cette ce niveau de vie des
retraités il va baisser c'est inscrit
parce que les pensions ont baissé en
relatif par rapport au pouvoir des par
rapport au pouvoir au salaire des actifs
donc de toute façon le pouvoir d'achat
des retraités va baisser
donc trouver de l'argent ailleurs
j'entends les syndicats disent égaliser
les salaires hommes femmes soit mais
vous rendez bien compte que ça c'est une
une mesure qui est difficile à mettre en
place et longue et souvent les salaires
des femmes sont aussi inférieurs à ceux
des hommes parce que les femmes
travaillent moins sont plus souvent à
temps partiel ou à mi-temps enfin vous
voyez donc il y a pas de baguette
magique de solution magique sinon bah
elles auraient été appliquées on voit
ces images depuis la place de la
République en hauteur avec
certains manifestants cagoulés en noir
qui s'en prennent visiblement à ce
restaurant de gastronomie américaine qui
commence par Mac et qui finit par Donald
et qui vient être protégé par les forces
de l'ordre voilà d'ailleurs pour être
totalement honnête tout à l'heure je
vous disais que le gouvernement donc
multiplier les concessions et par la
même les dépenses donc il accorde de
plein de mesures sociales
d'accompagnement qui coûte cher et qui
prennent sur les économies attendues de
la réforme mais pour être honnête ils
essaient aussi de trouver des leviers de
financement à côté donc la première
ministre a dit nous trouverons les
moyens de financer ces nouvelles
concessions je rappelle pour ceux qui
nous rejoignent parce que c'était il y a
presque 10 minutes Marie-Cécile vous
êtes en train de m'expliquer que cette
réforme avait pour but de faire des
économies 17,7
à l'horizon 2030 qu'il y avait à ce
moment-là environ 13,2 milliards de
déficits ce qui donnait une marge
d'environ 4 milliards sauf qu'il y a eu
plusieurs mesures qui ont bien réduit
cette cette marge
alourdi la facture et donc finalement
nous serions encore en 2030 en déficit
alors on essaye de trouver de l'argent
ailleurs comment on fait
donc là le gouvernement
veut revenir sur bon c'est un peu
technique mais sur les cotisations
applicables en cas de rupture
conventionnelle donc il y a un forfait
de 20% si c'est avant l'âge légal 30% si
c'est après et ensuite quand il y a une
mise à la retraite d'office à partir de
67 ans c'est 50% donc ils ont décidé de
mettre un forfait à 30% pour tout le
monde bon l'objectif c'est l'objectif
premier c'est d'inciter les entreprises
à garder leur seniors mais au passage ça
fait rentrer 200 à 250 millions d'euros
dans les caisses et voyez c'est une
petite somme par rapport aux dépenses
qui sont engagées donc
ça suffit pas on est loin du compte et
j'interrogeais Matignon qui me disait
mais il va y avoir dans le débat
parlementaire des mesures de recettes
qui vont apparaître il a encore trop
temps trop tôt pour pour trancher on va
voir ce que il y a quand même un
problème et c'est toujours c'est
toujours la difficulté avec des réformes
c'est que il n'est pas trop de mesures
d'accompagnement qui viennent
grignoter les économies attendues
est-ce que ça en refroidisse certains
de voter cette réforme je pense à la
droite notamment en même temps la droite
a largement poussé pour avoir plus de
mesures sucrées comme ça qu'on les
appelle alors il y a des partisans à
ardent de la réforme qui finissent par
se demander si le jeu en vaut la
chandelle si la force de concession
voilà il faudrait pas que les
concessions pour quelques-uns
pénalisent les efforts réalisés par tous
donc
quant à la droite c'est vrai à droite de
la droite mais la droite elle est
diviséeau qui dit non mais c'est
n'importe quoi on a plus d'argent et
c'est d'autres à droite qui disent oui
mais il faut pas
qu'ils ont d'ailleurs poussé pour les
minimum à 1200 euros voilà donc on est
face à une droite qui a perdu la tête et
qui ne sait plus quoi voter en même
temps à la fin bon alors Bruno
Retailleau qui est donc au Sénat
président du groupe LR au Sénat depuis
des années enfin qui qui prône le
sérieux budgétaire qui depuis des années
propose d'augmenter l'âge de des parents
retraite à chaque vote du PLFSS du
budget de la Sécu à l'automne lui bien
sûr il regarde il regarde les comptes
alors c'est vrai qu'il a poussé pour une
revalorisation des petites retraites
parce que ça c'est dans l'ADN de la
droite c'est valoriser le travail c'est
faire en sorte que quelqu'un qui a
travaillé toute sa vie il est quand même
à la retraite une pension supérieure à
celui qui a passé toute sa vie enfin qui
n'a rien fait et qui vit du minimum
vieillesse d'allocations vous voyez
qu'il y a un écart suffisant entre les
deux comme ça il l'a défendu en revanche
il est il est un peu consterné par les
demandes au sein de son propre groupe et
il met en garde ses propres camarades
députés à l'Assemblée notamment monsieur
Pradier qui demande lors de la les
élections de la présidence à la présence
des républicains était contre le report
de HDL à 64 ans
parce que là à chaque fois qu'il demande
une mesure et qu'il obtient satisfaction
en fait après il en demande une autre et
c'est vraiment l'équilibre l'équilibre
financier de la réforme qui qui qui va
finir par être mis à mal
quels sont selon vous les les prochaines
étapes de ces manifestations vers quoi
va évoluer le mouvement donc c'est ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure il va
y avoir une forme de ventre mou a priori
pendant les vacances avec déjà samedi il
y aura plus de monde c'est le dernier le
dernier coup de collier avant les
vacances non probablement qu'il y aura
un peu plus de monde parce que il y a
des gens qui n'ont pas voulu prendre une
journée là perdre une journée de salaire
et qui se sont dit j'irai la
manifestation samedi l'idée des
syndicats c'est de pouvoir allier des
gens qui voilà qui travaillent qui ne
peuvent pas s'absenter
mais après il y a les vacances scolaires
qui vont s'enclencher les débats il y a
les vacances parlementaires aussi la
semaine du 21
[Musique]
donc il va y avoir un peu une je pense
une retombée un peu du soufflé avant un
durcissement des limaces puisque les
débats après le texte va arriver au
Sénat en commission des affaires
sociales puis à dans l'hémicyclo Sénat
puis s'il y a pas d'accord il y aura une
CMP et ensuite le texte revient à
l'Assemblée tout ça nous porte jusqu'à
fin mars 26 mars et donc il est probable
que en mars il est ingurcissement avec
peut-être la menace de grève
reconductible de blocages voilà donc une
peut-être un ventre moule en février et
puis un durcissement en mars la place de
la République qui est en train
progressivement de se remplir avant que
le cortège ne se dirige vers la place de
la Bastille vous voyez ces images de
notre envoyé spécial Julien Leclerc elle
est avec Damien est-ce qu'on retrouvera
dans un instant avec ses forces de
l'ordre qui ont protégé quelques
boutiques emblèmes du capitalisme on le
sait oui
tout ce que je vous dis personne n'a de
boule de cristal et c'est très difficile
de prévoir ce qui va se passer
la météo sociale c'est toujours très
imprévisible il suffit qu'il y ait un
événement enfin voilà
personne ne peut dire il faut avoir
l'humilité de reconnaître que personne
ne peut savoir comment tout cela va
partir est-ce qu'on peut mesurer on aura
dans quelques instants suffisent ravinal
qui était au début de la manifestation
elle nous dira ce qu'elle a vu notamment
devant là où se trouve les leaders
politiques et syndicaux est-ce qu'on
s'est mesuré l'impact que peut avoir une
journée de grâce sur l'économie
alors il y avait l'économiste Mark
Touati qui disait que chaque jour ouvré
revient à environ 10 milliards d'euros
de PIB la production et donc
il y a 200
on prend s'il y a une baisse d'activité
de 15 à 20 % dans le cas d'une grève
dure
bien ça coûte à l'économie française au
moins un milliard d'euros en tenant
compte du réajustement dans les jours
qui suivent vous voyez d'accord donc un
milliard d'euros par jour de grève par
jour
mais tous les économies sont pas
d'accord chez Rex et code de nifférent
estime que les retombées
macroéconomiques sont somme tout assez
limitées que ça en revanche c'est vrai
que journée de grève dure ça peut coûter
très cher à certaines entreprises je
pense notamment à la SNCF on a vu au
moment de Noël avec les billets
remboursés à 200%
allait évalué à 100 millions d'euros
[Musique]
une sorte de CRS ou des gendarmes
mobiles s'approchaient et protéger
certaines boutiques quelques petites
tensions même si ça n'a pas éclaté vous
me confirmez
Thibault sur la place de la République
il y a quelques minutes il y a eu
quelques échauffourés qui ont éclaté
effectivement entre des manifestants et
les forces de l'ordre qui comme d'un
seul homme sont sortis des rues
parallèles à la place de la République
pour venir ceinturer une banque
notamment qui se trouve sur cette
fameuse place parisienne et assez vite
ils sont retournés dans les rues qui se
trouvent juste derrière moi d'ailleurs
vous les voyez juste derrière moi ils
sont en train de de suivre la
manifestation mais c'est encadré de
façon assez habile parce que on ne les
voit pas on sait qu'il y a 4000 forces
de l'ordre qui sont présents qui sont
présentes dans dans la capitale et on
les a pas vu à part là pendant ces
quelques moments de tension place de la
République bon il faut quand même
souligner les quelques rares dégâts
qu'il y a eu une poubelle brûlée
quelques manifestants qui ont envoyé
voulait agiter en tout cas le défilé
mais pour le moment ça se passe toujours
dans une ambiance assez cordiale on sent
malgré tout beaucoup de destination chez
les manifestants j'ai discuté tout à
l'heure brièvement avec un ouvrier qui
travaille à la chaîne qui m'expliquait
que pour lui c'était très compliqué de
joindre des deux bouts un peu comme le
pompier que l'on a eu l'occasion de
d'interroger tout à l'heure et que si
demain il devait y avoir une grève
reconductible et bien il participerait
donc on sent vraiment une détermination
chez les manifestants ici qui est assez
palpable et voilà la manifestation se
poursuit pour le moment il y a le
cortège de la CFDT qui passe juste
devant mes yeux et on va les suivre et
revenir vers vous assez vite cher
Thibault
merci d'avoir été niaise place de la
République dans le cortège parisien qui
se dirige vers Bastille Sophie ravignel
bonjour bonjour Figaro politique grands
reporter vous suivez la gauche pour le
pour Le Figaro alors cette magnifique il
y avait Jean-Luc Mélenchon absolument
cette fois-ci il était à Paris il était
deux dernières fois alors il était à
Marseille
une des manifestations délocalisées
entre guillemets
enfin ailleurs en France son ancienne
circonscription en l'occurrence et c'est
là où il retourne absolument il a été
longtemps au moins Amanda on dirait pas
mal bougé dans toute la France
et la semaine prochaine enfin samedi ce
samedi il sera de nouveau à Marseille à
Marseille
aujourd'hui rapide oui il était garde de
Lyon j'ai vu ah oui trois quarts d'heure
combien il a été accueilli ecoutez
plutôt bien j'étais avec des députés
femmes écologistes à qui je disais tiens
tiens je cherche Jean-Luc Mélenchon où
est-il et puis je voyais des caméras au
loin il doit être par là vous voulez pas
aller le non n'est pas spécialement
tenté
il y a voilà mais enfin tout le monde
était là et tout le monde beaucoup de
Parlement alors oui ça ça m'intéresse
qu'il y avait des questions au
Gouvernement cet après-midi comment et
finalement les bandes de la gauche
étaient assez assez remplis donc ils se
sont répartis
sachant que certains sont restés
[Musique]
une 30 il y a eu tout un cortège qui est
parti de l'Assemblée nationale à 13h30
de députés de la nupesse et qui se sont
rendus à l'Opéra c'est quoi c'est 20
minutes à pieds bien marche-en
tranquillement peut-être plutôt il fait
beau donc il fait très très froid en
revanche mais il fait beau et donc ils
ont fait ce petit cortège de de voilà de
l'Assemblée jusqu'à l'opéra et ensuite
ils se sont retrouvés dans leurs
différents points fixes parce que comme
depuis toujours d'ailleurs dans les
manifestations sociales les cortèges
politiques et syndicaux ne se mélangent
pas les politiques toujours pas c'est
déjà arrivé non
vraiment c'est la barrière
et on ne verra pas en dehors des cortège
mais alors ils sont très sourcils les
uns et les autres au respect voilà il y
a eu une tentative on l'a dit plusieurs
fois ici de fait le 19 janvier donc
place de la République une tentative de
la part des parlementaires politiques et
notamment d'un petit groupe d'entre eux
qui avaient vu les syndicats au
Parlement d'aller saluer donc les
centrales syndicales qui défilaient Unis
donc une première depuis 2010 et Laurent
Berger donc de là CFDT ne l'a pas
souhaité il ne l'a pas plus souhaité la
semaine suivante 10 jours après donc le
31 janvier avec un départ place d'Italie
où là les politiques n'ont pas tenté
cette fois-ci d'aller
parce que je me souviens il y a quelques
années on a écouté Olivier fort tout à
l'heure il y a quelques années Olivier
fort il n'était pas du tout le bienvenu
dans certaines manifestations 2019
c'était absolument et c'était les
résultats entre guillemets du
quinquennat François Hollande avec les
manifestations loi travail et donc le le
Parti socialiste n'avait pas encore
complètement
lancé sa révision
cette digestion du quinquennat de
François Hollande
il peut s'entendre du côté des
manifestants qu'Emmanuel Macron était
l'enfant de François Hollande dans sa
droite lignée ou gaucher
dans les distinguaux au sein de la
nupette où il y a un rejet de cette
partie du Parti socialiste qui
considère que François Hollande a fait
un très bon quinquennat et du coup voilà
une séparation entre les deux Bastille
qui va se remplir progressivement tout à
l'heure avec l'arrivée des manifestants
vous avez senti quoi cet après-midi par
rapport aux autres manifs du monde de la
tension qui a changé
après ils s'en vont et surtout
aujourd'hui parce que il y avait aussi
une minute de silence au Parlement à
laquelle souhaitait beaucoup participer
donc les les parlementaires de la nuit
vers 13h30 de 14h ils sont retournés aux
alentours de 14h45 le 15h à l'Assemblée
nationale pour 7 minutes de silence pour
les victimes à des tremblements de terre
en Syrie et en Turquie OK et du coup le
pour vous répondre le cortège c'est
toujours difficile de comparer les
cortèges ils ont à chaque fois des
circuits différents mais ce qu'on a
observé y compris dans les villes de en
région et dans des villes moyennes c'est
qu'il y a une baisse de la mobilisation
alors j'ai beaucoup interrogé les
politiques à ce sujet qui eux n'y voit
rien que de très normal je vous ai une
interview apparaître bientôt dans le
Figaro ce matin d'Alexis Corbière qui me
disait absolument et un peu figure
frondeuse au sein de la France insoumise
face à Jean-Luc Mélenchon
des petits frères des socialistes qui
eux-mêmes ont été fondés
et du coup il me disait mais dans les
mobilisations sociales il y a toujours
donc des des sommets et puis on arrive
sur un plateau parfois ça descend avant
de remonter sur un autre plateau voilà
en fait ce que les uns et les autres
disent de façon assez unanime c'est que
cette fois-ci il y a eu c'est quand même
la troisième mobilisation en semaine
il y a eu cette proposition de la part
des syndicats de marché un samedi samedi
prochain et c'est vrai que la
perspective de marché samedi
a pu décourager un certain nombre de de
personnes à marcher aujourd'hui une
journée aujourd'hui et perdre de
l'argent alors que je peux manifester
quand même beaucoup dans le portefeuille
des Français et certains donc on
cherchait à alléger un peu ça et puis il
y a peut-être aussi le fait que et bien
le gouvernement l'exécutif passe
voilà de de de de va vouloir imposer sa
réforme on ne sait pas très bien encore
jusqu'où ça pourra aller si Emmanuel
Macron va aller jusqu'au bout de quelle
façon est-ce que oui ou non il y a une
crainte au sein de l'exécutif de perdre
un peu la main mon hémicycle c'est pas
complètement clair vous avez raison de
parler de l'hémicycle parce qu'il y a
ces images aujourd'hui de la
manifestation à Paris et puis il y a ce
qu'il se passe à l'Assemblée vous étiez
à l'Assemblée au nom vous avez regardé
la différence entre vous et moi vous
êtes au service c'est un peu ma charge
voilà alors on explique ce qu'il s'est
passé hier la première heure
lui passait toute la journée toute la
soirée là-bas et nous en fonction des
parties qu'on suit on reprend plus ou
moins certaines heures
il faut le maîtriser dès qu'on a fini
dedans comme je viens de le faire oui
surtout de donc ça a commencé à 16h de
16h à 17h bazar sans nom à l'Assemblée
nationale sans rentrer dans des choses
justement de soyez pas trop de technique
parce que je peux pas nous internet
m'expliquer on va essayer de voilà il y
a eu des émotions référendaires des
textes présentés par les parties de
l'opposition pour s'opposer donc à la
réforme j'essaye d'être assez simple il
y en a eu deux qui ont été présentés
celui du RN mais avant celui de la
nupette celui de la nupette a eu plus de
signatures mais en ce moment tout est un
petit peu nouveau enfin disons que la
façon dont sont menées les débats dans
une assemblée nationale qui n'est plus
avec la majorité absolue pour le
principal partie c'est assez disons
inédit et donc il y a des processus qui
sont assez inédits et normalement
d'émotions référendaires il n'y en a pas
deux qui sont déposés or cette fois-ci
il y en a eu deux et donc il a fallu que
la présidente c'est très simple c'est
pour demander à ce qu'un texte soit
examiné en référendum c'est ça c'est
pour résumé absolument pour que ce soit
demander à fort que ce soit proposé en
référendum et donc cette fois-ci
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ben il y a le
bon Pivet présidente de de l'Assemblée à
improviser à décider un tirage au sort
bon le tirage au sort a donné raison au
rassemblement national et la news
proteste parce qu'ils affirment avoir
été les premiers à déposer le texte et
avoir déposer avec le plus de signatures
bon et qu'est-ce qui s'est passé hier il
y a eu Charles Amédée de Courson qui est
très attaché à la démocratie qui est
très attachée aux institutions qui fait
partie d'un groupe un petit groupe un
peu avec des anciens socialistes avec
des centristes un peu au banc un peu
bizarre
comme il en existe souvent à l'Assemblée
territoire des centristes indépendants
des anciens socialistes et donc lui en
fait partie voilà et il en fait partie
et il est sans doute leur meilleur
porte-parole parce que il a décidé il a
de présenter enfin avec son groupe une
troisième motion référendelle et
effectivement selon les textes de
l'Assemblée cette troisième motion
aurait dû provoquer un nouveau tirage au
sort puisqu'il a été présenté dans les
temps ce que vous me dites selon le
règlement de l'Assemblée je les ai vu
hier tout avec leur petit carnet le
héros et dire rappelle au règlement le
règlement ils avaient tous l'impression
de le connaître à droite à gauche au
centre
qui a raison alors j'ai essayé de savoir
aussi ce qu'on me dit c'est que un peu
tout le monde c'est-à-dire que à la fois
charmer l'idée de Courson a raison dans
le sens où quand il y a une situation
nouvelle la tradition à l'Assemblée veut
que les solutions soient trouvées avec
un consensus et donc que le bureau des
présidents et aurait dû bravo aurait dû
à minima se rassembler pour décider un
tirage au sort ou non mais voilà il y
aurait dû y avoir au moins se
rassemblement cette petite réunion à 16h
Grand Bazar les députés de la campagne a
refusé cette réunion du bureau des donc
la gauche proteste dit qu'elle ne veut
pas qu'elle veut voir sa motion
référendaire celle de jade en fait il
s'agissait de juste de de faire en sorte
que ça l'idiote soit examinée parce que
tous les parties RN et nups confondues
ce serait mis derrière mais évidemment
on comprend euh l'exécutif qui n'avait
aucune envie de voir avancer cette
notion référendaire oui aucune envie de
voir cette notion avancée sauf que on a
perdu du temps pour absolument rien
puisqu'il n'y avait il faut le dire
Sophie aucune chance que cette motion ne
passe et qu'un jour moins que le
gouvernement ne le veuille mais
vraisemblablement pas le cas très très
peu de chance que cette motion passe et
donc que les Français soient amenés à
voter pour ou contre cette réforme dans
un référendum donc on a perdu une heure
autour de cette question impossible
qu'il y a les brunes Pivet donc les
présidents
les français pour un jour dans les deux
mois qui viennent pour révolter un
référendum ah oui je ne suis pas ce que
j'allais vous dire c'est que je ne suis
pas certaine qu'elle n'était pas
satisfaite que l'on perde du temps parce
qu'elle n'était pas forcément certaines
parce que dans la soirée elle a
largement largement donné la place à
toutes les interventions des uns et des
autres inégales mais toute relativement
intéressante et donc il n'était pas
exclu qu'elle est une petite crainte de
ne pas avoir de majorité sur le premier
article et donc c'est intéressant parce
que moi je interdire je me dis ça y est
la nups fait de l'obstruction
parlementaire le RN se frotte les mains
en prenant de la distance
que de la gauche alors ça n'est pas la
faute que de la gauche et puis cette
disons que Charles Medit de Courson il
ne fait pas partie parce qu'il y a eu
des éléments de langage très amusant
j'ai regardé tous les députés de la
majorité présidentielle qui utilisait le
même adjectif il devrait être un petit
peu moins invisible dans leurs éléments
de langage c'est la zalisation du
Parlement donc tout le monde y est allé
de sa réalisation du Parlement de fait
il y a eu vraiment un peu de de bazar
mais c'était pour une bonne raison et
que Courson défendait lui-même mais ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que au sein de
la nups et au sein des insoumis il y a
des lignes divergentes il y a certains
socialistes et certains écologistes qui
n'aiment pas beaucoup la façon avec
laquelle les parlementaires insoumis
veulent absolument
présenter des masses et des masses et
des MAS pour l'instant on est à 7 entre
7 et 10 000 amendements présentés par
les insoumis et y compris chez les
insoumis il y a une tension à savoir si
oui ou non on garde tous ces paquets
d'amendements ou si on les fait sauter
par bloc parce que c'est possible pour
arriver à une étude de cette fameuse
article 7 je rappelle que nous sommes
sur la durée je rappelle que nous sommes
en direct que nous suivons cette journée
de manifestation dans les rues de Paris
ça semble plus clairsemé sans doute
moins de monde les premiers chiffres qui
nous remontent de région tente à prouver
que en effet il y a moins de monde dans
les rues de la capitale et nous parlons
tactique politicienne parce que nous en
sommes là il y a ce qui se passe dans la
rue
parlementaire vous avez raison il y a
aussi ce qu'il se passe à l'Assemblée
nationale les questions au Gouvernement
vous les avez suivi tout à l'heure ont
encore lieu alors on se parle donc il y
a ce bazar hier très physique avec des
députés qui crient qui empêchent le
ministre de parler et tiens une petite
question j'ai vu certains
que ce sont les cadres mais j'ai vu
certaines personnalités à gauche restez
assise sur leur chaise moins revendie
revendiquer moins
physiquement si j'ose dire je pense à
Fabien Roussel qui était comme ça
Olivier Faure lui aussi assis calmement
ce sont parce que ce sont des stars
entre guillemets de la politique et qui
sont visibles ils laissent leur les
députés moins connus mettre le bazar ou
est-ce que non c'est qu'ils sont pas
forcément d'accord avec c'est en train
de se passer alors c'est qu'il y a
parfois effectivement donc des des
divergences sur le mode d'action c'est
clair il y a chez Fabien Roussel chez
Olivier fort chez Valérie rabot aussi
ancienne présidente du groupe socialiste
mais sans doute aussi
chez d'autres chez les écologistes vous
l'avez dit une
volonté et une stratégie une façon
d'aborder le débat parlementaire qui est
qui peut être différente et je discutais
là avec des parlementaires qui me
disaient bon voilà il y a cette ligne de
tension mais les deux général on sait
pas très bien en tout cas moi il y a une
chose que je sais c'est que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon lui assume totalement cette
volonté d'y aller et d'y aller carrément
on l'entendait tout à l'heure dans la
rue j'étais là avec quelques confrères
et il nous disait face à cette reproche
à ce reproche qui qui leur est fait à
tous de transformer l'Assemblée en cours
de récréation lui répond mais nous
n'avons à Jean-Luc Mélenchon à l'adresse
de Jean-Luc à l'adresse pardon
d'Emmanuel Macron
le chef de fil des insoumis dit nous
n'avons
aucune
aucune leçon à recevoir d'Emmanuel
Macron qui met le feu au pays pour sa
propre gloire et uniquement pour aller
faire le Kakou à Davos enfin c'était
elle a une traduction de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui assume totalement de
vouloir entre guillemets comme le dit
Gérald Darmanin bordélisé l'assemblée
avec le bruit hier comme Darmanin c'est
pas moi qui en poster hein à l'Assemblée
hier
euh physiquement avec ses cris et a donc
il y a tous ces amendements déposés j'ai
plusieurs analyses certains du service
politique me disent ces amendements vous
allez voir ils vont sauter au bout d'un
moment
non plus qu'à parce qu'il faut accélérer
et certains me disent NON NON François
vous avez bon moi tout à l'heure vous
allez voir ils vont aller au bout et ils
vont bloquer jusqu'au bout quitte à ce
que cette réforme parte au Sénat sans
avoir été touché moi ce que me dit
Alexis Corbière ce que disent d'autres
parlementaires avec qui je discutais je
parle de lui parce qu'il sera voilà dans
nos pages bientôt mais de fait il y a
une volonté chez les insoumis de
conserver la main d'être un peu face à
Emmanuel Macron eux-mêmes le maître des
horloges et donc avec leur paquet
d'amendements ils peuvent les retirer
quand ils veulent ou les maintenir il y
a des avis divergents sur le fait de
savoir est-ce que ça mérite ou non
d'aller jusqu'à l'article 7 sachant que
cet article 7 est l'article stratégique
sur le report de légal
de départ est fixé à 64 ans voilà et du
coup est-ce que mais en même temps cet
article 7 il est discuté aussi tout au
long de chacun des articles donc les
deux se valent en fait je pense qu'ils
sont en train de voir comment va être la
mobilisation dans la rue et d'essayer de
de gérer ils sont tout à fait capables
moi je dirais que j'ignore si oui ou non
ils vont continuer à faire de
l'obstruction je n'en ai pas la
certitude et il peut vous être le en
même temps de se dire du service
politique du client il y a deux
personnes qui peuvent moduler ces
questions d'amendement se dire les
parlementaires eux-mêmes qui peuvent
décider de les retirer mais aussi à la
présidente de l'Assemblée qui peut
utiliser l'article 100 qui oblige qui
oblige à étudier conjointement des
amendements qui sont extrêmement
similaires d'accord voilà et donc si
elle sort l'artiste
avec trois mots voilà et du coup ça
passe par centaines et donc là elle peut
user de cet article et donc sortir une
arme je l'ignore mais en tout cas elle a
la possibilité de le faire oui parce que
on le sait et vous avez raison de le
préciser il y a de la tactique côté un
swing tactique côté majorité est-ce que
la majorité n'a pas tout intérêt à ce
que ce texte puisqu'on le dit il sera
débattu seulement deux semaines grâce à
un autre article l'article 47 1 c'est
bien ça dans la durée absolument
l'ensemble du texte n'est pas analysé et
bien il part tel quel comme il est
aujourd'hui absolument et d'ailleurs il
y a un débat savoir si oui ou non là
enfin il n'était pas tranché ce matin il
est peut-être cet après-midi mais en
tout cas la question se posait de savoir
si l'assemblée elle est siéger samedi ou
dimanche ce que demande la news et ce
n'était pas acquis ce n'était pas obtenu
et donc ça fait encore deux jours en
moins de débat merci beaucoup Sophie
dravinel il est 17h vous remontez dans
des étages au Figaro parce que vous avez
encore du travail oui c'est ça et on
vous lira demain dans le Figaro et sur
le site Damien canivevez c'est à vous
vous êtes dans la manifestation est-ce
que vous avez quitté
République vous en êtes où
oui absolument on a quitté République on
se trouve vraisemblablement vouloir du
temple et je peux vous assurer qu'il y a
quelques instants les esprits étaient en
train de s'échauffer un petit peu les
policiers sont revenus au niveau de la
manifestation de façon assez rapide en
tout cas c'est impressionnante parce que
voilà il y a eu quelques dégradations
vous le voyez peut-être une mutuelle qui
se trouve juste à côté et
bien cordon de policier à protéger ce
bâtiment de façon à ce qui est pas de de
de dégâts supplémentaires il y a des
abribus qui ont volé en éclat aussi
quelques feux de poubelles mais rien de
très très impressionnant pour l'instant
le cortège continue sa route direction
place de la Bastille on a revissé de
notre côté le casque pendant quelques
instants parce qu'on pensait que ça
allait dégénéré mais finalement les
esprits se sont vite sont vite apaisés
d'autant que il y a un vrai service de
sécurité ici du côté de la manifestation
et des syndicats parce que dès lors que
des individus cagoulés ont commencé à
à s'échauffer en tout cas à essayer de
de
commettre des dégradations à partir de
ce moment-là le service d'ordre de la
des syndicats est intervenu à essayer de
faire en sorte que tout se passe
normalement et que le défilé puisse
suivre son cours donc voilà vous
entendez quelques quelques bons
artisanales qui qui éclatent ici ou là
mais pour l'instant pas d'échaufferait
particulière et je vois la place de la
Bastille à l'horizon donc a priori on
devrait arriver là-bas dans quelques
instants
[Musique]
la manifestation
visiblement il a du monde autour de lui
en tout cas William Pleumeur bonjour
bonjour on a dit au service économie du
Figaro on va entrer dans des tailles de
la réforme parce que c'est parfois
compliqué tiens vous le sentez comment
vous trouvez que
il y a du monde encore ou non ça stagne
et ça baisse et donc la mobilisation et
bien n'est pas si forte que ça non
évidemment ça baisse c'était attendu
les syndicats s'attendaient à une baisse
parce que déjà c'est la première fois
qui qui prévoyait deux dates d'affilée à
savoir ce mardi mais aussi samedi
prochain c'était le souhait de la plus
favorable finalement parce qu'on préfère
manifester un jour on ne perd pas
d'argent exactement plus favorable et
effectivement vraiment différent dans sa
philosophie parce que elle va pas
ramener le même profils de personnes non
a priori ça enfin la CFDT espère
vraiment avoir dans
dans ses harengs et dans les rangs de la
mobilisation de samedi des personnes qui
sont assez différentes soit des
personnes qui n'ont pas encore
manifestées donc c'est ça veut dire des
personnes du service de service de la
propreté enfin des secteurs de la
propreté
restauration du privé oui bien sûr bien
sûr et c'est peut-être des profils qui
manifesteront samedi peut-être
moins habitué aux mobilisation qui sont
effectivement plus dans une démarche
moins radicale que certains grévistes et
effectivement ça pourrait amener des
personnes complètement différentes une
forme de tactique c'est à dire que
on fait grève oui on essaie de bloquer
le pays mais on se rend compte que ça
marche pas si bien que ça alors on fait
grève le samedi tactique gilet jaune
mais d'ailleurs le les syndicats
s'engagent pas et en plus ils veulent
capitaliser sur ça en se disant la
troisième date c'est mardi et samedi
donc c'est le fait c'est dans les faits
ce qu'il souhaite c'est que on dise que
la validation c'est la somme de mardi et
samedi qu'il faut comptabiliser et pas
juste ce mardi parce qu'effectivement
comme vous le disiez il y a moins de
monde il y a moins de monde aujourd'hui
dans la rue
dans les dans les rangs des syndicats on
nous dit qu'il y a au moins 15 à 20% de
personnes en moins
c'est significatif c'est un petit c'est
moins que que la première date du du 19
janvier après ça reste quand même assez
assez important c'est c'est ce que
disait François Hollande ce matin avant
de démarrer en tête du cortège il disait
que on restait sur un fait un mouvement
qui était quand même d'une ampleur
historique et inédite donc effectivement
historique
inédits sont dans leur rôle de
communication et d'essayer de faire
monter la sauce est-ce que tous les
syndicats sont sur la même longueur
d'onde vous avez dit il y a un instant
la CFDT espère que samedi il y aura un
public différent c'est-à-dire que c'est
la CFDT qui décide pour l'instant alors
c'est la CFDT enfin
veut pas entendre dire que que qu'il est
chef d'orchestre mais mais dans les
faits c'est c'est vraiment son son
syndicat qui qui a la baguette car
depuis depuis le début depuis le 10
janvier c'est lui qui a pris la parole
le 10 janvier à la sortie de
l'interdicale et c'est et c'est c'est
c'est c'est justement les représentants
syndicaux qui avaient voulu que ce soit
lui parce que il a la tête du premier
syndicat de France c'est c'est plus
d'adhérents et effectivement il est
quand même à la baguette dans le sens où
on sait que la CGT a des vérité d'aller
plus fort solidaire aussi
il faut serait prêt aussi à rejoindre
les deux autres organisations de
salariés mais Laurent Berger et ses
lieutenant donc les personnes qui sont
vraiment dans dans l'intercyndicale
essaye vraiment de calmer les ardeurs de
ces syndicats plus radicaux dans le sens
où ils estiment que la mobilisation et
le seul vecteur qui peut faire plier le
gouvernement
plus plus la mauvaise sur montre plus
personne exactement et donc
ils ont raison parce que il y avait du
monde les deux dernières lors des deux
dernières manifestations le gouvernement
a pas vraiment pris c'est c'est dur à
dire mais effectivement on peut on peut
imaginer que non ce soit pas suffisant
et qu'effectivement la CGT qui pousse
pour avoir des plus de blocages de
paralysie et vraiment bloquer les
Français effectivement ça aura
certainement plus de poids auprès du
gouvernement alors est-ce que c'est une
question de calendrier est-ce que cette
paralysie ces blocage surviendront plus
tard parce qu'on rappelle que les
vacances débutent et alors effectivement
alors samedi samedi soir donc interdit
de syndical va se réunir et ça va être
un moment vraiment charnière dans le
sens où
on a fait quatre dates on a mis du monde
dans la dans la rue mais le gouvernement
n'a pas bougé d'un iota sur sa réforme
ont rien donné donc effectivement dans
les rangs de la mobilisation ce matin
solidaire et nous disait clairement oui
là on va demander à aller sur de la
grève une mobilisation plus dure et on
le voit on le voit aujourd'hui il y a
moins il y a moins de mobilisation il y
a moins de grévistes en revanche par
exemple dans les raffineries on voit que
le taux de grévise niveau de grévistes
et
assez équivalent à ce qu'il y a eu la
semaine dernière donc effectivement dans
des secteurs stratégiques effectivement
alors peut-être un peu moins de
transport parce que le transport est un
peu différent
de transport et qui nous disait ils
attendent mais exactement ce sont eux
qui sont à la pointe des de ce genre de
mouvement là pour l'instant mais
justement l'énergie et les raffineries
aussi et les raffineries là ont un petit
peu durci le thon on sait que c'est une
grosse crainte du gouvernement de voir
les les stations essence à vide on l'a
connu en octobre en novembre dernier
dans les dans les travées des des
ministères on on a une vraie crainte de
de ce de ce scénario qui qui reviendrait
et effectivement
en février en pleine vacances scolaire
ce serait très problématique
après effectivement l'autre challenge
pour les syndicats de ce samedi ça va ça
va être effectivement de composer avec
avec la avec les vacances scolaire bien
sûr parce qu'on va moins mobiliser ça va
être plus embêtant et effectivement
aussi s'il y a des mouvements de grève
au niveau de des transports qu'on me
disait à la SNCF ça va être pénalisant
pour les Français et les syndicats ne
veulent pas perdre l'opinion publique
c'est ça parce que pour l'instant les
Français sont favorables sont favorables
alors retrait de la réforme
grève plutôt contre la réforme
exactement c'est une nuance qui est mais
qui a du poids dans le sens où
effectivement le c'est tout l'enjeu de
la CFDT dans l'insert syndical c'est
garder l'opinion publique avec eux là où
on sait que c'est un équilibre subtil
parce qu'il faut à la fois garder
l'opinion publique et à la fois faire
plier le gouvernement hors pour faire
pilier le gouvernement il faut bloquer
le pays et donc
forcément
embêter les Français exactement le
l'équilibre est dur à trouver ça va être
tout le challenge des des des syndicats
ce samedi et effectivement on sait pas
encore trop à quoi s'attendre parce
qu'on de manière générale on savait
qu'il y aurait un ventre mou en février
et que que que la mobilisation
reprendrait certainement plus surtout
sur ce manifestations de de ce mardi on
verra samedi mardi alors samedi c'est un
vrai test aussi parce que c'est la
première fois qu'on a une mobilisation
le le week-end et c'était le pari donc
comme je disais de la CFDT et si ce pari
n'est pas gagnant ici effectivement il y
a moins de monde on peut imaginer que la
CGT que solide solidaire et et tous les
syndicats plus radicaux disent bon à la
CFDT on vous a suivi pendant 4 journée
voilà maintenant on y va voilà est-ce
qu'il vous étiez dans les manifestations
est-ce qu'il y a une crainte de
débordement pour l'instant c'est bien
tenu
qu'est-ce que ça pourrait changer là
aussi perdre l'opinion publique mais
alors ouais est-ce que les est-ce que
les syndicats on l'a vu sur les
premières manifs on fait ce qu'il
fallait pour pas qu'il y ait le
département est-ce qu'ils vont continuer
à le faire oui parce que je pense que
c'est dans l'intérêt même la CGT la le
sait quand c'est une grande mobilisation
une manifestation il faut pas
débordement
Laurent Berger a dit en début de semaine
aller sur une radicalisation des
casseurs tout ça ce serait donné un
cadeau au gouvernement
pour mettre justement l'opinion publique
derrière enfin contre donc non ils ont
vraiment pas envie que ça détourner le
débat exactement ils veulent vraiment
que le débat reste sur la réforme des
retraites et que effectivement ne pas
perdre de vue que c'est un combat qui se
gagnera dans l'unité et pas contre les
Français pas contre contre même enfin
effectivement c'est la CGT a des envies
mais elle respecte quand même pour
l'instant le le calendrier émis par la
je voudrais qu'on parle William un tout
petit peu technique de cette réforme je
vous êtes penché ce matin dans Le Figaro
avec Marie-Cécile Renaud sur
ce que doit rapporter la réforme
théoriquement et
elle se pourrait qu'elle n'arrive pas à
atteindre ses objectifs ouais on sait
qui nous ça on sait que toute la réforme
enfin c'est que le nombre de cotisants
et plus plus plus assez fort pour
assurer en fait la pérennité de de toute
la de toute la tous les du régime du
régime des retraites donc effectivement
le gouvernement va sur une réforme
aujourd'hui tout en sachant
qu'il faudra certainement retourner
parce que justement ce coup de ce coup
de pinceau sera pas suffisant
il faudra aller plus loin parce
qu'effectivement le régime ne parviendra
pas à l'équipe sur du long terme donc
donc ce que vous êtes en train de me
dire c'est qu'en 2026 fin 2026 lorsque
les candidats la présidentielle se
déclareront petit à petit il parleront
des grandes réformes alors ce sera
certainement
pendant la prochaine fin pendant la
campagne un sujet un sujet encore majeur
on a l'impression que c'est tout c'est
toujours majeur bien sûr depuis les
années depuis des décennies même on voit
tous les trois ans on tente de faire une
réforme exactement on voit que tout les
tous les premiers ministres de ce sont
cassés les dents sur une réforme des
retraites et ce qui va être aussi
intéressant pourquoi celle-là elle ne
suffirait pas à régler le problème de
manière
un peu plus de pérenne c'est juste dire
alors oui c'est pas une grande réforme
systémique mais si 64 c'est pas assez
pourquoi on l'a fait pour qu'on fait pas
plus tout de suite là c'est
effectivement une question de de plus
sous différemment d'ailleurs alors là
c'est clairement une question politique
on sait que la droite poussait pour pour
aller sur 64 ans sur 65 ans pardon
Emmanuel Macron a donc choisi la borne
des 64 ans pourquoi alors certainement
aussi pour pour garder une
pas non plus se mettre complètement ado
on se dit que peut-être que 64 ans la
France a encore
réconciliable 65 ans c'était peut-être
aussi une manière de se différencier de
la droite donc effectivement il faudra
nécessairement remettre un coup sur sur
les prochaines années mais effectivement
ce qui est aussi intéressant c'est c'est
pour la majorité aujourd'hui parce qu'on
sait que on a souvent posé à la question
à Elisabeth borne est-ce que est-ce
qu'elle joue sa place au sein du
gouvernement
on sait que en 2010
Eric verte a réussi à faire passer ça ça
réforme est-ce que Elise Elizabeth borne
réussira c'est une vraie question on
sait qu'en plus le le
la majorité à une base de
assez faible enfin voilà historique
comme l'avait la gauche ou la droite les
républicains ou les socialistes donc
effectivement il y a il y a un vrai
enjeu politique ne pas aussi fissurer
bon ça ça j'imagine que Sophie marinel
vous l'a dit tout à l'heure il y a pas
non plus
scindé la majorité en plusieurs parties
parce que effectivement on voit que la
France
que cette réforme n'est pas la bonne
c'est à dire que tous ces gens qui sont
dans la rue pense qu'elle n'est pas la
bonne ce qui la font savent qu'elle ne
va pas assez loin on est d'accord pour
dire alors on est face à une forme de
problème mais politiquement exactement
et après c'était aussi un engagement de
campagne d'Emmanuel Macron
2017 donc effectivement lui tout à fait
la même promesse exactement
il a changé justement un peu les
paramètres en jeu il y a une crise aussi
du covid qui est qui est toujours qui
est arrivé mais oui il faut se dire que
on a quand même un pays qui qui a entre
1000 milliards de dettes donc on peut
pas ne pas se permettre de pas faire une
réforme en revanche effectivement est-ce
que c'est la bonne réforme on peut
évidemment se poser la question dernière
question est-ce que à l'heure où on se
parle cette réforme qui a pour but
quasiment exclusif de faire des
économies de 17,7 milliards en 2030
parce qu'elle est nécessaire je vois que
toutes ces mesures sucrées comme on les
appelle qui ont été ajoutés pour
essayer de plus de justice pour essayer
de faire passer la pilule d'une certaine
manière on parlait de politique est-ce
que à cause de ces mesures sucrées cette
réforme des retraites qui nous est
proposée sera nécessaire la réforme est
quoi qu'il en soit nécessaire on le sait
que le régime est et n'est pas à
l'équilibre il ne le sera pas dans le
futur donc oui il faut une réforme
après ce qui peut poser question c'est
pourquoi le gouvernement n'a pas aussi
tenté et là c'est effectivement ce que
ce que disent les indigas mais mais
certainement à raison
pourquoi le gouvernement n'a pas tenté
d'agir avant tout sur une loi travail
sur une loi pour enfin sur une réforme
pardon puisque sur une loi sur une
réforme travail pour favoriser l'emploi
des seniors pour agir sur les
cotisations en fait il y avait
effectivement d'autres marges de
manoeuvre avant d'aller sur le noir
réforme paramétrique mais qui était
quand même nécessaire il faut il faut le
rappeler mais effectivement il y avait
d'autres enjeux qui ont été un tout
petit peu survolés quand aujourd'hui le
gouvernement parle de la de l'emploi des
seniors la seule idée qui est arrivé
c'est un index des seniors un index qui
prend un peu la forme de l'index égalité
homme-femme
et est-ce que ça va être très efficace
et c'est aussi une manière de se mettre
à dos le patronat qui lui était plutôt
en faveur
exactement donc c'était un jeu dangereux
de mettre sur internet mais donc c'est
la possibilité c'est la c'est la c'est
le souhait du gouvernement mais
effectivement il y avait d'autres il y
avait d'autres choses à mettre en oeuvre
aussi parfait merci beaucoup William
Ploemeur on aura le temps d'en reparler
voir ce qu'il est possible de mettre en
œuvre parce que le débats vont encore
durer les manifestations vont se
poursuivre on retourne sur le terrain
Damien Canivez Damien vous étiez près
des forces de l'ordre
c'est tendu ou pas parce que sur les
images qu'on voit ça a pas l'air mais
visiblement ah je crois qu'on vient de
perdre Damien canivels à l'instant c'est
pas grave on va rester un peu ensemble
alors William encore un petit un petit
instant tiens j'ai encore plein de
questions est-ce qu'on sait mesurer
une journée comme celle-ci sur la
l'impact qu'elle peut avoir sur
l'économie c'est assez compliqué des
études enfin des des instituts
conjoncturelles l'ont fait par le passé
enfin du moins c'était des journées un
peu plus larges avec aussi l'implication
la SNCF et effectivement en 2019
effectivement je crois que c'était le
FCE qui avait tenté cet exercice là
effectivement j'ai plus les chiffres en
tête mais ça pèse effectivement ça
pesait assez lourd demain sur les sur
les sur les comptes du pays bon c'est
pour ça que on se demande parfois quoi
servent ces manifestations puisque le
gouvernement ne recule pas bien si on
regarde ça évidemment ça y est on a
retrouvé Damien Kany vs Damien
expliquez-moi vous avancez vers Bastille
ça a l'air de s'être calmé même si les
forces de l'ordre sont dans les dans les
rues perpendiculaires au cortège c'est
ça
oui absolument je me trouve à côté de la
solo de la CFDT pour être très honnête
avec vous je sais pas si vous la situer
mais là pour le moment on est à
boulevard de beau marché et c'est
effectivement un petit peu tendu là
c'est dernière minute avec des éléments
assez radicaux qui ont commencé à jeter
des bouteilles sur les forces de l'ordre
très vite ces éléments sont partis dans
le cortège afin de jouer un peu au chat
à la souris avec les forces de l'ordre
il faut bien reconnaître et nous on a
sorti nos pipettes de sérum
physiologique parce que ça commençait à
devenir un petit peu compliqué que ce
soit pour les manifestants ou même pour
nous il y a eu des jeux de gaz
lacrymogènes mais pour le moment écoutez
tout est redevenu plutôt calme même si
bon les
les casseurs sont se sont projetés plus
vers l'avant du cortège et j'ouvre
vraiment au chat et la souris avec avec
les forces de l'ordre ils vont jeter
effectivement quelques bouteilles
ensuite repartir en courant c'est assez
compliqué ici de voilà de de de de
d'évoluer dans cette manifestation pour
le moment
punaise faites attention évidemment on
essaye on essaie de vous retrouver
rapidement vous faites attention Arthur
bijota bonjour bonjour Thibault bonjour
à tous figata Arthur la semaine dernière
vous m'expliquez qu'il fallait
particulièrement surveiller ce qu'il se
passait dans les villes de province les
villes moyennes de province
rappelez-nous ça c'est tout à fait ça on
avait constaté en analysant les les 250
les 260 rassemblements qui avait eu lieu
dans toute la France le 31 janvier on
avait constaté des des ratios entre le
nombre d'habitants et le nombre de
manifestants très important dans des
petites villes quand je pense à foi dans
l'Ariège à Figeac dans le Lot si ma
mémoire est bonne je pense aussi à
Digne-les-Bains dans les
Alpes-de-Haute-Provence je pense à
Châteauroux dans l'Indre et c'est à dire
que par exemple pour une ville de 10000
habitants il y avait 1000 personnes dans
la rue ce qui est énorme 10%. non je
prends l'exemple de Morlaix Morlaix il y
a 14000 habitants mardi 31 janvier vous
aviez 10 000 personnes dans la rue ce
qui est quand même énorme et à signaler
donc on s'était intéressé à pourquoi ces
villes moyennes manifestaient on avait
eu Jérôme Fourquet qui nous avait
expliqué que c'était à cause des emplois
publics d'une forte présence des
ouvriers des employés etc etc on peut
par exemple dans certaines villes il y a
des hôpitaux et une très grande partie
des habitants de cette ville travaille à
l'hôpital je vois donc je vois que vous
avez retenu la leçon
il y a plus de syndicats par exemple et
où la culture syndicale à la culture de
grève et plus forte c'est tout à fait
cela l'exemple le plus le plus
paradigmatique c'est Digne-les-Bains
c'est 30 000 habitants et 1000 emplois à
l'hôpital donc je vous laisse faire les
calculs
est importante oui je parlais tout à
l'heure de Figeac si Jacques Aero c'est
de la sous-traitance aéronautique donc
c'est là où il y a une industrie je
pense également au Finistère aux
Côtes-d'Armor vous avez beaucoup
d'usines agroalimentaires beaucoup
d'ouvriers beaucoup d'employés donc une
forte mobilisation dans ces territoires
et puis dans ces villes il y a il y a
peu de cadres de profession
intellectuelle supérieure ils sont
plutôt dans les dans les grandes villes
et eux ils sont plutôt en faveur de la
réforme c'est ça en faveur ou en tout
cas moi contre ils se disent que quoi
qu'il arrive en ayant commencé par
exemple après un master 5 ans vous
commencez à travailler à 23 ans pour 43
ans de cotisation ça vous pousse tout de
suite à 66 ans donc le recul de l'âge
légal à 64 ans pour eux ça n'a qu'un
faible impact donc il se sentent
beaucoup moins concerné et c'est ce qui
peut expliquer entre autres
plus faible mobilisation dans dans les
grandes métropoles cette semaine les
cinq villes
lesquels et pourquoi des villes
qu'il faut particulièrement surveiller
on va les faire ensemble l'expliquez-moi
pourquoi vous les avez sélectionné
d'abord ça m'intéresse des villes qu'on
qu'on a décidé de particulièrement
surveiller ce mardi alors la première
c'est tout simple c'est Annonay dans
l'Ardèche pas grand monde ne connaissent
c'est assez rural pourtant c'est la
ville
le ministre du Travail Olivier du socle
qui a été maire socialiste de 2008 à
2017 et dans cette ville là on avait
remarqué une mobilisation qui avait plus
que doublé c'était passé de 3000 à 7000
donc c'est c'était massif c'est
impressionnant je crois qu'il y a 16000
habitants à donner donc c'était massif
plus de 40 % des oui oui d'accord donc
en plus c'était la ville du ministre du
Travail qui défend la réforme et son
propre ancien bastion entre guillemets
lui disait non on en veut pas donc ça
c'est une première une première ville
intéressante pour nous alors pourquoi il
faut la surveiller pour voir si là aussi
on continue à augmenter les chiffres de
mobilisation ou si ça baisse c'est ça
que vous la regardez en fait tout à fait
il y avait également et surtout un côté
un côté assez symbolique c'était une
ville ministre qui porte cette réforme
voilà c'était une ville rurale et en
plus c'était la ville du ministre du
Travail qui qui est à l'Assemblée en
train de défendre cette réforme alors
actuelle notre ville foi dans l'Ariège
fois dans l'Ariège ou paradoxalement il
n'y a pas une manifestation aujourd'hui
ah bon dans l'Ariège vous êtes planté
alors non non non dans l'Ariège vous
avez un seul lieu de manifestation c'est
soit foi d'accord soit pas mieux donc
les deux premières fois c'était froid
les deux fois suivantes aujourd'hui et
samedi l'impression d'être dans le dîner
de console
c'est juste d'accord les deux premières
fois voilà la troisième fois Pamiers et
la troisième fois Pamiers donc là on va
surveiller la mobilisation à Pamiers il
n'y a qu'un seul rassemblement dans
l'Ariège donc
l'Ariège une vraie terre radicale
socialiste une vraie terre on a
l'habitude de se mobiliser et une terre
où à foi on avait 5000 5000 manifestants
pour 30000 habitants dans
l'agglomération c'était un sursis
c'était notre plus gros ratio d'accord
on s'est dit fois
les
équivalents à Pamiers ce soir tout à
fait c'est ça on n'a pas encore les
chiffres bon ça viendra je vous rappelle
que nous sommes en train de suivre la
manifestation parisienne ce cortège qui
s'était lancé de
l'Opéra tout à l'heure aux alentours de
14h et qui arrive progressivement place
de la Bastille je suis avec Arthur
bizota du fil data non on s'intéresse à
des villes moyennes des villes qu'il
fallait particulièrement surveiller pour
prendre le pouls de cette de cette
mobilisation Langres en Haute-Marne
l'angle en Marne 600 manifestants la
première fois 2800 là ça fait largement
plus que quadruplé pardon donc pareil on
s'était dit voilà en Haute-Marne en plus
les autres villes à côté
Saint-Dizier Chaumont etc avec également
largement augmenté leur mobilisation
donc on s'est dit que c'était un point
particulier à particulier le bouclier et
où il fallait vraiment être très
attentif les chiffres ou pas encore pas
encore les manifestations Haute-Marne
ont la particularité de commencer à 17h
ah bon on fait on manifeste le soir
Morlaix dans le Finistère Morlaix dans
le Finistère comme je le disais tout à
l'heure 10000 manifestants 14000
habitants beaucoup de manifestations
autour mais une très forte très forte
mobilisation on a surveillé Morlaix
aujourd'hui ils ont défilé ce matin la
la mobilisation est en étant large
baisse c'est en forte baisse pardon à
Morlaix il y avait ce matin 4000
manifestants au lieu de des 10000
d'accord donc de la semaine dernière là
c'est la première fois dans les villes
qu'on vient de regarder où on a les
chiffres et vous me dites ça a largement
baissé donc c'est un indicateur c'est un
bon indicateur autre autre ville
intéressante Rodez Rodez dans l'Aveyron
verront Rodez ou ça a également baissé
puisque on est passé de 7500 selon la
préfecture à 1600 et la raison la raison
étonnante c'est qu'ils ont décidé de
diversifier les manifestations c'est à
dire un lieu de rassemblement dans
l'Aveyron à Rodez pour tout le
département ils ont fait cinq petites
mobilisations donc on est en train de
recenser les cinq petites mobilisations
pour voir si la Veyron a défilé en
nombre aujourd'hui sur biseautage
revient vers vous dans un instant
meurton sur le terrain Damien Canivez on
a vu des forces de l'ordre d'arriver en
très grand nombre d'une rue
perpendiculaire à celle empruntée par la
manifestation et autour de vous c'est
tendu
vient d'être saccagé je peux vous
assurer que c'est extrêmement tendu même
ici pour nos journalistes c'est assez
difficile de faire notre métier parce
que dès qu'il y a une caméra certains
éléments radicaux ont tendance à nous
empêcher de filmer alors que
effectivement les policiers sont en
train de charger les éléments enfin les
manifestants
ultra-violents on a eu des géants tout
genre j'ai pas pu vraiment identifier
les ce qui volaient au dessus de nos
têtes mais je peux vous assurer qu'il y
avait des bouteilles peut-être même des
pavés on a vu même des des manifestants
qui étaient en train d'attaquer des
boutiques à coups de marteau une
pharmacie a été saccagée enfin là c'est
vraiment la fin de manifestation assez
compliquée en fait poubelle aussi qui
vient d'être allumé par par des
manifestations par des manifestants
pardon et là oui c'est une fin de
manifestation un petit peu un petit peu
brutal et on a l'impression surtout que
les manifestants violents se sont
démultipliés en un temps record parce
qu'on a bien vu le début de la
manifestation que des enfin que des des
des militants étaient là plus pour
casser que pour crier leur
revendications contre la réforme des
retraites ils étaient assez peu nombreux
finalement ils se sont très vite placés
devant le cortège et là il y en a
peut-être plusieurs centaines qui sont
là voilà galoper dans les rues de Paris
a joué au chat et la souris avec les
forces de l'ordre en attendant voilà il
y a le cortège qui est scindé en deux le
cortège qui se trouve des syndicats se
trouvent en retrait bien évidemment et
puis on a l'impression que les policiers
essayent de de prendre en tenaille ce
groupe de Black Blocs qui s'est formé
dans cette fin de manifestation je
rappelle que je me trouve actuellement
au boulevard Beaumarchais je suis donc
pas très loin de la fin de cette
manifestation qui va se s'échouer à pas
qu'il va qui va aboutir au niveau de la
place de la Bastille donc voilà pas mal
de dégâts des poubelles qui ont été
renversées bien évidemment sur la
chaussée et et des policiers qui courent
un petit peu dans tous les sens
allez au secours 150 sur le côté s'il
vous plaît
faites attention on voit que les forces
de l'ordre mis leur casque en espérant
que ça ne termine pas trop trop mal et
on continue à suivre ça on arrive près
de la place de la Bastille fin de cette
manifestation parisienne on a des
premiers chiffres à 17h à 17h au Figaro
vous comptez si j'ai bien compris toutes
les villes ou les manifestations sont
terminées donc on a un certain nombre de
villes lesquelles par exemple on a on a
énormément de villes je crois que sur
les 250 rassemblements il y a une petite
50 petite une cinquantaine de villes qui
nous manque à l'heure actuelle d'accord
donc sur 200 villes à 17h là où les
manifestations se sont terminées combien
il y avait-il de manifestants
aujourd'hui alors aujourd'hui à 17h
selon notre décompte qui reprend celui
des autorités préfectorales à chaque
fois il y avait 607 000 manifestants
aujourd'hui contre 1,03 millions la
semaine dernière d'accord donc baisse de
près de 400 000 manifestants c'est ça
toute la journée on a aussi lieu entre
30 et 40% de de baisse selon les
chiffres des autorités d'accord bon
c'est une tendance qui devrait se
confirmer là avec ce qu'on voit dans les
dans les autres villes comment vous les
recevez ces chiffres vous attendez vous
aviez un communiqué de la préfecture on
recense chez nos confrères de la PQR la
plupart des manifestations et on voit
sur les réseaux sociaux etc dans la plus
grande rigueur évidemment toujours mais
on essaye d'avoir à la fois le chiffre
préfecture à la fois le chiffre syndicat
ça fait 3e mobilisation la troisième
fois qu'on réalise ce petit recensement
et ça nous permet d'avoir une base de
données et de suivre au fur et à mesure
l'évolution du nombre de manifestants
dans toute la France à gauche les images
place de la Bastille ça semble ça semble
être la fin du du cortège place de la
République c'est ça oui place de la
République et à droite place de la
Bastille on s'en approche avec Damien et
les forces de l'ordre qui marchent en
rang et qui essayent de repousser de
potentiel casseurs qu'on a pu voir tout
à l'heure Damien nous montrer certaines
vitrines boutiques endommagées on est
ensemble avec arthurbigota continuer à
parler de ces chiffres alors vous me
disiez qu'il y avait des cortèges un peu
différents
avec des enfants des familles ça c'est
toujours le cas oui et les syndicats
depuis ce matin explique je pense
notamment à Laurent Berger chez nos
confrères Delacroix qui expliquaient
qu'il voulait quand même plus miser sur
la mobilisation de samedi d'accord faire
une véritable fête populaire je reprends
ces termes et essayer de vraiment parce
que je pense que les syndicats ont
compris que les journées de grève
commençaient à impacter le pouvoir
d'achat les salaires à la fin du mois
des gens qui qui se manifestent et qui
se manifestent et qui ne vont pas au
travail donc je pense que les syndicats
vont essayer vraiment de recréer cette
ambiance bon enfant pourquoi pas amener
les enfants également les vacances
scolaires ce qui peut jouer tout ça ça
va être joué au maximum je pense samedi
11 pour la seconde mobilisation de la
semaine vous êtes aussi rendu compte
qu'il y avait une différence entre les
régions manifestent pas de la même
manière partout c'est ça non on
manifeste
c'est beaucoup de facteurs
on a parlé tout à l'heure des employés
d'une plus forte présence d'employés
d'ouvriers d'une plus forte présence du
secteur public d'une tradition
différente également il y a des régions
je pense à la Bretagne on se souvient du
mouvement des bonnets rouges
c'est contre les kotaxes de Ségolène
Royal c'était à l'automne 2013 ça
remonte mais c'est quand même une preuve
de d'une forme de tradition de
mobilisation en Bretagne et à l'opposé
vous avez des villes plutôt dans l'est
du pays je pense notamment au nord-est
où la tradition est un peu moindre et où
le rassemblement national a un ancrage
fort il rassemblement national n'appelle
pas forcément ces électeurs à manifester
et alors le rassemblement national qui
n'est pas le bienvenu dans dans ces
manifestations c'est pour ça que il n'y
a dans les régions notamment du Nord-Est
les départements où Marine Le Pen fait
plus de 30%, c'est eux qui ont un taux
de mobilisation le plus faible c'est
assez plus votre département a voté en
faveur de Marine Le Pen au premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle de 2022
moins le taux de mobilisation est
important c'est une corrélation ça
n'explique pas tout mais c'est un
facteur qui nous permet de mieux
comprendre le pourquoi du comment Arthur
on a des images de des forces de l'ordre
qui avancent assez rapidement vers
visiblement des individus du cagoulé et
en noir ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va
écouter on va prendre le pouls de ce qui
se passe sur le terrain et on revient
ici dans un instant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça marche
[Applaudissements]
attention derrière
[Musique]
voilà nous sommes effectivement
nous sommes en train de
nous
déplacer boulevard effectivement Julien
vient de reprendre la caméra et c'est
extrêmement tendu ici les forces de
l'ordre on séparé le cortège en deux
d'un côté les éléments radicaux et de
l'autre les syndicats qui manifestent
pacifiquement il y a énormément de force
de l'ordre ici sur ce boulevard
Beaumarchais autant tout à l'heure nous
ne les voyons pas et maintenant je peux
vous assurer que on les voit bien ces
forces de l'ordre elles sont là elles
sont présentes elles sont très rapides
très mobiles et le danger peut venir de
partout pour elle parce que il y en a
devant derrière dans les rues parallèles
donc c'est un capital compliqué pour
pour elle et
pour le moment les cortèges des
syndicats arrivent donc voilà assez
proche finalement du de ces manifestants
qui qui manifeste pacifiquement on reste
aussi sur nos gardes nous parce que
comme je vous l'expliquais tout à
l'heure c'est pas forcément évident de
faire notre métier dans dans ces
conditions il y a certains manifestants
qui tout à l'heure nous ont
[Applaudissements]
du vent nous arrivent en pleine figure
donc c'est c'est assez difficile de de
c'est assez difficile pour l'instant de
d'évoluer dans cette manifestation
surtout lorsque des manifestants sont
venus pour manifester pacifiquement
voilà
ça va
[Musique]
un peu plus d'animation
on va rester dans la manifestation merci
beaucoup Arthur bisottard on reste avec
ces images on met l'ambiance et puis on
met l'ambiance en tout cas pour que vous
puissiez entendre ce qui se passe et on
vient dans quelques minutes
[Musique]
mon téléphone tu sais des fois que
quelqu'un
oserait m'appeler pendant une parfaite
Olivier Martin
si nous sommes en direct Jacquot Olivier
Martin directeur de la rédaction du
Figaro.fr il est 17h30 9 nous sommes en
direct nous suivons la fin de cette
troisième journée de manifestation
contre la réforme des retraites on n'a
pas encore tous les chiffres mais
visiblement c'est moins bien pour les
pour les syndicats aujourd'hui oui
absolument enfin encore les chiffres je
pense qu'on sera en dessous du million
on sera probablement autour de 7 800 000
enfin je vais un peu mais hasarder mais
donc c'est moins de manifestants moins
de grève je fais quand même juste une
parenthèse 7 800 000 personnes c'est
quand même beaucoup de monde c'est pas
mal voilà bien sûr mais c'est le premier
reflux est-ce qu'il faut attendu dans le
vrai reflux il aura lieu samedi s'il a
lieu non exactement je pense que c'est
samedi je pense que là c'était cette
journée un peu intermédiaire ou bien
venir manifester c'est le troisième jour
où on va manifester en semaine c'est pas
simple pour tout le monde alors que ce
week-end effectivement c'est là où on va
vraiment voir si le mouvement reste
puissant on peut les manifestants
pourront se retrouver en famille même
sans avoir du posé de jour donc
effectivement c'est là où on va vraiment
mesurer si on est en dessous du du
million 2 qui étaient de chiffres du 31
janvier un million 270 000 de mémoire là
on verra je pense que là les syndicats
espèrent si vraiment ils veulent faire
une démonstration de force faudra qu'on
soit supérieur
à ce à ce nombre alors grand coup de
collier espérer
samedi c'est moins le cas aujourd'hui
pour l'instant nous aurons les chiffres
définitifs un peu plus tard ça va pas
tarder ça va commencer à communiquer
coup de collier samedi avant une pause
c'est les vacances est-ce que le
mouvement reprendra un peu plus plus
tard au mois de mars peut-être non c'est
assez difficile de le savoir je pense
qu'on en soit beaucoup plus samedi en
réalité il y a certes les les vacances
même si c'est une réforme qui doit se
jouer en 50 jours là sur son volet
politique
je pense qu'effectivement il faut tout à
la fois tenir la mobilisation c'est à
dire que il y a eu des inquiétudes après
la première manifestation attendre 10
jours ou 12 jours pour la suivante on
s'était dit bah les gens vont perdre
l'envie de venir donc pour les syndicats
c'est extrêmement difficile ne pas
lasser
les manifestants mais ne pas non plus
trop attendre il y a certes les vacances
si dans la stratégie qu'ils ont utilisé
aujourd'hui qui est une stratégie plutôt
de mobilisation qui se passe bien alors
effectivement on a vu quelques
échauffourés mais dans l'ensemble vous
avez raison
que nous étions habitués depuis
plusieurs années avec notamment les
gilets jaunes à 100% des manifestations
qui se terminent voilà exactement donc
pour l'instant ça se passe bien c'est un
signe très très important c'est que
c'est c'est canaliser c'est si pour
rester finalement dans le dans le dans
le mouvement dans cette stratégie il
faut à la fois trouver le moyen de faire
venir des manifestants et il faut tenir
dans la durée c'est absolument pas
simple alors est-ce qu'on va avoir une
évolution de la stratégie là on faudra
revenir dans un instant vous avez raison
mais ça m'intéresse vous avez parlé de
manifestations calmes question un peu
provoque mais est-ce que sans violence
c'est manif ne servent à rien et je
reprends ce même exemple si vous n'êtes
pas le premier à qui je pose la question
mais je prends l'exemple d'Emmanuel
Macron qui lors de la séquence des
gilets jaunes avait faibli d'une
certaine manière il y avait apporté des
réponses avait sorti le portefeuille
parce qu'il y avait des violences là
sans violence le gouvernement toutes les
semaines félicite et Gérald Darmanin au
premier chef félicite la CGT pour ces
manifestations très calmes mais
n'importe aucune réponse pour
revendications alors moi je vais
répondre alors je vais prendre juste un
petit peu de temps peut-être
effectivement en 2010 il y a eu un
nombre de cortège Ford mobilisation pas
de blocage façon 1995 et effectivement
la réforme est passée donc on peut se
dire que là on part sur les mêmes bases
on peut peut-être faire 10
manifestations de ce type là sans faire
forcément
reculer le gouvernement donc la question
que vous posez est légitime moi il y a
plusieurs façons d'y répondre est-ce que
vous dites c'est est-ce qu'il faut
espérer le cas où est-ce qu'il faut
espérer le blocage moi je suis pas sûr
que dans une débordement courage
certainement pas ça mais j'imagine ce
que peuvent penser ce qui nous regardent
ceux qui manifeste et la CGT ou la
Salette alors ça ne sera pas exclu on va
le savoir moi j'ai le le sentiment que
c'est une autre stratégie
on peut perdre une partie du contrôle on
a vu aussi que ça avait fonctionné sur
en 1995 à une toute autre époque il y
avait pas les réseaux sociaux il y avait
pas Internet aujourd'hui
faire une mobilisation
sous forme de blocage durcir le
mouvement j'ai envie de dire en tout cas
pour une partie dans les grandes villes
il y a beaucoup de gens qui sont
télétravail donc on bloque moins la
société que c'était le cas il y a près
de 30 ans même il y a 5 ans d'ailleurs
même qu'il y a 5 ans il y a des risques
débordement à partir du moment où il y a
des durcissements et là on l'a vu grâce
au réseau sociaux ou à cause des réseaux
sociaux on peut perdre le contrôle d'un
mouvement et puis troisième point que je
juge est le plus fondamental c'est les
syndicats ne veulent pas
d'indurcissement aujourd'hui en tout cas
ne l'ont pas manifester en tout cas ils
n'ont pas affiché aussi parce que
aujourd'hui c'est un mouvement où il y a
une majorité de Français qui ne veut pas
de cette réforme ne pas perdre l'opinion
publique ne pas perdre l'opinion
publique voilà donc et puis peut-être ce
sujet est absolument cette question
c'est absolument passionnante il y a
aussi c'est il y a un débat qui vient de
démarrer hier à l'Assemblée moi je pense
que le débat démocratique à l'Assemblée
c'est une chose importante on peut faire
évoluer le texte il y a déjà eu des
évolutions ce week-end alors c'était
peut-être la réponse en partie à la
pression des républicains on pourrait
venir parce que faut voir aussi
voilà mais ça peut évoluer aussi à
l'Assemblée le gouvernement si un
million unique personne samedi dans la
rue je pense que ça va pas passer
inaperçu les images depuis les abords de
la place de la Bastille me semble-t-il
avec un face à face entre les forces de
l'ordre et les manifestants qui semblent
se revendicatifs en tout cas contre les
forces contre les forces de l'ordre on
continue de parler
de cette mobilisation est-ce que
aujourd'hui c'est la CFDT qui donne le
la et la CGT qui attend est-ce que au
bout d'un moment la CGT pourrait dire
écoutez maintenant notre méthode nos
techniques
bon il y a un front syndical uni qui
aime démontrer sa force depuis un mois
c'est quelque chose d'important c'est ce
qui permet de réunir des manifestations
de ce type là
c'est compliqué comme question on peut
très bien imaginer que ce front syndical
se fissure là aussi je pense que ça
affaiblirait probablement la
mobilisation générale et puis ça ferait
aussi le jeu du gouvernement qui est
serré de jouer peut-être les réformistes
contre les syndicats révolutionnaires
donc je suis pas sûr que on aille
forcément dans cette direction
moi le sentiment que je peux avoir ces
derniers jours c'est que entre la
semaine dernière et aujourd'hui c'est
passé une quasiment une semaine entre
les deux mobilisations je sens que le
mouvement est encore le front syndical
est encore uni je sens pas une forte
fragment début de fragmentation j'ai
peut-être tort on le saura peut-être ce
soir après l'Inter syndicale peut-être
samedi
probablement plutôt après samedi ligne
de crête évidemment pour les pour les
syndicats parce que on a l'impression
que pour faire
faiblir ce gouvernement il faut dire ça
le mouvement mais en durcissant le
mouvement on perd l'opinion publique
c'est compliqué absolument absolument
compliqué on parle de ce qui se passe un
peu à l'Assemblée Martin étonné par
cette première journée hier avec des
débats qui n'ont pas avancé du tout non
c'est le risque
c'est le risque c'est l'obstruction
c'est je pense que ça va se régler je
vais c'est important c'est des bails il
faut qu'il y ait un débat il faut que
cette loi soit débattue au sein entre
parler parlementaires c'est important
je pense que la stratégie d'obstruction
n'est pas forcément
la bonne même s'il faut savoir faire
pression sur le sur le gouvernement et
puis je crois que je veux pas tirer
finalement des conclusions trop tôt ça a
commencé hier à 16 heures c'est-à-dire
il y a à peine 24 heures je pense qu'il
faudra attendre de voir si on est
capable d'examiner aller jusqu'à
l'article 7 le fameux article 7 j'espère
qu'on y arrivera
voilà parce que si on a déjà parlé un
tout au long de cet après-midi on a
commencé à 14h mais si certains nous
rejoignent cet article sec c'est
finalement le cœur de la réforme tout
simplement c'est l'article qui détermine
l'âge de départ légal à la retraite à 64
ans absolument
c'est assez fondamental le gouvernement
ne veut pas bouger là-dessus les
syndicats ne veulent pas en entendre
parler donc c'est avec là le point de
friction on peut regarder la le sujet un
petit peu autrement c'est
le risque serait finalement je parle
l'efficacité d'une réforme c'est qu'on
maintienne cette cet âge légal de départ
à la retraite à 64 ans mais qu'on amende
tellement le projet on sort de sa
substance et que finalement les gains de
cette réforme d'un financier soit
inférieur
au coûtent finalement et ça et ça c'est
pas sans risque vous avez raison nous ce
point parce que on continuera parler de
politique évidemment on est dans la
tactique parlementaire et politicienne
mais oui rappelez-nous cette réforme est
là pour objectif principal de faire des
économies et bien d'accord absolument
pour 2030 17,7 milliards d'euros mais si
on donne et on donne et on donne et on
donne à côté et finalement le déficit
risque de pas se creuser mais en tout
cas pour suivre c'est un risque un
risque réel
c'est-à-dire que les contreparties ou en
tout cas les gestes je prends l'exemple
du geste
d'Elizabeth borne annonçait ce week-end
chez un de nos confrères coûtera entre
600 millions à 1 milliard d'euros par an
donc c'est un milliard d'euros de
d'économie
dépense supplémentaires qui vont
permettre de ne pas réduire le déficit
comme on les compte bon de mémoire alors
c'est toujours compliqué avec les
chiffres cette réforme aujourd'hui doit
permettre de faire les 17,7 milliards
pas de réduction des déficits avec un
déficit à partir de 2030 ou au-delà qui
serait autour de 13 ou 14 milliards de
marge voilà il y a 4 milliards de marge
voilà bon on les a déjà consommés ces 4
milliards de moins donc on peut
expliquer avec les dispositifs carrière
longue avec le revenu minimum la pension
minimum à 1200 euros tout ça et bien
c'est 4 milliards il s'amuse et peau de
chagrin et plus rien exactement donc on
est déjà en dessous je crois aussi
faudrait le voir très exactement qu'on
n'a pas encore entre guillemets corriger
ou intervenu sur le les maires de
famille qui étaient qui vont devoir
travailler plus longtemps on sent qu'il
y a ça va être un sujet de crispation
peut-être du côté des républicains
à côté de ça il y a eu déjà du hola chez
certains républicains qui disent aussi
de peut-être pas aller trop loin
d'accord ne pas aller trop loin mais il
joue à un jeu qui peut être dangereux
pour la réforme donc comprendre
politiquement mais il est pas il est pas
parce que certains républicains disent
oui mais si c'est cette réforme je pense
à Bruno Retailleau au Sénat qui a du
poids au Sénat c'est le président des
sénateurs républicains qui dit mais là
il y a trop de mesures sucrées sauf que
ces mesures sucrées elles ont été
poussées en grande partie par des
députés des républicains absolument quoi
joue les républicains c'est compliqué
c'est très très compliqué hein
souvenons-nous ils étaient déjà pendant
l'élection présidentielle
leur candidats le côté républicains
étaient pour la retraite à 65 ans donc
là c'était très clair à quoi joue les
républicains ils sont dans une ils font
de la politique et de la Réforme je
pense que déjà il constate que les
Français majorité ne veulent pas de
cette réforme donc ça les fait réfléchir
ils ont aussi cet enjeu dans les
territoires là où ils sont implantés ou
là où ils veulent revenir de tenir
compte de la réalité du terrain donc il
y a un effet d'opportunisme la deuxième
chose c'est que le gouvernement la
majorité a besoin d'eux pour faire
passer cette réforme on peut le dire
tout simplement alors il y a d'autres
problèmes mais sans les républicains
cette réforme des retraites ne passera
pas voilà donc la tentation avec 49-3
évidemment mais avec un vote
traditionnel ça ne passera pas la
tentation est très grande pour le les
républicains de de faire pression bien
sûr sur sur le sur le gouvernement
puisque ils tiennent les il tiennent le
gouvernement
en quelque sorte et puis après
effectivement le risque c'est de ne pas
aller trop loin moi j'ai le sentiment
alors c'est plutôt dans les
les conversations que je peux avoir
auprès de républicain que je rencontre
depuis quelques jours qui commencent à
dire faut quand même pas aller trop loin
non plus faut pas non plus qui évite
cette réforme de de son contenu parce
que les républicains en tout cas depuis
des années
sont plutôt favorables à une
réforme paramétrique c'est-à-dire comme
elle est engagée aujourd'hui de la des
retraites tous les paramètres on ne
chamboule pas le système en son
intégralité ils le sont Nicolas Sarkozy
alors il est peut-être plus toujours en
odeur de santé avait été quand même le
dernier président c'est parti voilà et à
avoir véritablement engagé une réforme
voilà bon donc moi je pense que
je pense que l'alerte pardon d'alerte de
Retailleau est une alerte il faut
peut-être entendre chez les républicains
ce débat autour des républicains nous
l'avons ouvert jacoli et Martin il sera
poursuivi ce soir dans le club politique
autour de Carl meus
je voudrais qu'on parle de la position
de du rassemblement national on a parlé
un peu de la gauche on a parlé des
républicains le rassemblement national
dans tout ça n'est-il pas en train de
tirer les marrons du feu hier nous les
avons vu dans l'Assemblée nationale très
calme presque sage prendre du recul de
la hauteur ils ne sont pas dans les
manifestations
une revendique d'être contre la réforme
mais pas plus il joue juste pour
l'instant
alors c'est encore trop tôt pour le dire
faudra voir ce qui sort de l'Assemblée
faudra ce qu'il voit ce qui sort de la
rue je pense que c'est trop tôt pour
savoir si ils vont être les grands
gagnants
pour le coup la politiquement de cette
réforme des retraites parce que sur le
fond on les a quand même vus largement
faire évoluer leur leur discours sur
cette réforme des retraites je suis plus
très sûr de savoir exactement ce qu'ils
veulent
je pense que la stratégie du non
engagement dans cette d'un engagement un
peu original un peu particulier je suis
pas sûr aujourd'hui que ce soit
forcément une stratégie gagnante mais
franchement j'ai pas d'indice
et je pense qu'il faut attendre c'est
trop tôt en tout cas moi je peux pas me
risquer aujourd'hui à savoir si
politiquement c'est la meilleure des
stratégies cette réforme qui est poussée
par le gouvernement et les combattus à
l'Assemblée et dans la rue qu'est-ce qui
est le plus risqué à l'heure où on se
parle pour le
de quoi le gouvernement a été le plus
peur
je pense que le gouvernement
il veut du calme il voit cette
mobilisation je pense que ce qui aurait
de pire c'est une France qui se bloque
ou des débordements
ça c'est effectivement le chaos c'est
très difficile un gouvernement à un
moment à un autre doit reprendre la main
quand il y a un quand il y a du chaos et
donc généralement là on est obligé de
d'intervenir c'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui donc ça à mon avis c'est une
crainte importante parce que vous êtes
en train de me dire c'est que le
principal problème actuel c'est
l'assemblée mais c'est dans la rue qu'il
pourrait y avoir le plus gros problème
c'est devenait à y avoir des casseurs
quand il y a plus de contrôle quand il y
a plus de contrôle il y a un moment le
gouvernement se doit de remettre de
l'ordre dans le pays qui gouverne donc
effectivement on l'avait vu alors à
d'autres moments mais sur les sur les
gilets jaunes on l'a vu à quel point il
a été embêté fin novembre début décembre
sur les blocages des raffineries
et des dépôts pétroliers il un moment ça
c'est c'est un élément
complexe il en veut pas de cette
situation là parce que il est
aujourd'hui dirige ce pays doit assurer
effectivement
le pays fonctionne correctement reculer
aussi d'un pas du tout envie parce que
qui recule d'un point de vue politique
dans un gouvernement où il n'y a pas de
majorité une majorité qui gouvernement
sans majorité absolue sur la seule
proposition
elle est très symbolique si on veut
réformer la France il faut commencer par
faire cette réforme c'est très courte
campagne qui a effectué Emmanuel Macron
lors de l'élection présidentielle de
2022 c'est bien une mesure dont tout le
monde se souvient c'est celle-ci c'est à
peu près la seule donc il faut là il
faut la faire voilà donc
on va voir c'est c'est encore c'est
encore un peu tôt ce qui va se passer à
l'Assemblée ce qui est encore un peu de
grains à moule ça aussi ça la vraie
difficulté politique c'est qu'ils ont
essayé de négocier en amont de
l'Assemblée la corde des républicains
peut-être
en tout cas il y a plus beaucoup de
grains à moudre parce que sauf comme
vous l'avez remarqué effectivement à
lâcher jusqu'à ce que faire que la
réforme n'a plus de sens c'est-à-dire
quand elle rapporte moins que ce qu'elle
coûte là c'est une réforme ratée surtout
lorsqu'il s'agit d'une réforme
clairement économique là on veut faire
des refaire des exactement on peut faire
des économies justement est-ce que le
gouvernement Emmanuel Macron si peur que
ça du 49-3 parce que ça peut être une
option pour lui on dit qu'il ne l'aime
pas du tout
non c'est jamais c'est jamais ça me
c'est un passage en force en quelque
sorte de passer en force à l'Assemblée
alors qu'il y a un million à 1h30
face à la rue qui ne veut pas de sa
réforme passer en force au Parlement ces
politiquesment
souhaitable bon après les institutions
le permettent donc
c'est constitutionnel et certains est-ce
que c'est vraiment
pardon pour le terme démocratique
c'est prévu dans la construction comme
vous le dites donc à partir de ce
moment-là il est possible et c'est pas
le premier on l'a dit depuis quelques je
crois qu'ils l'ont déjà utilisé 10 ou 11
fois mais d'autres gouvernement
l'ont utilisé encore de façon plus plus
nombreuse donc non il peut on peut pas
lui faire le reproche d'utiliser ce qui
est assez disposition pour faire passer
un projet qui lui semble être important
pour deux choses probablement
l'équilibre du système des retraites
j'ajoute aussi une chose et à mon avis
c'est très simple c'est plus que
symbolique c'est nécessaire c'est
important là c'est je m'exprime presque
plus à titre personnel c'est une façon
aussi d'inviter ce pays à travailler
plus et aujourd'hui
on travaille l'une des questions le
rapport au travail qui est soulevé lors
de ses débat rapport au travail et puis
aussi on peut pas faire totalement
abstraction du monde dans lequel on vit
aujourd'hui il est très important
on est en compétition
permanente c'est un fait on est dans des
économies ouvertes avec des entreprises
qui sont internationales on est obligé
de tenir compte un petit peu des de la
réalité et que les sociales et la
réalité de la compétitivité c'est pas
souci par le temps de travail difficile
à faire passer cette réalité lorsque
depuis 2017 on s'aperçoit qu'Emmanuel
Macron a largement
mis la main à la poche alors qu'il avait
promis lui de tenir les finances
publiques souviens des gilets jaunes on
se souvient du covid on se souvient de
ce qu'il se passe depuis un an et c'est
encore visible avec les nombreuses aides
suite à la guerre en Ukraine autour de
l’étéralgie notamment d'Yves s'il entend
maintenant pour les Français on leur dit
ah non maintenant on ferme les vannes
oui le quoi quand le quoi qu'il en coûte
a été utile probablement et a permis
d'éviter un crash complet de l'économie
mondiale ou en tout cas des pays
occidentaux donc ce quoi qu'il en coûte
qui a été utilisé partout a eu son
utilité
pas de problème effectivement c'est
conseillé l'argent est disponible à tout
moment quand on veut et à partir du
moment l'utilise en permanence et bien
effectivement on met on demandait dans
les manifestations c'est quelques
milliards on a qu'à le prendre toujours
sur ce quoi qu'il en coûte je pense que
c'est un danger considérable il y a un
moment il y a une réalité un pays ne
peut pas vivre à crédit parce qu'il est
il se met à la merci de ses créanciers
c'est une réalité les milliards il tombe
pas du ciel on se met à la merci de sa
créanciers et se mettre à la merci de
ses créanciers c'est perdre une partie
de sa liberté c'est perdre une partie de
sa souveraineté c'est des éléments
extrêmement importants alors aujourd'hui
on veut pas avoir peur de ça un jour ou
l'autre on l'a vu dans le cas de la
Grèce on l'a vu dans d'autres pays pas
si loin de chez nous ça peut survenir
voilà et donc c'est pour ça que je pense
que
c'est pas non plus la bonne solution de
penser que l'État il n'y a pas d'argent
magique un moment ou un autre il faut
rembourser ses créanciers ou même
simplement à garder leur confiance pour
continuer à emprunter et donc les
déficits
la dette qui galope à plus de 3000
milliards non il y a un moment ça ne
peut pas durer vous devriez aider le
gouvernement pour faire passer des
messages parce que là j'ai bien compris
le message et depuis que le gouvernement
tente de d'expliquer sa réforme on voit
qu'il y a les sondages sont pas là
favorables et que les Français sont plus
en plus pour de plus en plus contre
cette réforme merci beaucoup jacolivier
Martin merci je vous laisse remonter au
deuxième étage parce qu'il y a toute une
réaction à gérer vous pouvez suivre
d'ailleurs le live texte vous avez
toutes les informations les derniers
chiffres on aura sans doute dans un
instant les chiffres de la CGT on tombe
sur le terrain Damien Damien canivevez
ça y est vous êtes arrivés place de la
de la Bastille il y a eu quelques
tensions tout à l'heure c'est terminé
oui
c'est terminé tous tu es rentré dans
l'ordre il y a un peu de fumer parce que
certains syndicats sont en train
d'allumer des fumigènes pour marquer la
fin de cette manifestation puisque nous
sommes place de la bassine et j'ai
rencontré une étudiante qui est avec moi
mais pas une étudiante française une
étudiante qui nous vient de Suède et qui
a été interpellé par cette manifestation
c'est vrai que ce n'est pas forcément
dans sa culture de voir autant de
personnes et j'ai le plaisir hi so on va
faire l'interview en anglais parce que
elle est étudiante en français mais elle
préférait la faire en anglais ça au
thank you for nothing my question merci
de répondre à mes questions
opinion instrude to sing this
is like this life United people
[Musique]
effectivement si elle avait l'habitude
de voir ce genre de manifestation en
Suède et apparemment non c'est pas
forcément dans sa coutume et puis elle
est assez facile et finalement de voir
autant de manifestants ici en France
what the retirement de retail
comme vous pouvez prendre votre retraite
en Suède
[Musique]
et make it to sexy seven
sa famille
alors pour le moment en Suède l'âge de
retraite est à 65 mais le gouvernement
aimerait le repousser repousser l'âge de
la retraite à 67 et elle pense que c'est
une une bonne idée ouais do you thing it
good to work pourquoi pensez-vous que
c'est une bonne idée de travailler plus
longtemps
en fait je trouve que c'est une bonne
idée que les Français protestent contre
ça sont your Yong
de Fred to work to sixty seven or made
Belanger est-ce que vous avez vous êtes
assez jeune est-ce que vous avez peur de
prendre votre retraite tard comme à 67
ans par exemple un Voice
[Musique]
seventement
on se dit à certains partis qui m'aiment
aimeraient repousser l'âge de la
retraite au-delà des 70 ans et pour sa
génération c'est compliqué elle n'a pas
envie de travailler si longtemps merci
beaucoup thank you very much for my
cotion merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à
mes questions et voilà vous pouvez le
constater la manifestation se termine
ici place de la Bastille en musique
c'est apparemment cette fois-ci
peut-être antisocial j'imagine on l'a
pas encore entendu aujourd'hui
ils sont et c'est très intéressant
d'avoir des points de vue différents
venus de l'étranger romain courtier
bonjour bonjour Thibault journaliste au
Figaro au service réseau sociaux je vous
ai fait venir parce que c'est toujours
c'est intéressant après des journées de
manifestation de savoir ce qu'il s'est
passé sur les sur les réseaux sociaux
notamment à Nice c'est ça effectivement
ça bouge énormément sur les réseaux
sociaux et jours de manifestation je
précise un peu moins que les fois
précédents d'accord on le verra on le
verra plus tard on n'a pas encore les
chiffres officiels mais dans les
manifestations comme sur les réseaux
sociaux il y a une baisse significative
et des postes et les interactions sur
cette journée mais on peut quand alors
oui parce que vous avez un système qui
permet d'analyser c'est ça le nombre de
tweets par hashtag etc c'est bien c'est
bien ça on a effectivement on a des
partenaires avec qui on travaille qui
peuvent faire ce métier et puis nous on
est en veille tous les jours sur les
réseaux sociaux donc on voit un petit
peu quand c'est actif quand c'est moins
actif ça ne ça ne nous bon alors on a
cette image elle est pas d'aujourd'hui
mais j'adore elle est pas d'aujourd'hui
mais pour la mettre en plein écran et
parce que c'est vraiment l'image sur les
précédentes manifestations qui avaient
tourné pour le coup dans le monde entier
et donc il y a alors on le voit
peut-être pas forcément il y a marqué en
anglais
la maîtrise de l'art de manifester par
le peuple français et donc on voit
effectivement c'était à Nice
ce plateau de merguez et autres
saucisses sur un barbecue mis sur des
rails comme ça on peut se faire son
petit barbecue continuer à manifester
oui c'est ça alors il est sur les rames
du tramway exactement j'aime beaucoup et
donc il est voilà il est la bonne
distance
partout dans le moment ça ça fait le
tour du monde bon on vient aux images du
jour
une chorégraphie anti Macron alors ça
c'est un petit peu un classique ça fait
quelques fois qu'elles nous font le coup
alors c'est les femmes de l'association
une association altermondialiste et vous
voyez en gros plan donc Manon Aubry la
député européenne France insoumise
d'accord donc là c'était une
chorégraphie sur l'aire de I will
survive vous savez la chance
98 et là c'était
avec Macron etc etc j'ai pas les paroles
mais voilà c'est une chanson anti Macron
sur l'air d'Halloween survive le
happening a pas forcément à me téléfuls
sur place mais voilà il y a eu quelques
quelques réactions sur les sur les
réseaux sur cette chorégraphie on vous
laissera juge si vous allez sur les
réseaux pour aller la regarder est-ce
que c'est du niveau de Danse avec les
stars ou est-ce que c'est niveau
kermesse avec les politiques bon il y a
des forcément des dessins de presse dans
ce genre de journée évidemment
évidemment ils sont dans un cœur joie et
là alors on est voilà exactement sur le
dessinateur donc Alan bas c'est de le
mettre en plein écran comme ça on peut
le voir
dessinateur gauche et qui nous dit grand
Dieu je crains que gueux n'est perdu le
goût de l'effort et il est représenté
presque en presque en monarque à la
Louis XIV c'est quelque chose qui
revient souvent en tout cas sur les
réseaux sociaux Macron
Macron qui se prend pour un roi on va
chasser le roi Macron c'est quelque
chose qui revenait aussi pas mal à
l'époque des gilets jaunes et en tout
cas ça lui colle à la peau c'est cette
étiquette de monarque que les médias lui
aussi assez souvent donné bon on a des
des tweets de personnalités politiques
avec certains qui veulent interdire les
grèves alors on était à gauche avec
Manon Aubry et le dessin qu'on vient de
voir on passe de l'autre côté de
l'échiquier politique avec la député de
Vendée Véronique BESSE qui propose elle
une interdiction des grèves dans les
transports alors pour le coup durant les
vacances scolaires parce que c'est le
cas on est en période de vacances
scolaires
alors circuler librement c'est une
question de bon sens ça fait réagir en
tout cas
ça paraît peut-être compliqué dans un
pays comme la France interdire la grève
surtout
constitutionnel tout ça bon pose la
question en tout cas le pavé jeté dans
la mare et les gens réagi avec des gens
qui applaudissaient des deux mains
d'autres vendent debout contre une telle
proposition sur sur le droit de rêve qui
est quand même un droit auquel les
Français sont attachés même s'ils ne
l'exerce pas tous de caricatrices pas
évidemment un tweet venu de la droite
une réaction venue de la gauche monsieur
jumelles député communiste exactement
donc dans les dans une comme on appelle
ça une salle de l'Assemblée c'est pas
une commission exactement en commission
qui pointe du doigt le fait que le
gouvernement s'attaque au régime
spéciaux sans s'attaquer à tous les
régimes spéciaux vous décidez de alors
ce qui est pas tout à fait vrai parce
qu'il ne s'attaque pas au régime
spéciaux lors de cette réforme des
retraites c'est ça qui est toujours un
peu étonnant mais il dit vous décidez de
privilégier des régimes spéciaux des
bourges déclarer la guerre aux cheminots
aux électriciens gaziers aux agents de
la RATP on n'est pas non ceux qui font
du pognon en dormant voilà ce qu'il dit
parce que on le rappelle
il y a des régimes spéciaux pour les
députés exactement les sénateurs et les
députés ont des régimes spéciaux alors
comme c'est eux qui votent les lois
c'est effectivement un peu plus dur de
cette de s'attaquer à leur propre droit
mais effectivement quand on est député
communiste est-ce qu'il est député
d'ailleurs je sais pas si il est député
absolument qu'on est député communiste
c'est c'est voilà c'est une prise de
position à laquelle on pouvait
s'attendre évidemment et vous voulez
qu'on parle de la déclaration de la
journée le buzz de la journée à
l'Assemblée nationale alors oui est-ce
que alors non on a ce petit tweet juste
avant un petit peu pour contrebalancer
donc ça c'est un élément de langage qui
est assez qui est pas mal revenu dans la
bouche des gens du gouvernement et
qu'elle a repris par ce twitos qui nous
dit comment justifier les régimes alors
il revient aussi sur le régime spéciaux
en disant que effectivement il y avait
pas de régime spéciaux pour les gens qui
travaillent dans le BTP ou d'autres
métiers
difficiles comme cela que donc il
voilà il faudrait remettre tout le monde
d'équerre
sont-ils à ce point pénibles plus que
dans le BTP voilà ce qu'il dit donc lui
il répond d'une certaine manière à
Monsieur jumelles exactement
et les régimes spéciaux pour tout le
monde ou pour personne exactement bon
pardon je suis allé un peu vite le buzz
de Rachel alors là l'énorme buzz de la
journée c'est la prise de parole de la
députée Rachel kéké donc députés France
insoumise qui s'en est pris en fait qui
est Rachel kéké c'est une ancienne dame
de femme femme de ménage femme de
chambre de l'hôtel Ibis qui était resté
en grève ou les femmes de chambre
étaient restées en grève plusieurs
plusieurs semaines à Paris il y a
plusieurs mois même à Paris et elle
avait été élu en juin 2022 député de la
France insoumise c'est ça elle avait
mené la lutte d'ailleurs qu'elle avait
ils avaient obtenu gain de cause de la
part de de l'hôtel en question et donc
elle s'en prend en fait tous ses
collègues de l'Assemblée nationale sur
l'aire de vous avez tous eu une vie
plutôt facile qui êtes-vous pour décider
de la fin de des retraites des Français
moi j'ai eu un métier difficile qui
d'autre que moi peut lever la main et
dire qu'il a eu un métier de difficile
personne alors c'est une prise de
position qu'elle avait déjà eu il y a
quelques mois
elle réitère et un petit peu
j'ai déjà entendu cette les mêmes
éléments de langage heureusement qu'on a
la qu'on a la date et qu'elle a changé
de tenue pour pour bien voir qu'on était
aujourd'hui mais voilà j'ai un peu un
petit peu la carte joker de la France
insoumise ils ont une députée
issue voilà qui était une ancienne une
ancienne femme de chambre c'est il s'en
servent pour
pour faire une séquence qui
indéniablement fait le buzz je sais pas
si on va les chiffres on est à 4000
retweets 12000 likes déjà plus de 170
000 vues en quelques heures donc c'est
on va dire la prise de position qui a le
plus marqué sur les réseaux aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup merci Romain cours et on
revient avec ces images en direct de la
rue de Paris voilà le cortège qui
s'approche de la place de la de la
Bastille on y va on écoute sur place qui
se passe on s'imprègne de l'ambiance et
puis on est de retour dans dans un
instant
[Musique]
c'est extrêmement nul hein
non j'entends que toi ah si c'est bon
OK
non Damien ne m'entend pas Damien est-ce
que vous m'entendez vous êtes arrivés
place de la Bastille c'est ça
oui je vous entends Tibo
oui je suis effectivement place de la
Bastille et le cortège est en train
d'arriver petit à petit là vous pouvez
peut-être le voir derrière moi c'est les
c'est sur les syndicalistes de la CFTC
qui arrive les policiers sont toujours
présents pour maintenir l'ordre mais
globalement les manifestations c'est
quand même plutôt bien déroulé c'est
vrai que on a vu des échauffourés comme
vous l'avez vu tout à l'heure sur les
images de de Julien Leclerc mais c'était
assez ponctuel et ça n'a pas vraiment
reflété l'ensemble de la manifestation
qui s'est globalement bien déroulé voilà
c'est vrai que on a pu noter de la
détermination quand même chez ces
manifestants alors est-ce que le chiffre
est en baisse par rapport à la semaine
dernière et écoutez moi je ne peux pas
vous le dire parce que on était tout le
temps sur le le l'avant du cortège et on
n'avait pas une vue d'ensemble de la
manifestation mais en tout cas il y
avait beaucoup de monde ici des jeunes
des moins jeunes on peut vraiment dire
que toutes les générations étaient
rassemblées ici et et manifestement ils
n'ont pas l'intention de baisser les
bras
[Musique]
beaucoup d'Amiens Canivez on vous laisse
suivre la fin de cette manifestation et
évidemment on restera nous en direct
pour que vous puissiez voir les derniers
manifestants arrivés place de la
Bastille
je vous indique quand même quelques
chiffres parce qu'il y a eu des tensions
tout à l'heure 17 personnes ont été
interpellées à Paris c'est ce qui
annonce la préfecture de police c'est
beaucoup moins que la semaine dernière
par exemple il est 18h19 la semaine
dernière vers cet horaire si il y avait
eu des affrontements c'était au pied des
Invalides merci de nous avoir suivis on
attend les chiffres vous suivez ce soir
la prise de parole de l'Inter syndicale
pour savoir quelle suite les différents
syndicats donneront à ce mouvement et
puis vous vous ne ratez pas le club
politique c'est autour de carmélus c'est
à 20h avec cette question les
républicains vont-ils doivent-ils voter
la réforme des retraites parce qu'il y a
ce qu'il se passe dans les rues et il y
a aussi ce qu'il se passe à l'Assemblée
merci beaucoup excellente soirée sur le
Figaro live on reste avec les images de
la manifestation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]